[Music]
foreign
store is fire on every level fresh
chicken hot off the grill a rich
marinade of seared Marita peppers and
ground achiote balanced with a splash of
pineapple all combined for the right
amount of heat Chipotle's all new
Chicken al pastor is where fire meets
flavor
[Music]
don't kill me
foreign
[Music]
Victory feels good
making them proud of making them pay I'm
ready
I'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the one and only Evolution
championship series presented by
Chipotle we are here at the fabulous
Michelob Ultra Arena at Mandalay Bay in
Las Vegas today is going to be an
amazing final day because we will be
crowning the champion for Ultimate
Marvel vs Capcom 3. let's give it up
we also will be crying the champions for
Tekken 7. Guilty Gear shrive as well as
Street Fighter six but that's not only
it
we also have some uh game developer
announcements some
we also have uh some surprise reveals
yes yes and many more all right I know
everyone who's currently in attendance
is excited guys we have Ultimate Marvel
vs Capcom 3 here today let me hear you
well without further Ado let's kick it
off to our Ultimate Marvel versus Capcom
3 top six
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
if it is
n't it
[Music]
responsible
this is my code grab my joystick and I'm
back on the road quiet
soon alone but I've been training I'm
about to break like a cold and this is
my fight
go I grabbed my joystick and I'm back on
the road and I would never stumble when
I come up from taking
the restroom
it's time to meet your Ultimate Marvel
versus Capcom 3
top six
first up we have
came Blue River
[Applause]
next is
liberal Terminator
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
put your hands together for more
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
give it up for your Ultimate Marvel
versus Capcom 3 top six
on the call for all the action it's Tong
and combo Feen guys take it away
[Applause]
and we are finally back 12 years after
the game's release and six years since
we've last been at Evo it is finally
time
it is time for Marvel vs Capcom 3 here
at evolution
and I have the privilege today to be
joined by the legend
the one and only combo Fiend I mean look
thanks for that amazing intro tongue all
of this wouldn't be possible without you
and keeping the game going for these
last few years everybody give it up for
time give it up for Tom for making this
happen let's go baby
I am so excited to be here I am so
excited for the upcoming matches we have
this top six is stacked yeah I mean
right now we are about to have cane Blue
River versus liberal Terminator oh my
goodness Kane looking for a potential
two-piece I don't think there's any
there's been any uh
like two-piece marble champion no he
would definitely be the first Marvel
versus Capcom 3 Champion the repeat if
he can get past liberal Terminator we
also have on the other side of winners
jabril and Invasion two of the top zero
players competing today but awaiting in
the wings on the loser's side we have
Monday and Spartan Throne Monday
obviously one of the best Nova players
out here today but Spartan throne coming
all the way from the UK what do you say
that Spartan Throne uh making it this
far was a surprise
um I don't want to say it was a surprise
I think you know but it was definitely
not my top six pick
yeah so it's a you know it's a pleasant
surprise I guess yeah yeah a little bit
hey look I I think Spartan Throne I've
seen him in the weeklies I've seen him
putting in the work and what I've
maintained is that now that he's in in
the same time zone you know like like
there's no uh handicap for him so now
he's here to hold it down oh yeah that
overseas delay for online that that
alone puts you in a different time zone
all right all right so we got LT coming
up first against cane Blue River this is
literally two different generations of
players came Blue River as we all know
the 2015 Evo Champion for Ultimate
Marvel versus Capcom 3 he's traveling
all the way from Chile the World Warrior
himself but he's going up against the
Young Gun the new blood liberal
Terminator only 18 years old he just
started competing in tournaments when
parsec started so you're talking about a
guy who went to his first major last
year and this is his first Evo ever
yeah but he's been cleaning it up this
year right and uh I think he's a heavy
favorite to take this the way he plays I
mean the funny the funny thing about
both Kane and liberal Terminator is that
if they touch you they they like execute
your character right it's a one-player
game it's it's literally as if you are
training mode against them yeah so it's
gonna be exciting to see if uh either
one of them could execute their game
plan against one another let's get it
going yeah for sure big bodies against
Nova but now these two guns have faced
off before back at CEO when came I mean
when LT was coming off a hot streak just
one combo breaker and Kane Blue River
came up as a surprise and actually
eliminated LT from tournament okay so
will he repeat will he repeat the magic
we'll see right now
I'm sure these two guys are itching I
mean you already know how the nerves hit
when you're on the main stage at Evo oh
my gosh and with this crowd here in
attendance oh man
all right guys we're about to get it
popping let's get it going let's get it
going
and Kane keeping it oh no
oh my gosh one player game begins oh he
already knows LT starting off with a
jump allowed himself to get air thrown
here and if KBR touches you you are
always dead it doesn't matter what
character you play how much health and
he doesn't use any meter it's on Fair
sometimes can he block it oh oh he mixed
it up a little bit he didn't go for a
jump okay oh but the grapple the grapple
always beats it and he's able to keep it
going yeah but the health of Hulk in the
story here but Tac infinite by Dr Dum
will erase that Health pretty quickly oh
yeah the great equalizer here but you
know what he's gonna go for the level
three keep it short you already know oh
but here here's the mix-up well wait
he's still alive oh no
1.2 million Health that's the advantage
you get and
going for the
ones even pushing it to the corner here
optimal every angle every position
always with the best combo can he block
this this is for a game oh and he forced
the bionic arm in the wrong direction
there oh wonderful game but the instant
overhead that's the downside of using
Sentinel you could climb him pretty
quickly oh yeah definitely the tallest
tree in the game
LT Spencer though this has been the
comeback character for LT as long as
he's got this character alive oh my gosh
oh barely oh no
oh man with the optimal Hagar combos
making hackers oh no let's start like
that oh the throw reset the finish off
LT don't start like that Kate is so sick
oh my goodness LT definitely gotta be
throwing the pressure now no jump on him
to start this round able to punish with
a doobie doomim is so strong against Oak
the Doom likes to step back when he
comes out all right he's going for a
snap he wants set them or haggar yeah
you have to get sent away the least
amount of Health on the team and opens
up a lot of the approaches and that's
definitely one of the nastiest 50 50s
with the grapple here leads into an easy
kill for him as long as he's got Spencer
coming out gosh one player game on both
sides right oh yes sir okay here we go
boom boom 80. give it to him X Factor
all right well hopefully you got a good
mix here you're a little familiar with
the 80ks right yeah
all right taking the Doom yes get the
combo okay yes like good Bible I think
folks about to get white oh yeah sir
that X Factor damage was definitely
critical in getting that damage oh and
then here we go into the set Play Let's
Go
now KBR even if he is able to block this
incoming here
and he is he's still going to be in a
very rough spot we got LT here oh my
goodness my goodness LT did not do a
bionic arm expecting to get grabbed that
far KBR seems to have the download on LT
he knows that the grapples are coming he
knows exactly how to punish the you
already know KBR is a lab monster oh and
then here's the last one now this is
where it gets tough because
[Applause]
oh my gosh
oh but you know what he still has a
chance here throw but so much so much
life on hack our side even with the
level three it won't kill yeah but
you'll get the health lead if you can
run away and that's what he's looking to
do oh no he actually goes oh yeah
because he thought oh okay all right the
world Terminator keeps it simple this is
going to be a win for him
LT there definitely had a uh a little
jump scare
oh my goodness 1-1 all right starting
off strong liberal Terminator if he can
get away at the beginning of the match
we have a match oh for sure right that
Nova has to survive uh to be able to
give Kane you know a run for his money
otherwise it's gonna be The Kane Show
yeah and I think Kane even if he lost
game two definitely made a statement
with that Haggard let you know I can
make it happen with any character
optimizes the combo but he drops it oh
my gosh
KBR just came down with the punch but a
missed input from Kane didn't have
enough charge there
oh and then Sentinel gets smack
Ed smash that oh my goodness now
full punish and hope there off of that
whip super and now we get to run this
back with the hard tag again
and this time there is no doubt if he's
going to be able to get the kill or not
all right and then is liberal gonna tag
back in there it is in tanova let the
games begin oh okay nice Kate had the
hard drive to get away from there but
didn't get away though yeah Kane has to
force the X Factor down and LT was
patiently awaiting in the wing for that
throw he knew he was gonna come back so
smart they're so smart right now yeah
for such a young player with limited
experience he definitely seems to have
all the knowledge checked in place
and just keeping
even need to use meter no
setting up nicely against haggar and
without X Factor this is looking Bleak
yeah and LT is about to pop that X
Factor real soon
there it is and just you know keeping it
nice and easy going for the quick one
for the quick combo quick kale he's
practicing this hundreds of times
but you already know how it is on the
stage in the combo you've practiced a
million times can still be a little bit
challenging when you got the nerves
hitting yeah but he kept it easy he
didn't even try to do an OTG there he
just went straight he hc-88c DHC smart
you want to just keep it clean keep it
easy
just go for the just go for the win all
right
Kane can he start off with the oh my
goodness caught him out of nowhere with
that balling jump light
this guy knows his team inside oh my
gosh he stayed on the same side for that
one it's like you psych yourself out
right you like yourself out you don't
know which way to block oh my gosh no
mix up mix up okay systematic
destruction here one player game status
one clear game status I don't like this
can't do it even have a chance oh hey
nice for uh liberal there but it's still
tough
that's gonna wipe out the drones uh is
he gonna be able to convert no that was
not too far it's too late oh and then
he's gonna X Factor yes Kane looking
good about to tie it up two two man
goes to the wire guys
okay now obviously LP picking up the
momentum the last two games but Kane
said let me get that back
game three
going back to the selection screen for a
quick breather sometimes guys you need
that the level of the future that you
feel there on the stage of men
that could be it
oh so optimal yeah it doesn't need to
waste any resources to keep this combo
going and convert oh my goodness guys
this is the thriftiest Marvel player in
the game never spends a computer will he
still get the good mix-up though
oh man and liberal Terminator swinging
for his life he knew that could have
been that could have been the losers
bracket right there
the scrambles are wild right now it's so
scary when you're scrambling against
Hope Oh that could be X Factor yes
that's the heart of the team didn't even
use the ground bounce to keep that going
how does he do it oh my goodness all
right well you know liberal Terminator
you gotta dig deep Doctor Doom Dr Doom
this is your time oh no I'm sorry bro
ggs you don't get to play we call that
the Evo winning mix-up right there Kane
Blue River guys
two wins away two matches away from
becoming a two-time
Ultimate Marvel vs Capcom 3 evil
Champion yeah it definitely would be the
first one the lp I mean he was swinging
all the way but this is roughly the same
result we saw in the past when they
played against each other a few months
ago I mean obviously Nova and Spencer
don't always do the best against the big
Bonnie team and Kane Kane Blue River
does the best he is the best Hulk
Sentinel Hagar player on the planet you
can hear the chip you can hear the
cheers from the fans you already know
he's a crowd favorite people love to see
that hole
yeah you know like the the low Vitality
of Nova just makes that start that much
scarier right because as we've seen air
throw anything that that Hulk does it's
over yeah for sure he doesn't even have
to waste resources he never spent the
meter to get that first kill not once
it's
it's kind of unfair but you know at this
meta you can't say Hulk is cheap right
well I mean you see liberal Terminator
do that to everyone week over week right
women after tournament he gets the touch
the game is over so
got kind of kind of got a taste of his
own medicine definitely definitely we'll
see if he can make it all the way back
through losers though
I mean obviously he wants that run back
and yeah I mean like like look at it
right there starting off with the air
throw it was already you know Nova's
Noble's already out yeah that's how he
lost the first game he lost the first
game by jumping at 99 and you have to be
careful because Holtz are always looking
for that yeah but at the same time
though if you don't jump if you're
trying to hit a button he might try to
do you know with Hulk he'll do the up
the up charge and then yeah try to take
that and it's game over options yeah and
99 seconds that's when Hulk has the
strong Advantage with Hagar assist in
the back too if he wants to call it I
mean as a Nova player you just have to
find Space put that pulse up and you
know hide at home yeah easy to say easy
to say but hard to do especially get
somebody a talented as Kane yeah all
right and then uh let's see so next up
we have a jabril
versus evasion a zero battle yeah
definitely a zero mirror both of these
guys obviously the strongest zero
players in the game today but jabril has
been dominant the last couple years he
has been beating everybody winning more
tournaments than he doesn't but invasion
is also super consistent as well evasion
has been top three top four at every
major in the midwest area combo breaker
frosties doesn't matter and this guy is
the picture perfect consistency but does
he have what it takes to beat jabril
today if Asian was able to do it at
combo breakers okay yeah I mean like
jabril uh from you know talking to a lot
of people he is the favorite to take
this very clean zero uh May Cry player
you know his zero clearly being the
strongest of the zero players out here
so you know it'll be interesting to see
who could you know maintain control who
could even establish control in this
fight and this evasion will be able to
kind of you know repeat the magic once
again definitely I mean zero mirrors
about who can strike first who can force
the neutral who can put their
projectiles out you know meter
management is going to be so important
here between both of these guys
and uh are we yeah yeah yeah buttons
buttons are ready fists have been bumped
let's get it man let's get into it
yeah you can feel the anticipation just
oozing off both of these players they
are ready to go their first match ever
be either one of them on the main stage
here at Evo
no man I'm feeling this right now you
know it's so it's so wild that like the
2-0 players have to play each other
because imagine that the brackets were
flipped
a rough run that would have been a rough
one for a game oh yeah for sure
all right and obviously both of these
guys are big zero May Cry players they
love to use that jam session no Doom
beam here so yeah Miramax okay
all right a vision activates first try
to try to establish control nice Dante
called her
all right oh okay okay evasion getting
the first touch will he be able to land
this are you gonna are you gonna hit the
loops is it gonna be one player game
like we said you can practice lose
combos all day but can you do it on the
main stage when it matters oh my gosh
that is what you need you need that
first zero win to establish control
but you know we got Virgil in the
background uh that's the other you know
crazy comeback character so let's see if
uh you know evasion Kenny vade this
death come in his way yeah bro quit the
DAC in the Virgil didn't want to take
any risks in the neutral not here at Evo
at least oh wow I almost got in there
nice block on the rapid Flash
and a vision oh getting thrown oh that's
all jabril needs is he gonna X he's not
an X nope he's gonna try to do it
economically
oh no no no that's kind of scary there
yeah you try to set up for the reset
there didn't work out quite all the way
he wanted
all right Ephesian keeping it cool stay
in the air and blocking the swords
and both these players now out of meter
you already know no so Gamu no swords
nobody's got any resources you gotta
kind of have to play this Fair yeah and
the real tagging deck ends off me
smartly he's like look if I have the
sacrifice oh he activated x with Dante
maybe he saw an opportunity there maybe
you saw jam session coming but you know
what sometimes you just gotta swing the
sword
and desperately trying to get that hit
so he could wipe out Sante but but look
at that okay
oh the teleport's going crazy right now
evasion already knows he's gonna get
some kind of Advantage before jabril
comes out with the X Factor inverter
when the X Factor doesn't quite work out
doesn't end up in the kill
no Jabra playing so clean it looks like
it's over here oh wow you can't block
that yeah little swords a little
teleport
yeah you gotta take your best guess
that's why we're in Vegas
all right jabril taking a moment to
gather his thoughts you know he played
that pretty clean
foreign
that's what we talk about you got to be
able to finish those combos here on the
main stage
all right but you know we're real right
now yeah just well taking the so Gamu
trying to get some of this neutral back
he's been kind of dominant and neutral
already he's getting the assist calls
the way he wants him
yeah triple staying you know staying in
the air keeping it safe and you know
just kind of kind of just controlling
right yeah just again I mean evasion has
to get activated trying to take control
but it's real staying in the air and
just being smart about it see now it's
now it's his turn exactly you just want
to wait your turn so that way you're the
last one to go first one to spend that
meter and waste it it's gonna be the
first one to lose
and look at that jabril slowly chipping
out evasion zero okay so now evasion
down to Dante and Virgil
is he going to be able to get anything
going oh you might be able to convert
that
real optimal there it is
cutting them down all right Invasion
down inversion this is his chance and he
do anything no you just get to watch
drill put you to sleep yeah just kind of
sat on the same sign waiting for
Invasion to kind of mix himself you know
he just picked the sign and guess can he
pick wrong this time
and just like that jabril
never giving evasion a chance to even
activate his X Factor to get started
two wins all right
evasia's gonna need to step it up uh
he's gonna have to figure out the better
way to you know establish control and
get that first hit and take out uh uh
jabril's zero because that's a story
here javeral Zero's been putting in work
it's been dominant all throughout the
last couple years winning just about
every tournament that he can
he's just one CEO as well coming off hot
like I said if Asian has beaten Jabra
before just this year
let's see if he can make a comeback
all right
oh this is your chance of video Let's Go
okay don't drop don't drop nice nice
little fix there to be able to keep it
into the corner here so you can go into
the loops hopefully and he's maxing out
the damage before the first activation
here we go is he okay now we gotta we
gotta battle on our hands jabril is
gonna have to eat this mix up here nope
oh wait oh my gosh did you see the
lightning I didn't see that I got hit I
got three layers too many layers I got
hit for sure
[Music]
oh but do you know the left right it's
my time oh yeah all right definitely
hurts to get hit by rap slash when
you're a virtual player yourself what
side
not I can't even tell you what side that
hit on right there but I can tell you
who won this game
oh my gosh
that quick into the DHC clean
Queen jabril clean 3-0 advancing to the
winners finals
jabril is looking too strong he's
definitely looking like the favorite to
win it this weekend yeah Kane definitely
has his work cut out for him when they
pair up in the next match
man man I'm starting off strong so you
know we had a 3-2 and then we had a 3-0
I hope that you know for the sake of
hype we keep going with three things
please yeah definitely I'm a I'm a big
fan of the game fives you know we want
to keep these matches close to evasion
though like I said sometimes you take
that one loss you take that one big loss
and you kind of build up that momentum
for the next one you know it kind of
just resets your brain and you go man
okay now I know what I need to do I
messed up there I can't get it back but
you know what I'm gonna get it on the
next one correct I made a few bad
decisions I need to clean it up
um or you know in some cases hey I
didn't really get my chance to show what
I got because uh I got zero so you know
like you know even the heroes can get
zero right exactly but you know now it's
his time because he's not fighting any
more zeros in the upcoming matches and
yeah like you know but let's take a
quick
quick look look at the highlights there
you know you see just right here jabril
in full control and it seemed to me for
most of the match he was in control a
lot of the time evasion really didn't
get to start his game play until it was
too late
yeah and just right here like you know
your bill never had to activate the X
there was no risk of anything evasion
never got to activate his in the last
game what side was your bro hitting from
I don't know but that Virgil definitely
took care of the entire team Dante was
just sitting in the back watching hmm
man
all right all right though that's gonna
send that's gonna send invasion they
have to go up against mudbank which
we're gonna see later but we also have
LT versus spark drone yeah I believe
that match will be coming up next
however uh we'll come back to that after
we take this quick break I stick with us
yeah
see those we're gonna see those losers
matches in just a second right after
this short break guys all right thank
you
Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code
hdkn236 and receive 250 fighter coins
with your order visit chipotle.com sf6
for defense
you got this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
be
the best
it's dangerous these are incredible
steaks you're going to be forced to make
Split Second decisions that could cost
you your life get out whether you like
it or not you are in this race
get in the fight yes sir Gran Turismo
based on a true story radio PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back everyone to Evo 2023
Ultimate Marvel versus Capcom 3 finals
we are about to start our losers bracket
sorry lower bracket apologies gentlemen
we used to call loses back back in the
day okay well what I'm saying on the
stage yeah it says Lose Yourself yeah
yeah but who do we have coming up talk
to him Tom oh man we've got the man
himself from the UK Spartan Throne
wearing the country on his back look at
that man representing carrying the
country on his back carrying the
continent on his back carrying that
entire part of the world on his back man
I'm I'm excited to see it Spartan Throne
has been dominant so much in the
European scene and of course he's been
entering those online tournaments
playing all that lag but somehow still
able to perform and now he gets to play
in person you get no advantage over at
this time and like I said he actually
made it here to Evo qualifying through
online tournaments going up against the
online guy himself the liberal
Terminator LT we just saw him take that
Big L against Kane Blue River
unfortunately he's going to want to run
it back through loser so he can run it
back against KBR yeah it was a close
match with those two three two down to
the wire I mean it was close until KBR
touched him but you know like but
as we've seen time and time again
liberal Terminator touches you at start
one throw from Nova one overhead from
Nova game over right uh Spartan on the
other hand we've seen him optimize with
his Wolverine dormammu Play One Touch
from him characters are erased so
exactly you know that that's Modern
Marvel Modern Marvel is a one touch kill
game it's so dangerous so scary this is
hype yeah the other other the other
character you got to worry about though
is Iron Fist Iron Fist is in the back
there and that assist is a killer silent
killer cause it's gonna come out of
nowhere and it's gonna have armor and
it's gonna blow your whole team up if
you're not paying attention man I'm just
thinking about Spartan man think
thinking about him coming across the
ocean and making it onto this stage what
a treat definitely you have he had all
his friends supporting him throughout
the entire weekend I'm sure they're here
in the arena right now cheering them on
but let's see if those cheers are going
to be enough to beat LP oh and look at
that LT aware of the angles that Iron
Fist is going to come out and going
under it with uh Nova's crouching medium
punch
man spark Throne is definitely gonna
have his work cut on for him
and Spartan very aware of that Dr Doom
beam going under it getting the first
hit is he going no he doesn't have
enough heaters oh he's gonna build it
though he's gonna snap going for that
Spencer nice block oh LP definitely not
afraid to push buttons there when he has
the opportunity and definitely not
afraid to let the arm rip oh yeah
especially when you have a safety AC
with Nova behind it all right what is he
gonna do here grab a message trying to
get a random hit for the wall bounce but
not quite Landing yeah I mean LP can
definitely take his time put the pulse
up and just chill if he wants to the
onus is not smart Throne to kind of go
in on him he's got the Wolverine yeah
and liberal knows exactly how far Iron
Fist is going to go and he stays right
out of that range tries to it's trying
to chip slowly but surely at Wolverine
Sparta can't get him out in time yeah I
have to guaranteed chip set up there
with a Crouch medium oh that could be it
no drop from Liberal but no picked it up
that's definitely going to be a kill
smart throw definitely feeling the
pressure there that's why he was able to
get air through
LT is looking like he's going to finish
this off yeah and then you know here we
go back into the you know two dates not
are we gonna even see two DJ now we're
gonna think
yeah but yeah he wants the positioning
he wants the mixer exactly but we have
Iron Fist left in the back yeah we have
iron in the back I can see what he can
do here spark plugs
and maybe the next game we'll see what
he's doing yeah yeah yeah maybe if he
behave to you then sooner we'll see what
he can do look spark Throne had to beat
Ryan lb the 2017 Champion to get into
this top six that's true but the thing
the big difference here is that liberal
Terminator will not let you play If he
if he can touch you right oh for sure
it's a very it's a very systematic uh uh
sequence he has going on and then you
know one touch all Mix-Ups Can You
Escape yeah right it's just one game
though let's see if he can bring it back
here
like I said he really has to be able to
put the pressure on Nova not let Nova
get started with the polls yeah and I
think oh my gosh I think that might be
it for a wolverine yeah it'll be such
great use of the plasma being from
Doctor Doom
and just like that
DHC and Confessor for just for that
controlled mix-up
are they coming yeah and I do feel like
one of the advantages LT has going into
this match is he just played on the
stage this is spark throne's first time
that's true he's warmed up he had one
game
oh my gosh you don't even get to touch
the ground you don't even get to play oh
man here we go 80 and then he's gonna
get nope in there
so optimal look at that
one meter for The Knockout it's
ridiculous
oh do you think just to be safe
and okay the Iron Fist have an
opportunity to play this time no he does
not
but once again LP just being dominant
here took even less damage in the first
game Iron Fist just doesn't look like
he's gonna be able to play a faster
outside of the assist I say liberal
Terminator oh he misses DHC this is his
chance this is this is Barton's chance
show us what Iron Fist can do oh and
that throw is definitely going to be one
way to get it started here oh my gosh
show them the power of the Dragon
let's go
what kind of what kind of Mix-Ups do you
have
oh
[Applause]
he's showing the power of Iron Fist off
that one drop oh yeah the power of chi
baby and Noah has to come into this mess
oh my gosh what oh my gosh oh and this
fit this is gonna go through the super
with the armor
oh my God
[Applause]
oh that was about to be it the biggest
comeback with the most unlikely
character oh rough smart Throne was real
close to bringing it back here going
back to character select he does play a
little Magneto as well but I don't think
we're gonna see a switch
yeah no I I like the Wolverine I think
the thing that's happening is just that
uh
liberals staying at the exact range
of uh Iron Fist assist and he won't get
hit by it he's not engaging exactly he's
waiting for the right opportunity so he
can call the plasma be yes that's what
he wants to do it's all revolves around
that
but LP is definitely eating these claws
here yes
[Applause]
nice cup no no
no look out one air throw and it could
be over oh I love the movement from
Spartan though this dormammu you cannot
catch him well done
all right oh but he used the uh
Wolverine assist so he couldn't tag back
in Wolverine but it's okay though he has
spells if he can just put the spells out
he could probably get a tag yet back
into Wolverine oh but he had called uh
Iron Fist not able to do it oh my gosh
okay and no Punisher from Spartan from
the scrambles are crazy right now but oh
no liberal Terminator got the hit going
for the Doom THC does he have it on
recall if he does PAC in for this oh
yeah he definitely has these lt's got
every tool in the book oh he should have
should have completed it there but you
know now Wolverine comes back in no okay
there you go
only put in BT because he's already in
the Power UP State oh he had to X Factor
there he was already in preservative oh
my goodness and mashes those Crouch
lights to be able to get this
all right keep eating easy you practice
this combo hundreds of times
all right and liberal terminator's X
Factor is running out on this Doctor
Doom this is looking kind of Bleak
especially when you have that dormammu
match up in the back
oh yeah we're gonna be able to get this
pick up here with the iron fist assist
oh my gosh nice Spartan not going out
without a fight why THC you didn't need
to my friend oh yeah he was trying to
get the guaranteed kill nice counter hit
there oh oh oh I understand okay Iron
Fist assist finally putting in work it
only took three games I know that's
that's the guy that's the 12th person on
the team you know he finally getting
they come in here make a play that's the
Rudy of the team right there yeah I mean
Iron Fist did his work on point but
finally did did his work as an assist
oh man amazing all right Spartan not
going down without a fight let's go
all right both players needed a moment
to gather their thoughts point back to
the character selection screen
you know you just need a few minutes
sometimes yeah definitely knows healthy
does bleed he knows he can get him all
right getting the throw here all right
well what side what side for the TAC up
no he's going for the snap he wants that
dude oh I would have went after that
Spencer personally but yeah definitely
Spencer is the the threat oh no
no nothing you want
it's gonna hit both oh Rob rough
stick drops but capitalizing look
liberal Terminator is so good as he
scrambles and just getting the hits off
of the scrambles but hey look dormammo
level three X Factor can definitely make
the comebacks no but it's looking kind
of rough
right here is liberal gonna this is
going to finish it off it looks like it
guys and this might be the end of
Spartans run here at Evo
with a little simple DHC here that is
gonna be LP moving on in this way oh man
and liberal takes it over his partner
man give Spartan a big round of applause
for making it through these killers yeah
traveling all the way across the ocean
just to get here to Evo making top six
congratulations to Spartan though
played really well obviously yeah huge
wallet went into an LT yeah a few
unfortunate drops here and there um but
generally speaking he showed off the
power of Iron Fist I'm sure we're gonna
see more iron fists moving forward uh
thanks to that display I hope so I hope
so Iron Fist is a High character you
know definitely got to show it off a
little bit that assist is dangerous but
lt's gonna keep going
believe we're gonna check out some quick
highlights here look at this this is
where Iron Fist was showing what he's
capable of right such a quote unquote
limited character going off yeah if he
was able to finish off this comeback and
we might be looking at a different
result here at the end but just uh was
that unfortunate drop with a level three
yeah
damn that was such a bummer right
because then that could have changed the
whole course of the the matchups right
because then it would have been uh 1-1
and then you know who knows how liberal
Terminator would have been feeling
inside with that comeback happening
exactly exactly how would he responded
but you know what no favorites here
we're excited for LT to keep it moving
the 18 year old the Boy Wonder himself
so all right so now we are looking at
our next match coming up yeah let's take
a look at this bracket here see who else
we got
all right so we have a vision you know
uh coming off of his you know loss
against jabril uh you know wasn't able
to really establish his Zero game plan
but you know here we go now he has an
opportunity to do so in losers he's
warmed up fighting against mundane yeah
even though you had that 3-0 loss in the
first round it's okay because that still
gives you the the slight advantage of
having played on the stage there Monday
though on the other hand dominant this
year as well he started off really
strong winning Steve false things but
you know he had some uh less than
Stellar performances at you know combo
breaker and some other events leading up
to it able to close it off by winning
Defender North so he's coming on here
with a hot streak himself a little
Victory under his belt before he makes
it the Evo let's see if he can keep that
momentum going though yeah when I uh ran
into him at the uh Mandalay elevators I
said you know what I think you and
liberal are definitely gonna make it
there you guys are the silver Spencer
Gods right now I like what I'm seeing
and uh excited to see them both make it
here on stage here here expensive fan
right all day baby
the original Spencer out here
I mean these guys definitely have to be
feeling the pressure I mean you're the
one that kind of shows them the way oh
yeah but be but you know they took it
and ran so optimal you know mundane
going with a slightly different flavor
using Magneto as his anchor uh using the
EM disrupter assist to get in uh and you
know he's so effective with his style of
the Nova Spencer show yeah exactly a lot
of people use the uh the coach Steve
show but Monday like you said switches
it up to Magneto and it has some
advantages it has some disadvantages I
don't think one is necessarily better
than the other it's just caters to his
style more mundane likes to move fast
you ever watch him blink he's one of the
fastest movements in the game is insane
and and I think I think a big thing for
him is that Magneto has that movement so
if you need him to come in as the anchor
he can make those big comebacks oh for
sure for sure and he can do it against
some of the tougher matchups that Doom
struggles with Black Hawk Eyes like
Morgan so you know he's definitely
putting them exactly
all right we're about to get it started
guys
who do we like I want to know what you
guys think who do we like who likes
Monday
all right all right all right that's a
pretty good response oh we got any
Invasion fans in the house
[Applause]
I think people definitely uh I think I
think evasion you need he needs to enter
some more uh weeklies you know or
something like that just to get just to
get a bigger you know a bigger
visibility I feel like you know you get
a little stigma when you're like a zero
Morgan player you know you don't see
those you know
big fan favorites as often that's true
buddy I think Nova Spencer is also
pretty nasty
all right starting off strong all right
everything's instantly activating he
wants to maintain some pressure try to
look he wants to Corner that Nova oh
that could have been it right there yeah
oh that's so good move so now he's gonna
be able to play the way he wants to here
yeah no meter on zero side zero has to
watch out one throw one low one anything
nice Tech all right
movement nice movement oh and the
gravity metric pumps just in the way
yeah I kind of jailed him there so he
wouldn't disabled he wasn't able to get
the conversion and Monday playing this
really nice really you know really
patiently but gets hit by Dante and here
we go one player game status is it is it
evasions time let's go
yeah
and here we go loops loops loops all
right can one thing block this mix up
yes but can you block the next layer and
can you block the third layer oh nice
clock and you couldn't block the fit
there so unfortunately here we go again
one player game status
will Invasion drop the combo world he
landed completely are we gonna go into
full loops Spencer gonna get no no no no
okay there we go yeah that huge drop
there is gonna allow Spencer to run a
month you already know and the DHC is
all he needs to kill he doesn't even
need to use the X Factor here and
Magneto oh my gosh Magneto with Spencer
if he's gonna snap I think he should
snap Justin be safe
oh see I think he might believe in his
mix up here obviously if he brings in
Spencer he's going to be okay yeah
a few minutes into the up throw right
there's a chance that even if uh evasion
blocks the mix-up and he tries to push
block he can get up grabs oh
100 of the time oh my gosh and then
Monday keeping it nice and simple
my favorite bionic arm oh yes sir yes
let's get it Invasion so dominant there
for the first 80 of that match but one
drop is all it takes to turn it all the
way around all right you gotta clean it
up evasion we gotta clean it up are we
gonna land full Loops here
all right amazing
he got it started early oh okay nice
nice one for the max damage version
Ken mundane collect this we know
Spencer's oh no last second left right
we know Spencer's the heart of the team
but but evasion did drop this last time
it got thrown for it so exactly exactly
he's got to finish it all the way you
gotta finish your plate every time and
once again he has a huge drop oh wait no
will he have the X Factor nope yes he
will yeah he knew that zero could
definitely convert there even from full
screen being pushed back from Shockwave
but this is but you know this is not
what you want if you're a vegan you
don't want to get my dick a chance okay
well like you gotta you gotta clean it
up baby keep it nice and tight and make
sure you hit the loops maybe maybe he
has a weakness of hitting it on on that
side you know some players can hit looks
better on one side oh definitely some
people are right-siders some people are
left-siders okay well if he's in showing
that he's both sided yeah right he's
just weak against faster
maybe he can't hit the Spencer side
this is and this is going to be tough
for Monday because he doesn't have any X
Factor yeah there you go fighting the
whole team to assist rough yeah Invasion
turning the back into the corner here
finishing off the easy way I'm not gonna
pick risks with any Loops against
Spencer anymore
Chicago
okay
all right putting up a fight 1-1 thus
far
all right let's see if evasion keep it
together here I mean obviously evasion
has been kind of dominant in the
beginning of these matches but he's
always giving Monday a chance
yeah I mean I think like with that last
one there you know if Monday did not use
that X Factor earlier then you know
maybe something else could happen but he
had to did he get anything here oh nice
box there for Monday Monday's Nova
hasn't really gotten started in any of
these games thus far exactly exactly and
that was actually kind of a sick mix up
from Invasion that ground throw you
can't really convert for any combos he
just sets it up for the Okie and right
now you have evasion just doing what
zero does you know playing a one-player
game and Monday blocked the mix up nice
blocks and mundink has a chance to keep
it going
all right how will but how will he Mount
his office which way is he going to come
in
oh and the team super here X Factor oh
my gosh that was so fast yeah and all
the blocks from evasion though had no
effect on him whatsoever yeah and now
this is tough X Factor running out and
oh Monday going in errantly in yeah you
just let that buffer go and receive
combo not clipped you know I mean you
know you could feel the desperation in a
way from Monday where he was trying to
really make the most of that X Factor
and he got clipped
and a vision just plain clinical very
clean not doing anything fast and just
making sure that he snatches this stuff
yeah evasion didn't go for anything too
risky on the mix up there against
Magneto he knows magnetos have a lot of
resources he can take his time right now
just kind of play the neutral the way he
wants it's just 1v3 no X Factor on
either side oh my gosh that conversion
was so sick stop
then a vision is playing yeah
I am not coming to the evil stage to go
all into not me that's right that's
right but Monday he's gonna have to hold
it together here he's gonna have to get
something started with this Nova because
this Nova has been a non-factor almost
every single time yeah it seems that
he's not too sure not to clear on how to
approach zero because he keeps getting
caught with uh you know just kind of
random hits here and there and and of
course any hit from zero could be the
game so you got to be a little bit more
careful yeah which is crazy I mean
Invasion must have practiced met this
matchup quite heavily because I think
zero struggles sometimes against Nova I
think that too
all right all right all right pushing it
a little bit more on Monday pushing a
little bit more trying to come at the
right angles nice law I mean like nice
presence there well that was his hit
that was his time his One Touch
oh he's gonna have to be careful here
leave us neutral play it nice and cool
oh that could have been a clip if you
went forward if he was a little bit more
uh confident with it but zero so scary
One Touch kills oh can you block these
can you keep blocking these
on the fourth layer he finally gets hit
here
just to get that and and that all builds
up a lot of meter for evasion yeah
unfortunately this is gonna be the end
for Nova once again he might not get
another chance to play here okay okay
you gotta block this Monday
left right oh no and this could be it
this could literally be it right here oh
my gosh an opportunity once again every
single time you can almost count on it
he has dropped the combo against Spencer
wow and he had to X get out of there uh
and right now it's looking good for a
vegan if a vegan can just you know avoid
getting touched during this X Factor
time uh the odds definitely go down for
Monday oh that was a chance yeah hit the
jump but wasn't able to convert
here trying to get in with these mag
blasts but this jam session is really
keeping him at Bay yeah and on top of
that Invasion just evading engaging with
mundane just keeping away and now now
this is the time to feel good about it
where you feel like you're in full
picture oh my God lightning at the last
second uh and mundane knows that this
could be it for him his Evo could be
coming to an end right here an evasion
just keeping it nice and a queen not
doing anything
doing what he's practiced hundreds of
times exactly now Spencer has to come in
by himself with no X Factor and he gets
hit by jam session as soon as he gets in
oh and corner to corner
corner to corner and there we go he's
about to activate it oh man
should be an easier Loop here with the X
Factor should be able to take this all
the way and invasion moves on here and
and look at that look at that evasion so
high because he's making it to the next
round you know
exactly that's going to put him in the
top for the bracket top four at Evo
already unfortunately that's gonna be
the end of the road for Monday now yeah
let's give a shout out to Monday for you
know fifth place
yeah still a strong performance this
weekend Monday because obviously beating
a lot of tough opponents to get this far
yeah and the biggest most stacked Marvel
tournament yet getting on stage here is
an honor and you know coming in fifth
definitely not something to laugh I'm
not gonna lie I'm a big fan of
invasion's game face right there I like
that you saw how pumped he was you can
feel that you could feel the passion you
can see it and
I'm talking about this you don't want to
be the guy who goes o into exactly you
know it's exactly it's a sad feeling to
make it that far just to get do stuff
exactly you come into the top six on the
winner side you don't want to just lose
and then lose again and he was able to
turn it back around he played a lot
better than he did on the winner side
like I said I think he just needed that
little bit to kind of get his nerves
going a little bit settle himself down
yeah and just some quick highlights to
check out here look at that mundane
getting clipped and unfortunately that
was the start of the end right there
yeah you know honestly Monday did get a
lot of Chances with Spencer kind of
getting dropped for every game evasion's
kind of fortunate he didn't have to pay
too much for that
yeah so looking at the brackets right
now it's you know the tournament's
coming close to an end we have winners
finals Kane Blue River versus jabril and
losers semifinal will be a vision versus
liberal Terminator yeah this is the top
four for Evo here I'm pretty excited
about who we have coming up
this is uh this is this is as stacked as
it could be you know and there's a
couple surprises here and there
obviously KBR kind of coming out of a
semi-retirement to to make it all the
way to the winner sign going up against
your brother no surprise there and
Invasion and LT has been dominant all
year long it's gonna be crazy to see
evasion and LT later because those two
are training buddies uh Elfie actually
went up to Michigan to go practice with
evasion uh for the week before Evo so
pretty crazy yeah no I'm super hyped for
those matches and we're definitely going
to get into them soon uh after we
gone's quick break
stay with us
at Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients in real kitchens when
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurant pickup or
delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we attendo are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each tenno product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
for Ultimate Marvel versus Capcom 3 here
at Evolution are you guys hyped
but yeah baby let's go let's get this
going we got winners finals coming up
here we got cane Blue River going up
against jabril
I mean this to me is uh you know Japan
has been playing for a while but to me
he's kind of a modern Marvel
representative but Modern Marvel
representative right and you have Kane
Blue River a classic
definitely definitely and you know you
have two Styles here one a little bit
more simplistic High Octane and another
one that's just more technical high
damage I mean sorry technical but just
very high damage but both playing the
same game essentially one player games
exactly exactly just different styles
like you said one's a Hulk main one's a
zero mean it's definitely the Opposites
me I mean but you know we say we say
that jabril is a representative of the
new school I didn't know he had been
coming here since 2014. he was only a
teenager I don't even think he was old
enough to drive when he first started
coming to Evo and uh man this is his
breakout performance yes sir yes sir I
mean k Blue River already has one of
these championships is he gonna get
another is it gonna be jabril this
Winner's finals might determine at all
I'm so excited about this right because
every time the match starts and Kane is
next to the opponent I'm always like
well they survive this well they get to
play right and I think if you know once
again if you're broken get away if he
can get the right guess at the beginning
and actually not get touched then we
actually might have a match in our hands
yeah Kane is like a train running full
steam ahead at you with his Hulk Hagar
team you have to be able to slow it down
or get out of the way yeah Enduro is a
good character to do that right it
doesn't matter how much life you have
the loops go on forever exactly it
doesn't matter if you're a Hulk player a
Thor player 1.2 you know it doesn't
matter if you're a phoenix player with
400 or less you know it doesn't matter
he can take care of you but you know
what Campbell River's been here he's
been on the stage before he's reached
the Mountaintop he knows what this feels
like jabril though the pressure may be
just on him a little bit more you can
see it you can see it on jabriel's face
you know he's definitely taking some
deep breaths really meditating really
trying to stay in that zone KBR just
there like yeah I'm ready to get this
exactly right daveyard's just laughing
it up giving directions to the bathroom
to the production guy it doesn't matter
you know he's here chilling he's out
I've been here before I know what it's
like yeah he's like I'm just gonna do
what I do you know round start game over
you know
look at that he doesn't care he's
checking his Twitter his Instagram
whatever he wants to do he's relaxed
here he's at home on the stage can
Jabrill pull this off to get his I am
enjoying the tension though I'm enjoying
how like you know one is so relaxed one
is so chill and the other one is just
like
zen master this is the this is my chance
this is my breakout you know I might get
that Trophy and we are about to kick it
off this is about to be an exciting
winners finals guys oh yeah no surprises
on the picks obviously we already know
what these guys play
like I said very opposite Styles here
but I do believe the advantage on the
matchup is hugely on jabrill's side
especially if that Hulk goes if jabril
wins the point battle he wins the war
definitely definitely definitely all
right
and great a great movement there from
jabril he got away now he can establish
his game plan with zero and just kind of
annoyed right like it's so tough for
Kane to get in right now yeah that's so
good move definitely setting them back
here but now with that so get moved on
KBR may be able to call some drones here
trying to work his way in but jabril
timing all of his moves so well and
perfectly spaced and I really like how
jabril used the dash to push the screen
a little bit more to give him more space
so that you know Kate has to work just
that much harder exactly okay
[Music]
let's go
characters
oh man KBR was forced to tag into haggar
because Hulk was losing so much health
but KBR does not care about matchups if
kvr cared about matchups he would be an
evil Champion today and here's the
question will uh Dante even get to play
no it doesn't look like him force is the
situation so you can get that free air
throw the heart oh my gosh into the hard
tag is this this to me feels like new
KBR Tech I mean the man is already
optimizing his team but it just gets
better and better and the DHC is gonna
have to do two dhcs yes he is but that's
right into the mix-up packed back in
into Haggard no oh that's kind of scary
leaving sentinel oh my gosh the armor
the frames from going to the Devil
Trigger allowed Kane to get the Crouch
medium and that's gonna do it KBR is
gonna take the first game here in
winners finals I just love how KBR knows
all the hits duns deterioration and
everything and on his combo so he's
always doing the the most optimal
Ralph's off any touch all the time
it's that's true Mastery oh yeah jabril
gonna need to recollect himself here a
little bit KBR is just laughing having a
good time he knows where he's at
laughs
I just like how KBR he just knows he's
like I know this is uphill battle but I
know at the same time you know if I
touch you it's over exactly exactly
you're you're playing cat and mouse but
that Mouse is really fast but you know
once you catch him what are you gonna do
I just love I just love how you know
kbr's team in his hands is cheap okay
I'm gonna go out there and say it right
yeah because it doesn't let you play uh
but we love it but then if you see Zero
do it we hate it
oh my gosh he's closing in oh no
and throw nicely uh you know creating
space there pushing pain back but
jumping in slowly but surely Kate is
closing it in oh my gosh one air
throwing it's over what okay you broke
out the hit now it's his time exactly
Jabra obviously an execution monster
gonna have no problems here hopefully
finishing super clean zero play he hits
the loose with 100 you know accuracy
every time Ken Sentinel even land can he
do anything oh and he does all right and
uh he got hit might convert there yeah
and I think whoa whoa uncharacteristic
drop from jabril but he's able to pick
it right back up and you saw that Kane
called in haggar but I believe haggar
got hit by Virgil the assist traded and
uh yeah it didn't do anything exactly
Larry Edison does have some weak points
it's not as strong as the point Larry oh
is this going to be a perfect
yeah yeah you're right you're right
could perfect
we'll see you here we'll see but you
know what KBR unfortunately he's gonna
already have to start thinking about
game three here because game two is
basically over
yeah yeah
probably block the Drone and uh man it's
your Brill taking that pretty cleanly
all he needed was that one touch right
I'm just telling you we have two one
player game Masters on stage right now
exactly because if KBR gets the first
touch you know what you're not getting
out either that's you know you lose the
point character that said you lost the
war
yeah I mean obviously jabril has been
starting off neutral very strong in
every game kabion was actually doing
better in game two in the neutral but as
he worked his way in jabril is kind of
looking forward to that and found the
opportunity to get that game too yeah
KBR jumped up one for the air throw and
got hit by a pizza cutter and then that
was all she wrote right exactly oh man I
you know oh no
physical drones not helping out Kane
this time yeah KBR got the 99 second
start he wanted but he just wasn't able
to capitalize all the way and now it's
jabril's turn
and this could be the start of the end
of this game already because jump bro
doesn't want to let you play guys he's
going to activate right now and he's
going to hit the loops and the question
is
will Sentinel have a chance to do
anything
yeah he does have the hard drive option
but jam session locks you down pretty
strongly and this time able to get the
cross up with the jam session
that you can't get you can't even use
hard drive to get out when he crosses
you up exactly and jabriel playing this
very clinically very cleanly not
dropping a thing
character after character getting wiped
it's a one-player game guys and haggar
is gonna be in for the toughest Battle
of his life going up against a zero-made
crime team that has X Factor on top
oh and he's and you know came just went
for that bit of damage off the Dante
assist just trying to get damaged where
he can slowly closing in trying his best
but these assists are just keeping him
forced out
he's gonna do it again he's gonna get
some damage on Virgil this time and zero
gets popped too
oh my gosh the reads are so hard over
here yeah just a little bit far away oh
my gosh air pipe air pipe and never
gonna have zero explode oh my gosh okay
okay we got a game guys we got a game
Dante can you can you stop this
oh it's looking a little scary here
Lariat in the corner and his X Factor
level three damage he's gonna get the
combo
let's go okay now we got something that
looks kind of even oh hell breaker D9
healthy this is what we want to see this
is what the crowd wants to see the
stolen games I can't really say stolen
but these haggar comebacks came just
showing you he's not giving up this
gotta be the best haggar in the world
that's the second comeback we've seen
with solo Hagar In This tournament from
cane Blue River
I love it I love it man and you know
jabril is like how did that one slip you
know it's haggar how did he even get
close to me I had two assists I was
controlling that pushing push him away
controlling the screen yeah he had all
the resources and the team on his side
but you know that's the that's the
beauty of how KBR plays you're never
safe you're never all the way done until
it says KO on the screen
you know you know I of all his three
characters which one do you think is the
one that might be the weakest level 3 X
Factor character oh and honestly it's
probably Hulk right yeah hulkets no
speed boost there he just gets a huge
damage boost which he technically
doesn't really need since he already
does so much damage anyway
so but you know what I mean KBR can make
it happen with any character at this
point
oh my gosh all right
oh he's getting pinned down Ultra Brew I
gotta survive okay your girl gets the
hit yeah coming down with that Paul and
H there the pizza cutter yeah and now
taking it Taking Kane corner to corner
and here we go it's a movie guys it's a
one-player game movie Let's Go
like yeah jabro is the only one with the
play and pause button here it's up to
him to complete it all the way and and
hope having so much life forcing so many
resources out of zero but let's see if
uh oh he wasn't Corner this time so he's
able to get away and start his game and
yeah now hack okay well I was gonna say
we're gonna see Sentinel play for the
first time really but maybe not yeah but
are we though yeah okay so
very clean uh we're all gonna Max the
damage out gain as much meter as
possible before activating together and
there we go
cleaning them up cleaning them up all
right haggar is this your chance for
another comeback turbo wants no part of
it he had to back up yeah this time he's
just gonna let Dante take the damage
there Buster from far away
and and look at this look at this Kane
slowly
slowly methodically trying to get his
way in there taking block damage it's
okay as jabril slowly gets Edge into the
corner
it's getting a little scary because all
it takes is one One Touch
that's right but this time it's jabriel
that gets the touch here able to finish
it off
and we're going to two two oh we're
going to a last game scenario
as we already know jabril not going out
without a fight a lot of people would
say that this is jabril's EVO to lose
yeah but I mean I don't think people
were taking into account kvr coming out
of the Woodworks and showing you that
he's still a threat he's an evil champ
for a reason exactly he's only had two
major appearances in 2023. he showed up
in Evo Japan and he showed up at CEO he
really hasn't competed in a lot of
brackets this year but I guess that
doesn't really matter too much when
you're an old Pro like KBR
all right we are about to head into the
third match you know players Gathering
their thoughts hydrating doing what they
need to do
and this is for this is for Grant final
exactly getting in on the Winner's side
of grand finals obviously a huge
Advantage here it's like having home
field advantage in the playoffs you know
pop two for sure damn and jabril getting
the touch
and like right there he has two bars you
know gonna extend the combo as much as
possible okay now we haven't seen a lot
of executional Errors from jabril so I
have no doubt he's gonna be able to
finish this when it matters right
another activation and ah man hope not
getting a chance to play unfortunate but
Sentinel however might have a chance
will kvr have a chance to like let's
open up the ground oh and the air throw
rough corner to corner carry
yeah this Ted can has only had one
purpose and it's for drones other than
that he's done nothing here but build
meter for jabril oh and jabriel playing
very cleanly right now not dropping a
single thing
oh my gosh is this a perfect this time
it might be I don't think he's even had
to block a drone yeah in the beginning
and he got away yeah this could be a
perfect guy yeah with two meter and X
Factor on Deck here and you know Kane
can only hope that Joe Bro would drop it
but turbo has shown us he is very
cleanly executing gosh this is so unfair
that time
oh no perfect this time but you know
what perfect enough wow Andrew Brill
such that convincingly showing you that
if he gets a touch you don't get to play
KBR though putting up a fantastic fight
taking him to the Limit 3-2 exactly KBR
is still gonna have a chance at the run
back here if he can win and lose his
finals but jabriel look at your bro
right there oh that heavy that heavy
sigh of relief
knowing that he's going to Grand Final
stamping his ticket top two exactly
guaranteed exactly like I said a lot of
people before coming into this week
we're saying that this is jabril's EVO
to lose and it's looking like it right
now he's collecting himself he's got his
calm you know he's already got his
confidence up from beating KBR which
might have been the biggest threat in
this bracket for him yeah and having
that you know now that you got to Grand
in the winter side you have a set that
you could potentially give up to get
information on the opponent who comes
back to you exactly getting to sit
around and wait watch a little bit yeah
just look at this unfortunate you know
mid-screen mix up what side does it hit
on who knows and Ultra Pro needs his a
touch one player game status miss haggar
here you know it's just been wreaking
havoc haul tournament long able to get a
cut back earlier but you know not enough
in the later on the later games to be
able to close out the set yeah the mayor
got impeached man he's out it's over for
him so as you can see here at the
brackets jabril making it to the Grand
finals now we're gonna move on to the
loser semifinal where we have evasion
going up against liberal Terminator
yeah and of course the winner that is
gonna have to go up against KBR like he
said I mean evasion and LT they aren't
training Partners they just train
together for a whole week in Michigan
now they're coming here and having to
compete against each other obviously
hard work has been paying off for both
of these two but only one of these guys
can move on to the next round yeah and
as you saw in the previous match you
know evasion had to fight a different
Nova Spencer Master now he has to fight
another Nova Spencer Master right but as
we've seen with zero one touch kills you
don't get to play but as we've seen with
liberal Terminator if nobody could touch
him the game could also be over that's
the meta now unfortunately if you don't
have that on your team you're not going
to compete at the highest level so you
definitely got to have those combos you
got to have that Tech and your team has
to revolve around being able to get
those One Touch kills and then get those
50 50s in the corner on the incoming and
that's it yeah and we saw that you know
in the last match that Monday you know
he was he was a little more conservative
in his approach and it couldn't really
find a way to approach evasion and his
Nova was a non-factor essentially so you
know we'll see if it's a little bit
different here with liberal Terminator
yeah both of these guys this is their
first Evo ever for both of these players
and here they are in the top six this is
the seventh time Marvel has been here at
Evo as a main game and both of these
guys being in top four actually on their
first time is such a huge accomplishment
for both of these players yeah this is
the tournament that you def like will go
down in history and being a part of that
being top four just shows that you know
their hard work has paid off that you
know they're playing their a game I like
these little Esports poses they're doing
though you know what I mean the first
time they're getting to do this this is
uh it's pretty fun the armed cross I
mean like does this production tell them
to do that sometimes I wonder because
you know
you could do funnier stuff but you know
a liberal Terminator looks super hard
right there
Invasion looks pretty hard too man you
know and uh I'm excited to see this
match go down I'm ready to see these
guys throw hands yeah both of these guys
very young obviously LP only 18 years
old but somehow being one of the best
players in the world in the 12 year old
game hahaha
so yeah players testing out their
controls the movement you could see
there I don't know I'm pretty hyped for
this honestly
and how are we feeling about this guys
who who likes evasion who likes evasion
out here
I mean you gotta like them now I know I
asked that last time but there was there
wasn't too much fanfare but he just won
his round he got to give him some love
and liberal Terminator how we like that
um
okay we got a clear favorite here the
Young Gun they're going for him oh yeah
this guy right here you know he actually
at Cobble breaker he wore a gorilla suit
I love it
he said he plays like a gorilla so he
wanted to dress like one too
yeah I really I I just really like how
uh LT pushes he really pushes the pace
when he plays and you know it's up it's
gonna be up to evasion to uh not get
bodied at the start
both of these guys know each other so
well they played each other so many
times over the last couple years online
offline majors at invasions house it
doesn't matter now they get to do it
here on the main stage and show who is
the best
it's always crazy when you have to fight
your friend on on the final stage man
like that that's wild right this could
ruin friendships okay
and you gotta hold that one forever no
matter no matter what happens for the
rest of the games for the rest of their
lives this is the one that's always
going to matter oh and look at that
Invasion getting that first first hit
early start pushing the advantage
oh but not enough Peter had to go for a
reset
yeah not a strong reset attempt there
allowing Noble to get back into it but
he goes right back out after so good
move ooh and we'll liberal no LT can't
block oh but with the cops there all
right doesn't hit anybody lucky for
evasion they're able to evade that
bionic arm yeah but not LT has a chance
to play we already know that Spencer
that Spencer is a threat no he is not I
take it off back no threat anymore
Invasion looking like he's gonna take
him out real quick yeah and then if he
just still has these yeah the original
assist then going at this again
oh man and oh my gosh the small drops
oh but LT can't get Dr Newman because he
didn't have either but it doesn't matter
oh Spencer with that
you know games with the games with your
friends are always a little bit
different than games against other
people you know yeah because they know
your Tendencies they might have like you
know some insight on you things like
that so you gotta play a little
different
but you know evasion showing that no I'm
still gonna play my game I'm still I'm
still gonna do what I do
what I've done to you in practice is
casual all of that I'm doing it to you
on the stage yeah Dr Doom doesn't look
like he's gonna get a turn either
and activating X just to make it easier
just to make sure that he gets a
knockout
oh and even with the drop there the
Buster is able to finish off Dr Doom
all right so evasion taking that one
pretty consistently liberal Terminator
will he be able to touch that they're
only activating the X because he knew he
was about to get light light punished
all right so right now we have liberal
Terminator not being able to find the
way in yeah and waste that X Factor so
this is huge for Invasion right now
yeah you got zero right now doing his
thing as usual one player game status oh
that's the end of Nova
yeah keeping it clean here comes the
mix-up whoa liberals be able to block
that LT cannot no
and also he doesn't have X Factor so
it's already a tough position to be in
Rachel
just to save a little bit of meter maybe
yeah and boom now evasion is just going
to wipe out wipe out LT let's look at
Bleak it's looking Bleak this game is
looking Bleak for LT
no meter sorry no X Factor it's all on
Doctor Who can't do anything
and just like that we're heading into
game three I think Asia might make a
clean sweep here it might be a 3-0
or not one more chance here for Liberal
Terminator I don't know how much you can
get out of that though so yeah guys
let's let's fast forward to game three
[Music]
foreign
making this look pretty clean you know I
think LT might need like a few like a
few moments to compose his thoughts uh
you know unfortunately it seems like
Nova is a non-factor too similar to how
uh Monday's match went even though he's
trying to swing a little bit more yeah
LP is the one that got evasion some
practice so he can be ready for one
thing but now turns out he accidentally
got in practice for himself yeah I gave
him he gave him too much Intel
okay this is the shot oh okay it's lt's
time oh oh but this is the hard tag
combo with the Doom that was a huge drop
and now you're got now do might be gone
might be the end of Doom
or maybe not all right let's go I was
going for the tag I don't like that that
was so
so risky yeah it's very risky here and
it does pay off for Invasion at least on
this side he's gonna be able to get rid
of Nova finally
and just like that Nova's gone and
Nova's a huge threat that's the
character that's gonna really fight zero
well on the team yeah so to lose that
tough tough position to be in let's see
if Spencer's gonna get the play no the
mix-up has worked every single time he
can't be stopped and the thing is that
you can tell that LT thinks it might be
a cross-up and he's like blocking the
wrong way and then he gets hit from the
front yeah a little bit of the uh the
friend the friend meta going on there I
think oh man and just like that
unfortunately it looks like this might
be the uh end of LP's run potentially
um yeah you're look you're sounding
right here even with the X Factor pop
the invasion was able to get the mix up
in the hit is he gonna be able to finish
this to go all the way
and he does 3-0 for evasion able to make
it into the top three and a huge pop off
let's go man invasion
getting into top three
and you know liberal Terminator is tough
I know definitely a fan favorite people
were rooting for him uh it's just when
you're fighting zero you gotta be so so
precise yeah I mean definitely an
innovation was precise there top three
already at this Evo and that's the thing
Invasion has been nothing but consistent
he's been top three and almost every
major he's been in look at that look at
that pop off guy let's go that's what
I'm talking about like I said man
invasion's definitely gonna have to
start getting some fans here because
he's been popping off you can see the
passion in his face like I know I know
zero players aren't popular and every
time I keep asking the question like who
do you like or anything like crowd gives
me like you know yeah some lukewarm
responses yeah well go guess what guys
we might be getting close to a potential
zero zero Grand Final so exactly you
know you better you're gonna have to
root for somebody let's take a look at
what we have left here in this map in
this bracket this top six that's been so
fun nominal we're going to have a
evasion moving on here evasion's gonna
have to get some fans if he ends up
winning Evo right but he's gonna have to
go against KBR first he's got to get
past KBR if either one of them wants a
chance at jabril to try to get this Evo
championship for Ultimate Marvel vs
Capcom 3. yeah KBR man the true people
is Champ the true World Warrior
everybody's excited to see him play
hoping for the best because you know
zero players are just villains to be
honest you know vilified you know if you
play Morgan or zero nobody wants to see
you actually win but we're gonna wait to
have to see that a little bit because
um yeah I think
we're gonna have a little ad break
before we see those matches so uh we'll
be back with losers finals and then
Grand finals right after this
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
new hunting ground Creighton wants a
hunt I'll give him one he'll never
forget better take him out before they
find the lizard
this gunship will quit I do not want to
be lizard food
Red Bull gives you wings
oh no
super Rola
Victory feels good
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back everyone uh to Ultimate
Marvel's Capcom 3 we are heading into
the final matches of this stacked
tournament yeah uh we got two more
matches left before we Crown a champion
here at Evolution at the most stack
bracket of all time right so we have
coming up for losers finals we have
evasion going up against KBR the villain
versus the hero actually you know Faith
was not really a villain he's a great
guy but you know if you play Zero you're
automatically the bad guy yeah that's
kind of the uh stigma you get you know I
can't believe though I don't think I've
ever seen a game 12 years after its
release have its biggest tournament ever
but we did it here we did it here
together as a family everyone in this
crowd right now that's enjoying Marvel
versus Capcom 3. every one of the 1350
players that signed up to play you guys
made him happen thank you guys so much
for bringing Marvel back together
yeah shout outs to everybody here in
attendance and those watching
and shout outs to Utah oh thank you for
making it happen and rallying the troops
man this is uh this has definitely been
a once in a lifetime experience as well
but I've never been able to guess we'd
be here but right now we're gonna have
KBR versus Invasion and the winner that
is gonna go up to jabril jabro's been
kind of sitting around here waiting to
see what plays out yeah and you know uh
jabril beat both Kane and evasion so
he's aware of what they can do he's
already kind of played them and seen
their capabilities I mean you know kind
of dispatch both of them pretty cleanly
actually no jabril and Kane was very
close but you know uh against evasion
less so so maybe you know a vegan has
thought of some things in case he gets
past Kane but you can't think that far
ahead you gotta take the game in front
of you first and his opponent in front
of him right now is a previous Evo
champion no slouch KBR coming out of
nowhere for you know I think I think
when you think of Modern Marvel KBR
isn't in that conversation but you can
never account about he is so optimal
six appearances definitely he's had some
strong performances in the past and a
title under his belt but he's looking
the repeat here to be the first repeat
Marvel versus Capcom 3 Champion but
Invasion wants his first title as well
so you know who's gonna come out on top
and I mean just you know for it to be
your first appearance at EVO to get up
on the stage no small feat so shout out
to a vision for getting this far and to
keep going look at that trophy that is
the nicest Evo trophy I have seen in my
lifetime and I have been coming here for
well over a decade wait do we do we get
one for being commentators you should
get first place man
all right look at the focus on these
guys faces they know they are so close
to the end here losers finals came Blue
River versus evasion and we saw and we
saw that you know with Jabrill he was
able to get away in the beginning pretty
pretty consistently against Kane
and that falling H paying off dividends
already and then we might be looking at
a dead Hope just at 99 seconds oh man
but we've seen a vision uh actually drop
the loops quite a bit so this could be
uh you know another one or if he could
not and he might be yeah he might be
refocused here you got the Cowboys out
right exactly that's you know the nerves
hit you but he's been up on the stage
enough times now
that was so good oh no Kane's not
getting a chance to play yeah the Buster
released there so quick hard to react to
it at all
and yeah we saw something similar happen
to uh Kanan the last set you know
unfortunately Central not even getting
to really touch the ground this time but
haggar came back last time but I don't
know about the thing yeah definitely
haggar looks like he's gonna go back
home Adventure as well wait for the next
game you're right though Sentinel has
not been a factor in any of the games
we've seen from game Blue River
yeah generally speaking you know he hard
drives has a chance to play with the
character
one more chance here oh my gosh
oh not sure what hit him but I'm sure
his Asian is breathing a sigh of relief
right now
personally
and yeah it's so hard to catch zero in
the beginning
exactly and unfortunately that's Hulk's
best chance is right there at the
beginning to try to lock him down or get
a hit at 99. once Zero's able to get
away here you know he gets to play his
game his neutral you have to respect it
yeah and you see you see uh Kane trying
to use you know the gamma wave to kind
of
hit up pin down division and things like
that you know something he wasn't really
doing against jabril
um but yeah still oh I throw oh nice
Tech from Invasion because that could
have been it yeah that Tech right there
might have cost him his whole tournament
like wow the tag oh my gosh that was
lucky for KBR to get haggar in but can
can the mayor do work
yeah here we go the zero see the the
thing is with zero being such a tough
character for a Hulk and Hagar players
it's actually okay for kbrarno because
this is a zero May crying team versus a
zero Doom team which kind of eliminates
the drones being in play so Invasion
kind of has to get a little bit closer
if he wants those assists to be a bigger
Factor
yeah as you see right now uh evasion
just trying to push KBR going for uh
some Mix-Ups with the Don Pacers oh is
this gonna hit
on zero able to block right after
releasing that buster there gets the
ground throw can't convert but he's
gonna set up his favorite mix-up
situation here oh Keepers jump out yeah
he had to but missing the missing the
air throw you know KBR KBR was gonna
jump but he missed the air throw there
unfortunately yeah Invasion actually
able to take advantage of kbr's plus
situation there with the X Factor in the
suit for Invasion just showing no fear I
think KBR
the drop the drop KBR just needs one
chance no that was no no no no oh my
gosh look at this three hits my friend
he's three heads evasion you gotta watch
this oh my god oh but not able to
continue it with the launcher there this
could be a chip out situation right here
going into Virgil is KBR just gonna let
him wow
too many Mix-Ups though with the swords
on the Belt yeah and also KBR doesn't
have X Factor so that also is gonna make
it really tough this could be a chip out
situation here oh he doesn't even chip
him out and now evasion and full control
pull rough without the assist it's going
to be tough he's got to be careful with
those assist calls there oh luckily
saved by Virgil that could have been the
end of Dante yo those slices are doing
damage
yeah that matchup is a little tooth up
there Virgil with a great call of jam
session to keep Hulk in the corner so
he's just able to projectile chip of the
deck rough oh an evasion getting the
throw getting the space that he needed
to now control the situation against
Kane I like that Invasion switched it up
there after the ground throw he not only
goes with the lightning to try to get
the 50-50 but he's already seen that
kind of get blown up before by Hagar
assist so he switched it up he's making
adjustments even on his wins oh man one
random touch there KBR and now here
comes division doing zero things yeah
you got one more assist call Max damage
and meter build before you activate oh
no looking bad for Hulk eat but if agent
could drop no drop no Drop The Invasion
has definitely been playing a lot
cleaner in this loser's finals than any
set before yes
and right now said no actually you know
on the screen tag no that's not what you
want to see because okay that's what you
want to see if you're a KBR fan oh
that's gonna be huge damage there
against Dante
oh my gosh what a risky tag but you need
to do that because on that pipe almost
crossed them up did you see that hit
from behind
all right this is 10 this is tense but
KBR he could he could create pressure
look at that avoiding the skin
oh my
[Applause]
God to get the pile driver and zero is
out of there this could be it what is it
Paul uses the double jump there trying
to avoid what he can but he came out
with half Health already he's got to be
careful here oh and then activating the
X no that was a little high yeah he had
to use the axle get the ground throw
conversion wasn't able to get it but
still picks up on air a standing
launcher
oh yeah this might be the end of our
hero guys
yeah of course the maximum damage you
can get going up against a sentinel that
big body taking extra damage and
invasion is gonna win and move on the
grand finals after this 3-0 sweep oh my
gosh and you know this means so much to
evasion making it there knowing that he
is one win away
from potentially capturing his first
evil title give it up for KBR and give
it up for Invasion for making it this
far okay
such a gentleman obviously showing a lot
of sportsmanship there supporting his
friend invasion
[Applause]
look at the crowd here they're they're
chanting for KBR oh man yeah KBR getting
the love he deserves from the crowd give
it up for KBR guys show them some love
he put in the work man this man has been
putting on a show for us for so many
years yeah yeah but you know the reality
is tears are tears for a reason you know
you can only get so far with your heart
before you know the game tells you that
you gotta you gotta deal with the zeros
and the virtuals of the world but don't
crush my hopes like please we just gotta
be real man look he overcame all the
odds before he actually over overcame
the odds this year by getting as far as
he did to Winners finals um sorry to
lose his finals and all that and getting
third but KBR True World Warrior Man
absolutely top three placing nothing the
scoff out there an excellent performance
by KBR like I said I don't think a lot
of people expected him to be in this top
six
but so yeah just looking at the bracket
here uh evasion going over came through
River 3-0 heading to the Grand finals
you know making sure he's part of top
two it'll be a zero May Cry mirror match
exactly I mean evasion as we saw in the
first round of top six had a tough match
against your bro where he got kind of
blown out three to zero but you know he
made his way back a little bit better
every time only dropping one game to
Monday and then 3-0 against LT and KBR
to get here like I said he's definitely
getting that composure he knows what to
expect now he knows what it feels like
on this stage he just needs to build a
deal with the pressure of trying to win
an EVO here at Grand finals well I mean
and you see Jabrill too jabriel's very
nervous as well uh but also maintaining
his composure and coming coming from the
winner side definitely gives him that
extra set you know uh just to make sure
that he can maintain his composure as
well and uh you know every match that
we've seen evasion has been Landing the
loops cleaner and cleaner and cleaner
less drops and even when there are drops
you know definitely converting and still
maintaining you know uh offensive
exactly able to pick it right back up
when he does drop but you know like you
said jabril is on the winner side here
he has a little more room to work with a
little bit more room for mistakes so you
know we'll see what he does with that
sometimes he can be a little
overconfident evasion takes that first
set quickly and the momentum is all on
his side yeah and we're exciting
everybody get into that grand finals
pretty soon but before that we gotta
take a quick break we'll be right back
guys stay with us
[Music]
that Sizzle that's the soundtrack of
Chipotle the soundtrack of Chipotle oh
yeah you come in you're gonna be hearing
that Sizzle that's how you know that we
always have fresh food
fresh is what you stand for that's
exactly
foreign
[Music]
and and we are back here with the
conclusion of this top six bracket for
Ultimate Marvel versus Capcom 3 here at
Evolution Grand finals we have coming up
jabril versus evasion this is going to
be the match to determine who is going
to go home Champion I know it's a it's
going to be a zero make cry battle both
players gunning for their first Evo
championship at the most stacked bracket
ever yeah the hype has been so real all
weekend long we've played Friday we
played Saturday we've been playing all
morning and here we are at the Grand
finals here both of these guys has had
such a long journey to get here jabril
of course in the top six kind of just
cruising on through on the Winner's side
but Invasion has had a tough road after
having suffered that loss three to zero
against evade against jabril yeah and I
believe we have some highlights that we
can check out of jabra's game and play
like that led him to these Grand finals
you know going through Point through
evasion you know pretty soundly earlier
yeah and also squeaking by Kane well
actually no he didn't was kicked by him
when he touched them it was over I mean
look look at this hopping on the stage
super hype you know his niceness
betraying the scummy gameplay
the dirtiest of Mix-Ups
a consistent Killer Instinct that he has
all throughout the tournament so far
yeah look at that deep side you know and
then right here against KBR haggar never
had a chance he's just a human yeah
surviving the comeback opportunities
that came Blue River has had man able to
just get through it but and just just in
full control then his zero technical I
don't think I've seen him drop one Loop
this entire tournament yeah obviously he
is practiced non-stop for this moment
here and that's what it takes to be an
EVO Champion hours and hours of practice
yeah and you know
on the other side of it we have evasion
right and evasion uh definitely one of
the kind of surprises in the bracket so
to speak for the finals of course uh but
showing why he's earned his way here why
he's a part of it and he has been
putting on a show I mean look at that
coming out there let's go gaining new
fans here or maybe not a little at a
time little at a time look you can't
hate him for playing zero now he's
playing against the zero you gotta root
for him a little I know pick your point
I was kidding no but no no but look at
this he was so clean against mundane you
saw Monday never had a chance with Nova
uh never got started with Nova against
liberal Terminator 3-0 that was pretty
shocking yeah definitely his training
partner there wasn't close at all
invasion was able to dominate and keep
it consistent all the way through and
able to close it out against KBR in the
same fashion with a 3-0 up
yeah and just like just just working his
way back getting better and better and
the matches have been look oh you you
gotta respect the passion you gotta love
the passion this means so much to these
players they work so hard to get here
the hours the training you know like the
advances in gameplay the losses that you
suffer the pain that you take from that
all to get here to this moment yeah both
of these guys definitely practice stuff
playing the exact same team obviously
these guys have been playing since the
game's release but now 20 23 12 years
later they're getting their moment to
shine here Jabra obviously with a little
bit more experience on the west coast
playing it Evo almost every single time
that it's been a main game invasion
though
his first time here and he's already in
Grand finals I know he's got to be hyped
but he's got keep that composure about
him yeah and I'm excited to see right
you know a vision lost the zero War uh
when they first played in winners semis
right so I'm looking forward to seeing
what kind of adjustments like uh Vision
has made for this matchup against your
bill yeah which one of these guys is
gonna take this beautiful trophy I love
that trophy
you know like we said jabril is on the
winner side here he has a little bit of
room he has a little bit of uh space for
error but I don't think he's looking to
have this go to a reset
and look at that getting their hands
warmed up I believe we are going to get
ready to start that match soon and this
is Grand finals
yeah we need to get a little excitement
in here Grand finals for Evo for Marvel
coming back let's get some hype in here
all right
[Music]
all right hopefully these guys must be
brimming with anticipation I know I am
I'm looking at a vision he's locked in
man like you know he is locked in you
could tell he's like this is my chance I
I fought through everyone all I need to
do is take you out to a broil you're in
the way I'm gonna do it at Gabriel So
Close
all right all right
who is going to activate the genuine
first oh and your bro gets the first hit
yeah no so Gamu needed here to get it to
the corner and I feel like this could be
the first game essentially because
playing that's what it feels like you're
flipping a coin at 99 who's gonna win
okay wow he won the zero point okay can
Dante block this can block him about to
even come in nice he said oh wait you're
if you might play this team but guess
what there's layers and everybody's
gonna shoot
zero Shenanigans it doesn't matter how
comfortable you are there's so many 50
50s you can only guess correct so many
times before the odds are against you
does Virgil have a chance to come in and
hit the ground because we know Virgil
can make that come back if he could
actually play oh oh oh oh oh what the
Buster able to stop the super but it's
okay he gets a little space to work with
them and then you know right now jabriel
has to find his way in
but it didn't and this but this is still
scary yeah Virgil's just kind of
swinging a sword down there but you know
what Zero's got a sword too he was a
little too Reckless there jabril coming
down at the right angle how did he know
how did he like how did he feel where
Virgil was going to end up at that was
kind of crazy honestly yeah it's that
competitive sphere that tells you hey
this is where I need to push the button
this is where I stop my opponent yeah
and you know to Pearl taking that first
game pretty convincingly right
it seems like whoever wins the zero
point pretty much could take the game
right so it's all dependent at the
beginning that first encounter who keep
it that way so far every single time
Andrew bro just slightly getting
slightly edging out uh
debating every time
oh my God almost almost out of there
almost converted there and Invasion
still stop finding the right way to come
in on Jabra Jabra understanding the
Angles and oh my gosh
again but didn't capitalize yeah evasion
doing the best he can to try to avoid
getting in here oh my God he's not
getting ahead of his own you're right
hit no drops no drops please
oh okay
all right blast it
don't drop if you can get the kill then
this could be your rounds okay
will jabriel be able to block this
already side switched a couple of times
but the Bros able to get the play going
here
wow and I see I see evasion not happy
with how that hit
resets into a new hit he doesn't
continue the combo after a million
dollars he says I need a fresh one oh
and you're able to call that Dante says
quite late in the combo to confirm oh
back to the same sign how many times can
you side switch him and he put him into
the corner nicely done they're girls not
giving a vision a chance to play
clinicals okay don't let Virgil even
land and get the chance to do when he oh
my gosh that was too filthy what was
that oh my gosh jabriel's Mix-Ups are
just too strong right now with Virgil oh
my gosh making quick work of evasion
this is not what we wanted to see we
wanted to see the adaptation we wanted
to see what adjustments have been made
but they're Real showing that no
there are no adaptions you can make
against exactly jabril is making
adaptations as he wins you can't stop a
player like that sometimes
and jabriel one win away one went away
from getting that
sweet sweet Evo trophy yeah I I just
blinked and here we are in game three
jibril on the verge of becoming the next
Evo champion
man those left rights were insane what
is going on to Brill too clean
he's feeling comfortable he's playing
like he's at home and that's why you
want to do when you're on this main
stage
ooh okay evasion getting the start
he got the uh zero win last time yep my
Virgil you know a big threat so let's
see a visually finish off zero looking
good looking good okay hit the loops now
Dante will he be able to get daunting oh
no this time he double jumps right into
the jam session no mix up there from
Invasion stays on the same side here
Invasion looks like he's gonna be coming
back for this fight oh he wants that he
wants that Virgil in he doesn't want to
deal with the shenanigans but jabriel
with the blocks oh my gosh
come on
oh no we didn't even activate the X no
he just dashed up and swung his sword
and it worked out perfectly for jabril
and he's going for the loops keeping it
easy
not wanting to activate the X Factor
because you know you could save that
he's going for the simple Loops yes
switching sides and then here's the
mix-up will Dante be able to flock this
oh that was so fast
that might be it for Dante however
Virgil still has a chance evasion still
has a chance one of the character away
from jabril taking Evo
what what is the block
oh my God
oh my gosh amazing talking for his life
first evil life oh oh no but that might
be it oh no
he still has the jam session he can
finish it
and
jabril takes it he is your Evo
2023 Champion he knew he could do it
everyone was picking him to be the
favorite
and he came through he lived up to the
expectations he knew when he was working
for all these past few years and he was
able to do it the emotional response
like like look at that man like you
he kept a stolic demeanor the entire
time you know the entire time he kept it
inside he kept his composure
um this is the cathartic this is the
cathartic release this is where he
finally all that work all that effort
has paid off he has proven that he is
the best in the world at Ultimate Marvel
vs Capcom 3 right now man when you work
so hard when you when you grind every
single day every single minute that you
can and it pays off for you like this
there is no better feeling jabriel is
our champion here at Evo 2023 6-6
appearances he finally got him he
finally got it the Everett elusive
evil Evo trophy Evo Championship man
yeah I'm so happy for Jabron right now
man this guy has been working it's been
he's been going to every single event I
mean just just look at how he played so
clean so clinically oh it was it was
actually art in a way you know because
he yeah I know we want to Abilify this
team but
the level that he was playing it was
just so so precise yeah definitely
unmatched in the way he's able to
capitalize with every single opportunity
left nothing on the table there
oh man jabriel just magical the way he
was able to pull this Victory off and
that was it right there and I mean a
vision you got to give it up to him he
put up a fight the defense was there he
was fighting for his life but like you
can only block so much you can only
block so much
feel the passion with every single hit
of that last combo you know he he knows
that he was about to win an EVO right
there in that combo
look at him look at him right there you
know and I think it thought about him it
just look at that that's when it hit oh
man I'm touched man I'm really touched
by that to be honest with you look at
that and then there we go we have our
evil finalists on the stage right now
all of these players gave it their all
they put up a fight
give it up for him
and I can't think of a person more
deserving of an EVO Championship than
jabril right now and we're doing the
metal ceremony you know we have coming
in fifth place Spartan Throne worked so
hard with that Iron Fist giving it up
for him next up liberal Terminator
he too putting in that work getting to
this stage you know definitely a
favorite getting up to that stage was
hard enough
yeah
then we have evasion here coming in
second place give it up you know uh so
close he played so well he fought back
from losers man he really really gave it
his all I love the passion shout outs
for making it as far as you did
the man the myth the legend coming up
KBR guys the people's champion World
Warrior
all the way from Chile you know former
evil Champion the man needs no intro
shout outs getting top three in this
stack bracket love it
yeah even though he wasn't able to close
it out today he put on an amazing
performance I can't be prouder of KBR
and also coming in fifth Monday gosh you
know uh definitely
fought his way to get on this evil stage
but you know uh uh unfortunately wasn't
he was kind of stopped there but it's
such a feat to get here he's such his
Legend in this day and age I love the
Nova Spencer and uh the man who needs no
introduction
jabril your Evo 2023 champion no one
more deserving grinding all the way to
get here this is your time jabril this
was your moment this is your Evo
yeah and just uh playing so cleanly in
in such a high pressure environment You
Gotta Give It Up you gotta recognize the
skill shout out man good works are bro
shout and shout outs to the rest of the
you know top the top six here today yeah
big shout outs to all 1350 players that
entered but only one can come out on top
and it is jabril this weekend Oh and
these guys are getting the all the
sticks oh my
one of those
so clean KBR with the bronze victrix we
got Invasion with the silver but your
bro with the gold fight stick oh and
it's breaded oh that's so pretty that's
so pretty trophy the gold stick man
and the crowd tomorrow
look if if that enthusiasm continues
then hey man I might be here next year
yeah
[Applause]
look at the crowd so happy for your bro
so happy to see Marvel back on the main
stage
you guys made it all possible yeah I
mean I really like I really like the the
performance that the players put on hard
fought everywhere and uh yeah man these
guys are amazing yeah it's been a crazy
couple of years for Marvel and it's been
such a treat to watch but man it has to
come to an end eventually it's been such
a pleasure yeah it's been amazing doing
commentary with you Tom it's been
amazing doing commentary with you you
know your huge reason why this has
happened continue continue to show that
love and and you know thank you
everybody for checking this out for
participating for showing that love for
responding to Tong's call
10 more years guys 10 more years
all right
we are gonna throw it I believe to Aaron
uh
to talk about what else is happening
yes I got something to tell y'all but
before we get to that point please let's
get around an Applause to our top six
and also 2023 evil ultimate
three
championship
all righty all right exciting start to
the day but the excitement continues on
coming up uh harasson has something
special for you taking fans
but
we need another special guest who's
gonna be coming up here please welcome
tetsuya fugahara game director of the
grand blue fantasy series
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
all right
um
[Applause]
hi my name is oh it's louder here hi my
name is tetsuya fukahara from side Guy
games I am the creative director of
grand blue Fantasy Versus Rising
and day one day today
[Music]
foreign
and we want to thank all of you for
helping out with that and participating
and today we've prepared a special video
for you
all right so let's roll the video
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
Horizon
[Music]
a little faster
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
Mississippi
[Applause]
Fantasy Versus Rising
[Music]
hi uh
so Grand blue fit Fantasy Versus Rising
will be coming out worldwide November
30th 2023
foreign
ERS open up on the PlayStation tour
store tonight at midnight and wishlist
on Steam will be available as well
and we have more news to share with you
all so let's go to the next slide
all right
so the game will also release with a
free edition
um so while some functionality will be
limited uh there will be lots of modes
that that are available to play
you know
standard Editions
so if you play the free edition you can
play along with others that are playing
the standard and digital editions
um so you won't be limited At All by
playing the free edition
[Applause]
[Music]
hi uh Grand Blues Legends will be fully
playable as well
um so if you want to find out more
details visit our official website
thank you
hi uh
all right one more little tidbit for you
all uh next slide please
[Applause]
the second Online Beta is coming at you
this fall 2023
mati is
[Music]
this time we'll be focusing on Cross
play with steam Lobby matches as well as
the online functionality for granberries
Legends
foreign
[Applause]
also thanks to your feedback from the
first beta we'll be implementing that
and take making some tweaks before this
beta starts
[Applause]
as we approach release we're doing our
very best to make this the greatest game
we possibly can so thank you for all
your support
thanks for everything see you
thank you
[Applause]
director brand blue fantasy series
[Music]
all right everyone we are just getting
started and like I said coming up we
have a big Tekken announcement from
haradasan followed by taking seven uh
top six you don't want to go anywhere
we'll see you all soon
[Applause]
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code
hdkn236 and receive 250 fighter coins
with yours visit chipotle.com sf6 for
details
Red Bull gives you wings
foreign
[Music]
Victory feels good
Trump
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
thank you
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Chipotle's new Chicken al pastor is fire
on every level fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground acchiode balanced
with a splash of pineapple all combined
for the right amount of heat Chipotle's
all-new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
[Music]
foreign
PlayStation
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
[Music]
call
I'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right everybody welcome back to the
Big Love alternate reading here at
Mandalay Bay in Las Vegas are we ready
for some Tekken top six
before we get started with some good
Tekken are you guys interested in any uh
updates for Tekken maybe maybe the band
dynamical team is there any interest
I thought I thought so I thought so
with that said
get ready
because I'm here with great honor to
bring out the legendary the director
from Bandai nanto Caso hero hararasan
and Michael Murray
foreign
[Applause]
so extremely happy to be here for Evo
.
[Applause]
what
oh no sign what what are you doing here
what what are you doing here
security security
hi everyone long time no see
hey
me yeah do you remember we had
some hard work homework
what what about the homework
we we we had taken Crow
going out
get out
get out here
[Applause]
I don't know he is but who he is I don't
I don't him
sorry for that little inconvenience it's
accident
just like I said
the information
oh yeah yeah uh
[Music]
um
so uh going back to Tech enroll tour
everyone's here uh competing today uh we
you still don't know any info about the
finals but uh Evo this year is huge
numbers for Tekken seven are amazingly
up over last year as well yeah
thank you thank you
all right
so we've got some info for you guys so
uh let's find out more about the finals
aside uh let's see the trailer please
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
all right
so now that's where we're going to New
Orleans and uh any of you are familiar
with we were supposed to be there in
2020 so I think there's a lot of people
super excited to go to the location
[Applause]
all right
that's all
thank you enjoyable
see you
[Applause]
foreign
you know we have to do that at least
once right
all right
[Music]
so we believe uh you want to know more
about who's going to be in Tekken 8
right
there
all right let's see the first trailer
yeah
[Applause]
all right
get ready for the next step
turn eight yeah
[Applause]
thank you
launches
actions
[Applause]
there
uh
what's up
so Raven's back
I don't know
um
[Music]
so many of your favorite characters are
back in Tekken eight now Raven you can
see all the cool special moves he had in
the trailer it might look like it's
difficult to pull off but now we have a
new feature in Tekken 8 if you haven't
seen it yet the special style you can
switch back and forth by just pushing
the shoulder button on the controller
and uh it makes it a lot easier to do
all these flashy moves
all right
so we have a lot of favorites coming
back but uh you haven't seen anyone new
yet have you
yeah
all right let's check out the trailer
[Applause]
get ready for the next stop
turn eight
challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
what
y'all can we please give it up for those
second favorite videos please please my
God
all right all right all right now we're
gonna get on to what we're all here for
is that Tekken seven top six here at Evo
2023 let's get this intro video and then
get these players down let's go give it
up up
[Music]
here
rage
find inspiration through the pain
Devil's book keeps running through my
face
[Music]
tell me what you wanna feel
floating till you hit the ground
[Music]
all right let's go this is it are we
ready for our Tekken seven top six
finalists
first up here we go make some lunch keep
the energy high for also
God
[Applause]
[Music]
next up Give It Up Make some noise for
Iceland
[Applause]
[Music]
Keep It Up Get Loud forever
[Applause]
make some more noise for our gang it's
done
[Applause]
okay
next up let's get mail in
[Applause]
the final top six competitor and again
all right everyone let's go make some
noise for your top six finalists and
Tekken seven
all right we got my best friends tasty
Steven riff up there to call all the
action take it away boys
yo hello
2023 the potential last Tekken seven
tournament if you're ready for some good
ass package Make some noise
oh it feels getting me I think they're
ready Steve and just in case you don't
know
my name is tasty Steve and I am joined
by one of the greatest to ever do it
level up your game Make some noise for
real
ball
yo those trailers were crazy but we got
some Tekken seven to finish up here of
course we got this top six amazing
competition ready yo shout out to top
eight compared to dojin and nobody
nobody making another top eight finish
here at Tekken seven you know he if you
go back in time right the very first
Tekken seven evil finals we had nobody
and ow in the Grand Final that's true
both of them made it back into the top
main but Al this time on the upper
bracket and you can see right now Al
King has done another player I'm really
really really happy to see if they're
representing the USA nonetheless and
then we have Leo ill of one of the most
dangerous competitors I feel like a lot
of people kind of let slip past the
radar and now it's in this Tekken seven
top six of course we saw him come out
last and finally not least Anakin even
talked about on Twitter he's like yo
it's been a minute it was a hard draw
but here we are in this top six for
Tekken seven and I have to reiterate
potentially the last time you're going
to see it here Evo it's amazing exactly
at the very top of this bracket of
course from Korea Olson going up against
Pakistan's Arsenal Ashland that has
three Evo titles under his belt right
two Evo Japan one evil Vegas trying to
get a fourth year which is basically
unprecedented right we're gonna have
seven Evo appearances protective seven
and arson might get four of them that's
wild that says a lot about what arson
and just the Pakistan Community overall
has done to the community of Tekken 7.
on top of that we didn't even get all of
them to come over here because of Visa
issues exactly but still the competition
was fierce nonetheless and if you go
back and look at some of those games
that we saw they were absolutely
ridiculous throughout the entire weekend
no they're ridiculous but of course
Genghis died a name you guys really have
to pay attention to right nobody saw him
making it this far into the bracket of
course one of the top Compares from the
USA but you know just a few years ago
even he was playing on just analog
sticks right so recently even a couple
years ago picked up the dual shock and
now he's up here on the stage and the
winner side of the bracket and you can
see the energy he's bringing to the
table already I can tell you that right
now I'm really excited to see what he
does here does have his work cut out for
him though Al is no slouch we've seen
him before he's been playing Tekken 7
for quite some time he's been on the
stage before so you know he's not shot
he has what it takes we've seen him play
quite strong for the last few events
that he's been in exactly 1500 entrance
here we're at the tournament right but
everyone expected Arsenal has to be in
this right seeing if you could got
another title but we also expect to kind
of see me or Kokomo was taken out Arthur
recently all of those guys were knocked
out of the bracket before we got to this
topic so right now when you look at this
bracket it kind of looks like it's
arson's bracket yeah that's definitely
true but I don't know man if we talk
about all side we talk about how strong
he was just before he had to take his
little Hiatus and then came back came
back on the scene and Steele was
delivering results where he was getting
top sixes top eights top 16 and still
considered very much one of the
strongest players in the world arson Ash
arguably number one and two if you don't
like me you know the best Tekken players
in the world I told Arsen this myself I
said it wobbles in Pakistan they have
actually changed the landscape of Tekken
seven yeah if you guys haven't been
following the tech instead of storyline
from 2019 onward Pakistan has invaded
the scene they've taken over and now
Arsenal trying to get his fourth title
but ulsan as Steve mentioned Bang now
since 2022. the shirt says it all and
here's the thing right when he was his
best he was kind of this Kazumi player
which is also arson's character yes in
this tournament usan has not used Kazumi
at all it's all been fengwei and Bob oh
the Bob and it looks like the players
are getting set up right now on the
stage I see him sitting down there
already getting locked in I'm glad that
you said that though Osan definitely has
multiple characters up his sleeve one of
the last Believers I would say in Bob
but the Kazumi is still there but
arsenaline I feel like has always kind
of changed his game up we saw him
recently not recently but in the last
couple years switch over to the Kuni
mitsu had a couple more characters to
his repertoire makes him so much
stronger as a player and that way he's
able to deal with some of these counter
picks some of these harder matchups but
this right here is about to be a banger
I promise you exactly the winner of this
gets into the top three of course if you
guys like usan though from Korea please
make some noise
you guys are a little reluctant I see
but our Salon is on the stage so this
next question is an important one if you
guys would like Arsen asked to take the
set Make some noise
wow wow not sitting on the fence at all
I see all right
Korea versus Pakistan to kick things off
here today here we go and he's got the
hand covering right now his name hand
covering as we get into it y'all ready
for some good ass decking let him hear
it out there if you're in the chat hit
some buttons if you're on the crowd Make
some noise
oh it sounds good here here we go Cooney
mitsu coming out for Arsenal this has
been the character that he's been
rocking the most of recently but Bob
from old son all right here we go
getting ready for the way boost Steve
way boo
wow delay on the string still finishes
it though yeah down forward one two
straight from Cooney mitsu so annoying
such a hard thing to deal with but duck
to high early
you really want to start set that
President right now we know our time
will test that range using that set Dash
we couldn't make it to get in really
close to the Gap really fast and all
ready to be doing a lot of work set
slide gets in first first Blood first
round arsenaline Ash he wants the fourth
title he's going for it back to check
here for both son try to keep him in
place go back to back throw breaks good
okay nice check right there with the
down 4-1 arson really likes to get
offensive
yeah right now who's on doing a good job
of keeping it in place right now though
Cooney moves it down
starting to come into play too as our
sign does the three walking into the
background oh second encounter anybody
can do that Cooney with the I
follow him through the set too for the
counter and that should be the round
pending no drop um
close it out arson two up
and that route also is looking pretty
clean the whole way through too get a
solid for both of it
that 2-2 string from this is so hard to
deal with though
I'm sorry man
double wave without no help maybe you
want to help sweep there
oh wow really compact play right here
not trying to give up too much you see
all signers definitely changed up his
approach
big lead right here but oh here comes
our sign he's making his move yeah he's
chopping down got the life lead now
oh what's up with the throw interception
oh this should be the end of the record
he messed up the combo
oh
my God that was a huge error for both
sides at the end there two huge errors
back to back and game one goes to
arsenash he had the opportunity to
punish get the win on top of that that
would have gave him the round to stay
alive but his nerves man I feel
definitely nerves are upset ozon never
played on the stage this large this evil
crowd this Arena obviously a different
place to play at
I'm gonna see what he's gonna change up
right here I mean I felt like he was
playing so good regardless right already
playing really well with the Bob finding
the hits in the whole nine however
arslines way in ability to kind of just
Traverse make sure you don't get
comfortable setup to start throwing out
these strong Bob folks has really made
him take the lead in his set already
game number one in the hooks game number
two here we go
definitely looking a little shaken up
right now down forward Supermarket
caught him coming in
making sure he's respecting the space
yeah and that down for one two Souls
that downward one two string is so
annoying because second it hit jab punch
well but if you try to interrupt you can
finish the string and hit you with the
third hit oh and we saw already how that
turned out no break on the throw right
there
nice just while standing four for the
punish
offense
becoming a lot more active on the side
of all time but it's not stopping the
lead from going away on Arsenal National
side Olson with the rage mode right now
life bar is low means of course you get
more damage than every hit here comes
the hell we're at the wall here looking
for wall combo doesn't fight but we're
switching positions off the throw Escape
he's got to finish the combo
switch
[Applause]
don't stop I love it dude I can't
believe
I can't believe it's still so good they
trade
oh power pressure not gonna work okay
from Arson as well but he's got a big
lead here
doing a great job just in case you try
to sidestep you have a better
opportunity to correct yourself exactly
and Bob jab actually one of the better
ones in the game because it's incredible
range rage art attempt I don't know I
don't think he had a button he did not
an arsonist with the round
curious what he thought was it coming
from Arson arson plays really compact
right there but that's set Dash is
something you really gotta pay attention
to when he's using it to get in when you
least expect it yeah you see that's the
step Dash right there she's gotta permit
safe option that is a count rate
launcher plus a low unsafe launch as a
counter launch as well
oh starting to find the game plan out
here right now switching up the low
staggering the all yeah big call out big
launcher right here you're definitely
going to the wall of this one there we
go he's backing it out shaking the
nerves off big one this is dangerous
probably not dead but this is a bad
situation to be in wait he went for some
okay there double raise again no
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it looked like Arthur didn't do anything
but it was a set Dash call out yo speed
and weight
oh power Crush oh to the back
we're a 3D game right the third
dimension
nice Jabs here keeping him honest still
and look at this game turn around and
arson's favor doesn't stop
does it stop this offense and now he's
pressuring on the wall wow over the top
still in it here trying to close out the
game and tie things up the backpack four
arson hesitating a little bit throws out
a ring jab punch watch up for rage yard
oh my goodness he's got a really good
right down to Logan beating up damage
arson step point oh my gosh the
turnaround the smallest scrambles
they're adding up like crazy
while standing four I bet that's just a
contest arson doing that set Dash
the downforce who gets the full launch
and look at the carry on this
oh man but now way behind arson smelling
blood in the water trying to close out
here big block though
save lives he needs another chance
here comes the Mig 50 50.
attempt again and then he adds it to the
favorites just for later in my private
time I'm going to look at that again
damn I'm good again and again and again
[Applause]
one to one
what a comeback
twice the sidewall screwed up Pearl
sidewall saves lives bro there's an
airbags and 3D games dude the airbags
and 3D games dude they save lives
oh my God three this is literally the
first Cent In This top six and it's
already heating up I am ready for the
next battle I'm glad you asked get ready
Steve it's coming
it's a good way to start this is a damn
good way to start yeah old son
definitely had some nerves in game one
shook him off stuck with the Bob the
whole way through two right he had that
rough start could have switched the
thing decided to stick with the bobbin
here we go infinite states by Arsen Ash
I love the song
oh man last time taking seven years
all right I'll hit the drop for sure
yeah wave wave over the back back four
punish
is really starting to pay off
punishes the while standing mixed up
there as well
unbelievable
[Applause]
you can never count Arthur now though
you can never count ours went out that's
a three-time Evo Champion for multiple
evils not just here but elsewhere too
Ducks the high didn't get the punish
though just got a big lead huge lead
here Arsen is in some trouble can't
count put him into although or Arsenal
trying to tell somebody got the launch
man it's just the string like a madman
this is still gonna keep the lead in
olstar's favorite hard Spike not really
the lead he locked the lead he had to
throw he Ducks under Becker double rates
the mix
oh
oh my God
round three final game
damn this game is sick I can't believe
how good it is there we go
down four two no launch this time wow
wow completely stop the dash from so far
too yeah
again the downpour one two check here
that was a beautiful comeback on Mars in
the last round here
a lot of times people get really shaken
up with their back turn pressure from
Kuni mitsu all time playing amazing
the counter hit and that is gonna do
major damage not dead this is gonna put
all side of the rage what's the move
yo
oh you gotta guess oh the middle okay
okay
but now put them down set point for
Arsenal and Ash
oh my God
oh I've been feeling it
one step closer to the top three here
comes the drop
I love that he's dancing actually
punished that by ducking under the hips
Arthur big Hall out of the crash one
from Bob Dr needs got the launcher
here's the combo
Olson in trouble
big trouble Arthur looking good here to
close it out okay starting to add up the
one he's adding up big time
are we going there already
enough with rage not enough the pixel oh
finally going around
I'm standing up I'm standing you think
I'm sitting I'm standing over it
oh snap
oh hello
the jab single Jabs throwing to the low
the second offense is helping out so
much he's crazy the interceptions right
now off the step dance it could all be
counterint and there's a counter it hey
Ma he's doing strings
try it again
oh God no throw breaks again but now
he's not rage it's enough damage if you
can find oh no put it watch for the blue
stuff watch for the blue stuff
he's going to the top three wow
I didn't know I would be saying this so
soon so forgive me but was that not some
glass taken bro that is the first game
oh my goodness is it not start off that
way but wow what a set to kick off
Tekken seven here wow
jeez
wow jeez arson Ash the clutch
clutch and Ash wow
top six already paying off dividends and
the switches the changes to accommodate
for the defense and the offense oh my
gosh
yeah
first they show us these trailers before
the top six and now they're giving us
these matches they don't want me to be
able to talk they don't want me to be
able to use my voice that was amazing
that was absolutely amazing and you know
at the very end there he had the race
Drive mix right and he went up he's like
I'm scared to hit a button he didn't
wave was in his face he did nothing he's
like I don't want to force to 50
straight and it was just so tense for
the both of them there think about it a
lot of times when people see wave dashes
right they freak out they're like yo how
do I contest this and the fact that like
Arthur was like I'm not moving I'm not
even gonna test it and so many times you
see kunimitsu with the down back 3-3 to
close out the round the double low kick
and usually it's enough damage but in
that situation that fine final round it
didn't kill Wilson had one last chance
after it man ridiculous the harada care
package coming in dividends right there
the plus five on the points there coming
in dividends oh man so we're gonna go to
the next part of this winners bracket
that was so good Al versus Genghis died
coming up to the stage Japan and versus
the USA and of course out here
an EVO finest for the very first time we
had Tekken 7 at Evolution got second
place in that tournament remember to
nobody actually yes yes right very
emotional loss per hour in that one and
now he's back here the winner side of
the bracket in the top six of the
potentially the final year of Texas
let's take a look at this replay Steve
walk us through it also what I was
talking about here we were talking about
how that first round it was not like
Olson was playing bad at all but I'm
gonna tell you right now Arsen Ash
really did take control and keep the
momentum inside for those first games
alsan tied it up really quick but it
really did come down to the streams the
delays and letting it Revenge at the
last second I mean he definitely had
nerves in game one right I remember
arson's been on this stage multiple
times this is his third time on this Evo
stage right he's gotten first third and
now whatever he ends up with oh my God
but this the slow-mo was after slow-mo's
man arson was hanging on the whole way
through and also he fought back and he
was there he had the lead and everything
but final fight around shows up down to
the wire and Arsen kicked Victory heads
into winners final and now he's in top
three guaranteed back to back evos bro
the matches already are looking
phenomenal I gotta fix my jacket geez
yeah you took my name bro that's crazy
these matches are already going well yo
Evo you guys still with me make some
noise if you're enjoying this take it
for me one time
I can't believe this is the seventh gear
this game's like 10 years old
giving us such amazing matches with some
of the most nail-biting instances in any
fighting game oh my God period and man
let me tell you this one coming up here
Alan Genghis Don's a wild one right Al
has been really really strong lately
right yeah I talked about how he was the
final first evil but in between then and
now he kind of took a little break it
seems like but now he's back and now
he's got the kudi mitsu he's kind of the
player to put this character back on the
board for everybody yeah and I really do
feel like it kind of fits Genghis Dawn's
kind of game plan right he really does
have like this kind of set play what are
you gonna do if I do this kind of style
but I want to talk about Al Al is such a
strong historic young player I know he's
been here before but think about it 10
total appearances in a evil this is no
spring chicken is trained in the ways of
Tekken and probably one of the best out
there especially if we're looking at
Japan exactly let's talk about
genghisanya right from Georgia Atlanta
Georgia in the building first time ever
at Evo and he's in the top six right now
not applicable we're finding out today
what the best results gonna be
man what a way to put it though I can
tell you that right now no slots we've
already been seeing you know the
regional Wars of tech and it's a career
it is Pakistan is it Japan USA where you
at UK what are you doing I love that
it's always been this battle for like
Tekken Regional Supremacy and it all
comes to a head on this stage you wanna
talk about regions premium look at this
upper bracket right we had Japan USA
Pakistan and Korea that was the
diversity in just the four players in
the upper half of this brackets
oh wow get ready for the next battle and
of course I'm not ready we got Korea and
USA too
oh yeah game on
all right guys
if you guys would like out to take it
make some noise
of you guys will like Genghis Khan from
the USA to take and make some noise
you got the people behind you my guy
we are good friends but right now it's
about the Battle let's see what happens
here owl a little bit Wilder with the
kudamezu willing to take a little bit
more risk than arson's style of
kunimitsu and getting down with his
Katarina man a very frustrating
character again when she came out
originally in Tekken seven people were
saying oh man just match kick one sweet
but you know there's a little bit more
skill involved and I'm gonna tell you
right now we already talked we always
talk about this house season in and
season out Katarina will get these
little adjustments that would make her
significantly better Lowe's got better
stream cancels got better and overall
damage just in general and now I
feel like she's a legitimate threat oh
my gosh move to death
doesn't matter Al with the first round
okay okay
Katarina character we definitely don't
get to see as much in high level
competitive play but also just saying
that we see this about like this
character in Tekken in general pretty
good diversity wise yeah no duck doing
the two two street from genes a little
scary okay the hairier transition
starting to pay off yeah Heritage
is what you're going to see Catherine do
a little dashboard after some of her
attacks and from that stance he actually
has a few objects couple little options
and some jumping ones as well you got to
watch out for
wow really trying to get away from that
wall I'll scouting early nice option
there the Harrier transition yeah that's
the one that tracks have been locked out
of product that's good enough Gangnam
Style ties it up
patient play adding up right now
2-2 check starts around here into the
teleport to side step into the Hop kick
but it's nice and done by Al hands off
oh they dance yeah gang is taking the
timer looking for the approach Catherine
a very long leg she can reach across the
stage some of those lows
those things chunk and they get really
annoying to deal with Andy patch it to
make it a little bit safer too so yeah
that's exactly
great choice for her there's a jumping
Travis not a Harrier to go out for out
doing a good job of it so far
down now getting a little more
aggressive now in this approach
yeah yeah you know and gang is not dug
in that 2-2 swing earlier kind of gave
out that maybe it's not as prepared for
the character nice Punisher from Al okay
to the wall we go
oh wow
yeah 50 easy
okay
while standing four
ning just gets right under that bad boy
oh nice we talked about those lows and
how they're adding up almost had a
transition there with the kick the gang
is still in this right now
[Applause]
keep it simple
give him some kicks for three three so
four forward ah it didn't kill and
that's why you should have did the rage
oh my goodness now looking to close down
Genghis trying to survive
[Applause]
gang is gone I can't believe the rage I
didn't do enough I mentioned that rage
drop would have oh yeah it does a grip
but here we go final round game one
there with him every step of the way
seems
Al playing a little further back right
now those lows started to add up a lot
really got getting wow back in the game
in the lows now you're worried about
that you're ducking I'm gonna hit you
with the Hop kick to the wall
[Applause]
oh no I was in trouble now
oh tries to go in after no throw rake
and the thing is you can control when
you go to that mid move and I like that
he stopped early and went to it early
that was really good because I was
looking for that next hit too wow it
made the owl getting the first game here
but Genghis was close the whole way
through to be honest
headphones are coming off
thinking about it taking a laugh I don't
blame taking the laughs you got to take
a lap up the evil stage he's like bro
where'd he go
look at my man I feel you out I feel you
bro we were in the middle of a battle
oh man we coach you when coaching that
evil I like it that's how I know you
want to win bro
it's a little dark so I can't tell you
Jackie Chan oh that's Jackie
yo another evil champ Jackie yeah in
four days Jackie Chan also from Atlanta
originally giving them some advice and
gangs done making his way back up here
hits him with the dab sends him back to
the setup
nice concise coaching session right
there I like it
he's like hey dude we're getting
something to eat after this yeah yeah
yo the USA champ came out of nowhere out
of nowhere yeah
and we're going to the arena
because we're in the arena because we're
in the arena
all right game two gang is done Winner's
side won't be out of the tournament if
he gets down here but you want to go to
this Winner's finals
keep At Your Service huh it's because
you're out here stealing rounds lady
tournaments Cooney Mitchell oh nice that
track and Harrier option right there
really starting to pay attention to the
fact that Alan likes the side step a lot
yeah and get the hairy transition you
actually want to sidestep right duck
right you can see how he's actually
doing that
and that's when you see the delays start
to add up for Genghis died he just takes
the space won't hit a button and make
you respect the move he's gonna do
afterwards nice check right there on the
set Dash exactly so low could go to
check it out here using the jab special
push towards the wall
I know oh cootie Miss with rage can't
stay down but it's scary to get him and
there we go Gangnam Style one one closed
out the first round okay okay
could have been a lot worse punish if I
was expecting that yo ma he's doing
strings yeah ganks is going in right now
going for the mid option since it's a
duck from Genghis Dodge both of them
trying to get away from the wall nice
block no punish
stop
[Applause]
waiting well Rising Two this is good to
the wall we go huh
back four hits beside the right duck
again to beat the Harry tracking But
Here Comes the big lows are adding up yo
gangs off with three rounds
two gank is gone
that's the way you want to answer back
in that situation
three rounds straight for Genghis Khan
what a robot three round straight versus
out Jackie what did you tell him what
did you tell him jackets read out what
you told him or just text me I Wanna
Know
now that's solid coaching right there my
man came back and run three rounds
straight
okay now that's coaching done though
first ever Evo might be guaranteed if
you can win this next game
he over there bopping right now
that versus that versus minion music
yeah Aldo
sticking it out with Cudi mitsu
switching the state though home court
advantage Vermillion Gates where we
headed kudi mitsu stage yo crowd I know
you guys are investing
you guys still want gang is done and
take it let me hear it out there let me
hear it out there
damn you guys were yelling for the
picture that was crazy
well let's see he's gonna be yelling
after this match in Victor your defeat
owl versus Gangster final game man it
was a fight game quote and victory or
defeat okay
was that from The Art of War what was
that from Zoo
let's see what Al does
a nice block
oh side step down 4-2 this time around
you talked about him doing it against
the wall no combo breakable balcony
right there yeah that's not the right
very impactful you have a big snake and
sweeps
the big laws are calling out and they're
working uh bro look at the damage all
the big
[Applause]
don't know
he went a little too far yo ow and then
ow
you know what I got some lows too
[Music]
oh the Harrier stands low they're
starting to add up hour in a bad
position against the wall yeah but he's
fighting out of it just fine with booty
mid to here
oh God himself is it enough damage Steve
it looks like damage uh uh that point
for out and Steele would have got the
wall yo you guys better make some noise
the game gets done this might be his way
this is his only opportunity right now
to stay up on this winter side yeah he's
going in Harrier jumping low all the
Harry Victors got
ninjas they're so tricky don't go
anywhere
else
don't stare at the birdie
walk gang is done
this is gonna put Alan rage
yeah we haven't seen a rage but there's
a rage yard instead and that should be
that
ow it's gonna take it over gang is done
going to Winners finals to face arslawn
Ash
well played Genghis Khan but now it's
gonna be the one advancing in this
bracket right now
oh man holy moly what a start
[Applause]
game's always this intense man we've
been talking about Tekken for so long
specifically Tekken seven yeah and when
I tell you that the games get so intense
the ceiling for this game I feel like
every year it goes higher but we're like
man we've seen the craziest thing the
craziest players what characters gonna
come up next and then we see these
players get on the stage we've seen
Genghis dining for the first time
playing amazing and look at the exhaust
the relief in Al's face right there I
mean you look back at round one of that
final game there and gangston hit the
snake as though then hit the other alone
did he try to gimmick him out with the
low kick string out ready for it got the
punish baxton got his load there and
that was that it was stalled around back
at the last second gang just over
extended a little bit and gave up the
momentum I mean it happens though you're
starting to get that momentum to be like
hey you know what I'm winning now let me
go in but after that that last game the
second game that gang is down one you
saw the complete switch up he's like you
know what let me get a little more
Offensive start at the check a little
more and I felt like that's why he was
brave enough to do that rage right right
there we saw a lot of hairier
transitions you need to interrupt those
on top of that Cooney Mitchell kind of
has the same game with the set Dash
right you really have to check her from
doing it if not she can get away with
murder in that sense yeah and games
didn't put a decent job of checking
early we saw the low case coming out I
think it was in game two so overall a
very close game obviously final round
situation our final game situation at
least man and this right here when I
tell you that the momentum was so strong
on the side of Genghis Khan and right
there going for that string that's a
very common round Ender for Katarina but
the thing about it is if it's
predictable it's pretty funny
Evo top six wins out of the bracket big
call out there on the Harry transition
with the rage yard Al prepared for it
you gotta let her off for their three
games like all right I got raised this
time he's like I don't let you get away
with it no more oh man that was a really
smart play though and let's take one
more look at the bracket the winners
finals is secured so either arsenash or
Al will be getting to that Grand Final
and one of them's gonna have to fight
their way through losers which is a
little more set up down there game is
Don versus male ill is our losers score
finals match and then after that it is
old song versus
absolutely incredible matches lined up
down there in that lower bracket but
Ultron Anakin man that is incredible
dude that is a big match you know Anakin
has had a couple of top eight finishes
throughout the history of Tekken seven
uh also not so many right so this is
gonna be a very big test for both of
them look I know Osan loves some tech
and I know he he's always sought after
that big victory but also the same for
Anakin you said he's been on the stage
quite a few times right I want him to
bring it home I would love to it but
before we go any further we're gonna
take a quick a shark a small break but
we got more attacking seven Evo 2023
right after this
thank you
[Music]
well my order just got extra fighter
coins and street fighter order any
entree in the Chipotle app using promo
code
hdkn236 and received 250 fighter coins
with yours visit chipotle.com sf6 for
details
you got this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
be
the best
but it's dangerous these are incredible
steaks
you're going to be forced to make Split
Second decisions that could cost you
your life get out whether you like it or
not you are in this race
get in the fight yes sir Gran Turismo
based on a true story reading PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
PlayStation
foreign
[Music]
yo you guys ready for some more taking
out there let me know you're still with
me give me a little bit of noise
there we go that's all you guys are
perfect perfect cause we got four
matches anyway I don't want you to lose
your voice early like these like me
I mean it's been wild out here already
of course right but we just saw our
winter side of the brackets squared away
arth and Ash getting it done against
ulthan earlier and then we just saw Al
get it done against genghisdom which
sets of course our upper bracket final
winner final gonna be arson Ash versus
Al which is a run back Steve of course
we'll talk about that later but that was
a wild one of the twt finals y'all want
to see where we go here I believe this
next match is going to be a doozy anyway
because once again I feel like it's so
much sweatier now to get off to get past
any part of this bracket is so hard like
no matter where you go every one of
these players is actually ridiculous and
like I said before a lot of them outside
of gang is done have been here before
they know exactly what it takes to get
there the nerves probably the hardest
thing to shake on the stage without a
doubt man and of course the players that
you know we have yet to see more ill and
Anakin oil is just one of these guys
just super consistent in placing him
very high in turn it's making multiple
top eights in places where other players
cannot consistently do it for some
reason he's able to do it but of course
Anakin is the USA representative he's
back here top three evil 2019 right that
was the wild one where arson took out D
in the grand finals right now Arthur's
First Evo Vegas Victory and Anthony got
third of that tournament so now back
here in the top six mix there he is on
the stage currently as well getting
ready to play out his match with Olson
wow so as we're gonna get Anakin versus
alsan first on the losers side of the
bracket one of these players one of
these ridiculous Tekken players is about
to go home they're gonna join you in the
audience
and we just saw Olson had that
Incredibly Close set with Arsenal just a
little bit earlier today but you can see
their stats here of course first prince
here 2018 for old Sonic Evo six total
appearances and his best result has been
a 13th Place finish back at evil 29 the
one that Anakin had his best results in
the third place oh wow you can see it
right now first appearance 2014 for
Anakin a total of eight Evo appearances
up on that stage that's how many times
he's been there and of course his best
results Evo 2019 third and it can
definitely one of the best players in
the country we've seen what happened
when they go on the world stage Anakin
definitely one of the pillars of USA
Tech yeah I think he had a tweet
yesterday he talked about how he had a
rough start to the year in terms of
placements Etc but here he is at the
biggest show of them all getting into
that top six here and let's see how far
he can go obviously this sort of a
situation Anakin is yet to play today
and usan is coming off of a loss and
that always kind of plays it players
mental sometimes I always think that's
strange like you got to go in you just
lost but you got to go right back here
go back in that's the way tournaments
work you don't get the you don't get the
luxury of just relaxing all the time not
when you make it up on the stage and
he's going back to the Bob it looks like
Anakin of course gonna be sticking to
the Jack yo the Jack my man has been
with a big body since as long as I can
remember the long-standing Jack player
but I got a question before we get ready
for the next battle
what's the question yo Evo if you guys
would like and attend to take it make
some noise
yo that's love that's love right there
you know it man
but here we go Osan with the Bob and
it's been impressive as we stick with
Bob here you know we've seen that
t-shirt the Fang main 2022 is the
character used throughout most of the
terms yesterday but the boss comes out
here in the top six Anakin versus Olson
USA versus Korea all right let's get it
started Battle of the big boys
hey
big lead brand getting ready to start oh
four two hits so far away right there
and swing these four twos here for multi
oh wow what a crosstalk
step two big counter hey big damage
right here from old sign yo geez
one
round number one
goes to Anakin
oh County
that's a big boot oh wow beautiful
that's
a little bit different than other hot
picks in the game
oh get up
Anakin known
for being one of the most oppressive
Jack players out there put you in a
situation where you feel like you can't
do much
also I'm doing a great job of tempering
all that while standing for for the
punish all right and that was a great
blocking that down back one there
and here we go round three to kick it up
and Define the counter hit down four two
happy hitting a button to get lost by
that one Walter here for both sides
oh okay oh wow walk the Jackhammer I
feel like you don't see that often all
right it's an important look to sidewalk
right you can sidewalk and left that is
the direction he's down for two launch
and we'll attract you to something you
have to be aware of and you can still
see also committing to that left bar
side step as well
from Jack punishes it instantly with the
whiff all side two rounds to one here
and this loses quarter
yeah one thing you may not appreciate
about Hometown is the incredible speed
that he moves with yeah
we got to get a way to monitor how many
moves yeah it's like an 8pm right
look at this sidewalk again for that
Jack Cam he's ready he's so fast this
movements
we saw what happened last time the
downforce he found his Mark waiting for
the application plant more seeds
yeah old song way behind here though
Anakin huge lead
sure you can accept I don't think so
down before Superman gets final round
game one
getting a little Fed Up goes for a big
launcher right there from Anakin
duck behind a big loss of bulls on here
ah two rounds of Peace here gonna get
the wall big damage on the board also
442 follow-up is good too and just out
of rank that time
down Jab
etes
actually gone this is the combo but the
low is okay oluson hangs on to get that
first game okay okay very scrambly right
there especially towards the end
Anakin down a game right now Olson
chugging the water and the interesting
thing about this magic too you know one
of Jack's core moves in neutral is that
standing too right incredibly long range
against most characters however against
Bob Bob's jabber exactly so good and you
can see also using that single day I'm
just a punish the signal two attempts
from jackromanikin
yeah you can see him really leading with
that Bob jab right just to like close
the distance it's a little harder for
Jack to retaliate and go for some of
those lows that we know Anakin likes to
go for
let's see what happens to game two
yo guys make some noise for Anakin out
there my man is down he is from the USA
he is from the USA
loser bracket match
down forward super mannequin take him to
the wall bop bop bop
just barely misses it could have had a
follow-up but it's okay 2-1 hits him on
the side
you see Osan getting really anxious to
get away from this corner right here
quick side step left oh wave a wave
as you start to call out those sides
them too but big lead also now spend the
rage mode with the rage Drive good 50
gets blocked and gets all in first round
while standing two strings to start it
off and one just for the record
again movement is so good for both on
I'm glad you pointed out because you
always talk about how old side moves
like crazy bro he's so fast
and sometimes it gets him in trouble
because he wants to just move so much
[Applause]
the pickup
big damage and again
start the string on the wall up two
rounds in the second game
and has the weed on top speeds Planet
trees save the Earth even the robots
understand it
I don't think so
one one
hey wait a minute wait a minute eyes on
the crowd making noise for the boy and
can't hold on
that's ATL's very own the chosen one
one game eats your final game situation
loser goes home
thinking about it on that random select
I know uh Olson likes Kinder jam oh no
Howard estate oh this is sick another
maker of a song bro I think I turn the
music up I definitely got to turn the
music up harada I know you can hear me
release the Tekken 8 soundtrack all
right I'm done all right
oh the crowd getting restless out there
the crowd getting restless out there I
feel it too it's okay that'll tingle on
the back of your neck that's good ass
Tech
the show begin
round one final game Anakin versus Olson
and he tried the Apple to start in the
round again doesn't find it we'll get up
needs to be careful the stage has
multiple walls and about holy moly what
a choice right blade and low
down one the low starting to add up for
Bob as well trying to set the president
with that jab wow just confirm
and just a little dangerous position
with that breakable wall behind him
though
while standing one hey
hey big damage
foreign
[Applause]
lows
spring
also I'm getting the lead in this third
game Jackhammer pick it up doing the
whole
oh big
hold on trying to size it right this
time what firms it and confirms it this
time around there's a beautiful call out
too to beat the low one round each
song going off right now
my man geese is like it's it's somebody
in my bedroom
he's like the turn of the music
and one four Bob has a lot of strings
that if you don't know he can get away
with abusing
strong defense on both sides likely he's
still in favor of Osan right now but
this positioning we're on the stage all
looking good for Anakin not so much
longer big launcher right here yeah that
was a huge Direction about launch but
now just to pick the Cincinnati one
round away from staying in the
tournament guys make some noise for Anna
can my man is in trouble big trouble
this time
now it's a big mix up for Okie in that
situation after Jack Hammer hits yeah
looking for the Okie right there
he's gonna put him on the wall
dangerous position big damage on top of
that
hell sweep's good Anakin got raid
doesn't lock 20 no confirmable fun oh my
gosh oh my God
[Applause]
days in the tournament
yo guys do me a favor do me a big favor
can y'all make some noise but USA the
ATL's very own
That's my boy that's my bro
Anakin going out here at fifth place
this year Evo 2023 but also moving on
into the top four Staying Alive here on
this loser side of the bracket we saw
his match versus our slot so you know
you know he wants to get that run back
and look at the pop off from Olson right
there as he gets the victory over Anakin
hard fought at that the Jack still doing
work for the boy Anna can I love the
commitment not gonna be able to get it
done here versus old sign but the show
goes on I'm still surprised that we're
seeing so much of the Bob here you know
I really thought we were going to see
morphing I thought that you know we
might see the switch up back to Kazumi
same it's Bob all the way through the
top six so far look Bob is one of those
characters I feel like not a lot of
people keep him in the rotation right
but if you can execute with Bob you can
get into your opponent's mind he is so
good the wave Dash makes up the strong
mids great launchers on top of that
Bob's one of those characters I'm glad
he's sticking with him yeah you have to
have the execution to pull it off though
right ulsan has the execution to pull it
off as you've seen here time and time
again I mean he's going for some crazy
stuff too the way but we're playing for
like three waves away like dog that's a
little crazy I mean Anakin did have a
couple of great call outs on the
defensive side just waiting for those
big launchers down four two in a lot of
instances we're all Rising Two to start
some of the strings as we go back to
this first game and you can see it was
all well collected even to the point
where you saw Anakin back dash and that
power Crush at the wall just playing
really defensively in the best way
possible but his first game not so clean
on the side of uh Anakin yeah it was
close is very back and forth and but
this was the end of it right here right
down to the wire and he could have had a
launcher didn't find it Anthony gets to
throw to switch position at least
which is a smart move too you see a lot
of people use those two throws to change
positions not expecting a string right
after that but that's gonna do it for
Anakin actually closes out going home
with fifth like you said before but
still a great showing here at Evo 2023
especially the consistency we've seen
from Anakin throughout the years of this
game exactly potentially the last year
of Tekken 7 and Evo Anakin multiple top
eight finishes across those seven years
of Tekken seven out here it's a
beautiful thing to see man it's a
beautiful thing to see is we take one
more look at this bracket we're getting
down to it guys loser semifinal is
almost confirmed we saw it with Olson in
that Victory but the next match our last
remaining USA competitor Genghis Dawn
will be going up against Mayo ill and
it's gonna be a good one Mayo ill
definitely one of these players I feel
like once again kind of slides under the
radar because you look at all these
other really big names but if you know
about male oil you know just how
dangerous he is in any bracket among any
players exactly Mario you know you've
been watching him I've watched a lot of
the Korean terms right there freaking
technically tournament and in those
tournaments it's so hard for even the
big names that you recognize like John
ding jdcr saying to even make top eight
in those and Moyle is in that topic
almost consistently every time it's
ridiculous no it says a lot about just
how consistent he is as a player and on
top of that the competition he plays
with there's not many people that can
even get that far considering I mean
that's like the best players in Korea
you know what I'm saying so exactly and
the team they're on kdf here with Bulls
on Moy Hill also have CBM as well you
know that group has been so strong this
past year year and a half as you've seen
two of them in this top six itself oh
man it's getting real dicey out there
and these games are getting really
sweaty but we have to take another break
before we get back to this Tekken 7
Action this is the top six of Tekken
seven at Evo 2023 I know you guys are
enjoying it stay tuned losers quarters
coming up right after this
new chicken alpaced door is fire on
every level fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground achiode balanced with
a splash of pineapple all combined for
the right amount of heat Chipotle's all
new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
[Music]
oh
don't kill me
PlayStation
oh no
super Rola
Victory feels good yes
yes
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
all right
anyway
s
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
come on
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the evolution championship series
here at the Mandalay Bay in Las Vegas
all right now real quick now before we
get into some more top six Tekken seven
we're gonna have a little special
segment brought to you by our friends
over at atnt now I know most of you are
all familiar with the game of high card
so we are going to play some high card I
got some very lucky contestants up here
what's your name I'm Bryce we got Bryce
right give it up for Bryce real quick
come on yeah Bryce
all right once we got name's John
name's John John
[Applause]
Roberto Give It Up
Andrew Andrew one more time for Andrew
mark
and Mark so please one more time Make
some noise for our contestants off here
all five of them yeah yeah
all right now no cheating
everybody pick a card don't cheat
and do not reveal them
do not reveal that these are for your
eyes only
all right has everyone seen their card
you sure
this guy doesn't play poker
he's got something good he doesn't play
he's got something good
all right are we all ready to see to
play some games are you ready let's do
it
okay
are you ready
please reveal your card my good sir
all right okay I mean there's a lot of
cards higher than the three but who
knows we'll see
if you would please Michael sir
[Applause]
all right all right so we got a sorry
dude we got a three a seven all right
let's go let's go let's go oh
were these in an order hold on a second
did we Shuffle those
All Right contestant number four
[Music]
Hearts the Flora hearts
let's see if he does or does not play
poker I could be totally wrong
let's see I knew it oh my God I knew it
[Applause]
all right guys before we give up prizes
one more time to all your competitors up
here to play a little game of high card
are we ready oh my God look at this oh
what do we got here oh
whoa
[Applause]
whoa and
uh correct me if I'm wrong am I right
that those are
first second and third place the trick
sticks
our regular Adventure sticks everyone
those are the gold the silver and the
brown the Broderick sticks
[Applause]
very cool yeah show them give them some
love yeah
yeah come on
I knew he was gonna win dude I knew it I
saw his face
he was like
all right guys thank you very much also
thank you big time to our friends over
at ATT for hooking us up at the evil
family we appreciate you guys for this
thank you very much for our game of
golden draw thank you guys very much hey
uh rip and tasty Steve you guys ready to
get this Tech in action let them know
you guys want this Tech in action
wait wait wait wait Make some noise for
the amazing the immaculate l-i-o
[Applause]
shout outs to the winner shout outs to
ATT for holding us down and shout outs
to victory victrix for giving us those
sick first second and third place stick
of course respectively gold silver and
bronze those are very cool man not a lot
of people even have those of course
because you gotta win EVO to get them so
whatever
easy
you think so I don't know why not with
that guys give me about the two guys
that didn't win the sticks tonight
come on dude um
but regardless hopefully you guys are
still enjoying this evil 2023 we are on
Tekken seven there are still games to be
played you guys ready for some Tekken
Make some noise
uh feels good here in the arena Steve of
course we had one of our loser bracket
matches already Anakin going home with
fifth place but we got another one right
we got Genghis Don going up against moyo
it's gonna be USA versus Korea in this
one and this one's Gonna Be Wild Man boy
look at that smile on his face he's
ready you cannot be mad he looks so
curious
but you can't be man look at the cheeks
look at his cheeks look at those cheeks
how happy he is
Santa Claus like lab I love it
but you can be mad at him because he
plays Keith Howard Steve yeah I mean
look the only other people hate 2D
characters I'm okay with it I like these
he's a cool guy one of the coolest bad
guys I've ever seen but of course
representing South Korea uh first
appearance 2020 a total of four
appearances this is not his first time
on the stage and we talked about the
fact that he's more than well prepared
and his best result was Evo 2022 and he
got fifth place that was last year and
if you lose this one Steve fifth place
again
opportunity to move ahead and improve
his best results that's what I'm saying
here it's an opportunity I like how
optimistic you are rip that is fantastic
bad at all no negative in any way
everything's an opportunity he's never
he's never played City that's true
all right first off shout outs to two
ugly Esports bro how did y'all get that
name
you said that I thought you were talking
about someone why would I come on I
don't know man I was like why would you
do that
oh man but gang is done obviously
representing the USA Mayo ill
representing Korea and give us your
predictions you can see it right down
there join the conversation at twitch.tv
slash Evo if you haven't already tell
your friends
we might be screaming a few people right
now Steve we might be streaming to quite
a few people actually yo look at mail
it'll stick that thing is beautiful yo
wow what is going on over there yo look
it matches his smile I tell you what
oh man this could be wild though you
know Korea they actually have a Katarina
player named galgonji and he's really
really good with Katarina one of the
best in Korea with them so they have
experience against this character
genghisdon's style though a little
different yeah I mean look and a lot of
people we talk about how you know even
though you fight the same character
across the world they can be played
differently especially I feel like in
Tekken because there's so many varying
play Styles around the globe so being
able to fight somebody even though you
might have a little more character
familiarity it's still really hard to
kind of get a beep you're still gonna
have to go through the proper courses
before you're going to be able to have
like a confident feel or maybe you just
go in swing exactly and you guys have
seen this throughout this weekend this
is the first time we've seen so many
players do this but they've been
bringing blankets or jackets something
to hide their controllers underneath wow
their presence yo the Mind battle
already happened you try to hit him with
the dappy covered his hands man people
eats Rock dude the mental battle has
already started
all right well game on here we go game
one Steve all right guys here we go this
is the loser side of the bracket if you
guys would like the USA's very own
you'll see it on his chest gang is done
to take it make some noise
boys
that's love
boy Hill here second back to back Evo
top eight finish let's see way ends up
Genghis Don gonna try to put an end to
his run here Katarina versus geese
Howard
of course the metaphor geese has
definitely changed a little bit still
very strong but now people seem to have
a little counter they're looking for
that back three to activate right that
will be a lot more aware of the gauges
and like yo I can't let him get started
here obviously those projectiles are
going to be the name of the game but you
see Genghis already using the third
dimension to get around there exactly
use those sizes but now positions
himself towards the wall here a little
bit dangerous but Goose Howard here that
doesn't walk like what it used to
that side step three just being super
super aggressive right now oh nice that
gang is not afraid to go for the big
lows and look of all caught up in hell
oh the Harrier stance is starting to
come out of here take them to the wall
if you can't a chair hey
that jumps in no bar you gotta finish it
now
one bar I mean in the bottom left it
doesn't spend it no punish for the
downpour in one check finds it okay okay
King is done taking the first round
first Blood first bubble on the board
yeah back to the space and moyo is very
very good at actually managing that
meeting with g s Howard one of the girls
they've given them is that they've
actually slowed down that beat again
throughout the season
no that's definitely true it definitely
changes the pace of all the way pieces
play uh but it also slows down the pace
of the game overall going for the low
Perry pink is down on the Run side step
three
taking another successful round two
rounds straight right now
taking control of the matchup away from
Boyle right now
God this song is such a big the Game Boy
I'm sorry too it's sick yeah
wall pressure right now gang is not
finishes the string looking for
something big backswing blow no punish
right there but that was supposed to
gang is done go look at the series right
now I told you just because you got the
experience versus somebody else that
ain't me Buckle yeah
gets done
[Applause]
yo you said he's got experience though
versus one of the best katarinas in the
world that means nothing the gang is
done I'm a conqueror bro check the name
oh my goodness
King is done
Dominic first game there and he's
bouncing he's out here he's out I'm
taking a lap bro taking a breather
we saw it last time went and went and
had a little talk with
Jackie Tran another Evo champion from
the tech in four days I like the camera
where'd he go go like a ninja he
disappeared
nah man shout outs to this taken seven
competition man it's really dope to see
this game played at such a high level
man the ceiling like I said before I
feel like it moves every year every
update we go up another level we see
another player we see another character
that rises to the heights man this game
really does Supply the fields I mean
call me crazy but I wouldn't mind a
couple more years of Tekken seven even
yo you need to chill bro I just see
those characters Raven is back dude did
you not see that old son Arsenal match
would you started off with you know what
all right you got a good point
all right abandoned temples where we're
headed though
bro that dude is cool
round one too close huh
game two
he's so stupid
oh they dancing a little bit obviously I
like they like the song
Yeah Boy I'll really slowing things down
and you know I've seen him lose plenty
of first games that really make great
adaptations going forward to still bring
the setback so even if you're getting
signed if you don't want the first game
three rounds to eight can't be
comfortable here and look at how he's
starting to adjust already to the
Harrier transition doesn't stop him from
putting his back to this wall and only
about half meter there nice sidewalk
right yeah I got it step two Hopkins
save lives
much like a life preserver
oh no break
the third dimension
[Applause]
oh man goose is like I didn't even know
you can do that you ever sidestepping
Fireballs they don't do that in my game
yo this is Craig the four rounds fake
gang is Donald foil is not something I
would have seen coming in or would have
expected coming in
great patience on both sides though
Genghis dying really jogging for this
position close to the wall Mayo fighting
back with the geese the Clean Cut
three-piece suit piece yeah Genghis is
not giving him opportunity to find big
damage right like he's got that bar up
here he should be fishing for back three
too believe he's betting me to defense
this week we have to forward to pick up
and he's not getting a ton of damage
like we used to see from geese Howard
and look at that he's the hit for the ex
Fireball and that actually takes him out
and there's the Hop kicking his time
he's gonna get real close to this wall
it doesn't get the Wall come from the
angle hands off Lady this is a
three-piece suit you see it shining yeah
boils in trouble in 13 seconds he's
almost to a barometer though if he's
going to get some damage here's the
bartender stand up stand up time winding
down the five seconds rage is there
jumping range
[Music]
yo listen for the Tycho drums
[Applause]
kidding there we go
one round each Genghis rage out there a
little early had plenty more time left
on the clock poof
oh wow what a rip punish hop kick thing
is done yo he's playing very well right
now
look at the wall
on the tear
and Boyle he's so behind on meter here
he's a big trouble gang is down at set
point Mayo ill and the trouble needs to
make an adjustment if he wants to get a
chance to fight back here and stay alive
in this tournament he has not made one
good exchange of meter in his entire set
so far what'd you say rip he is
damage
once again I'm not sure what geese can
do to punish that but I mean look he's
got the bar meter he's got to cash in on
it sometime
oh the single Jazz are crazy right now
spend the meter again but he finds a hit
this time give
him
the full goblin games has a chance with
rage here big money they only can close
this out
right here
Harrier transition once again what a jab
hands off me gang is not a close down
not gonna be on doing final round game
two wait a minute gang is done in
trouble right now Mandalay Bay you're
looking ridiculous out there thank you
guys for pulling up and still though
it's that boy Brooke gang is thought he
gets his round he moves on in the
bracket boyo if he loses out of the
tournament he's trying to get another
bar meter so he can cash it bigger
um Carry Your transition this time goes
for the mid what's up
taking him to the wall
one bar me
or take you into the crowd is building
it's building you can hear it that's it
hands off the merchandise but though
yo that USA it's rumbling mark on the
wall can he get it done that's why
you're fighting back right now Doug you
can have the Raging
God
[Applause]
taking it over Mayo ill
wow what a set gang is God's thing in
the tournament USA moving the top four
of Evo 2023. what a what is the name
first performance here but guys do me a
favor but do me a favor before Mayo ill
leaves that stage Make some noise
back to back fifth place Evo 2022 and
Evo 2023 for moyo they're very nicely
done from Korea but Genghis Don moving
into that top four oh man what a match
Genghis Don keeping the momentum
throughout the entire set and you're
we're looking for that transition where
he's like look if he gets barred right
he likes to take control he likes to
take that momentum and all it takes is
one time for him to get a combo take it
to the wall and the damage is more
mental damage well I accidentally real
damage a lot I mean but the thing is he
never landed it right that entire set
along I mean Genghis started four rounds
played against him too but entire set
gangstan who's preventing him from using
that meter to that effect geese Howard
usually as you mentioned finds that
meter catches it off and moyo's so good
at doing it usually did not find
openings there I mean if you look at one
of the things that happened I feel like
we're moving the fireball game was very
strong early sidesteps making sure you
don't feel comfortable doing it and then
there's just the entire fact of like
just getting over it the hair your
transitions was really starting to work
out and the minute that Mayo ill was
like you know what I want to start
swinging magic forehead counter hit the
Hop kick started
to work out and they weren't like they
were punishers they were with punishing
so whenever they whipped the hot pick
was there waiting and gangistan was
waiting for the crowd to Make Some Noise
for him right there after that win as we
get into losers semi-final which will be
Genghis Khan versus Olson yo damn what a
match but look look at the regional
diversity in the top four Pakistan
versus Japan winner final USA versus
Korea loses semi-finals across the board
it looks like we started in the winter
side of the semifinals dude this is
beautiful I love look when I go to a top
six or any top format I love to see the
players there oh a lot there's a lot of
diversity we are going to the winners
finals oh my gosh here we go arceland
Ash versus Al Pakistan versus Japan
incoming winners final win of this go to
the Grand finals and guarantees a top
two finish for themselves here at Evo yo
rip I thought you said this was a run
back talk to me about this a little bit
exactly do you guys go back to the team
BT finals Amsterdam earlier this year in
February these two met in pool play and
Al actually took out our at the Nash 2-0
in that match up there so Al is capable
of winning against Arsenal but this will
be a longer set it's best to five it's
first to three this time around also
different and that's that it was out
with kudi mitsu versus Austin block and
zafina so in this case aren't they gonna
run the kudi mitsu mirror match are we
gonna see different characters we're
gonna find out in just a second I would
be really interested to see if arceland
runs the mirror match or even if Al
allows the mirror match I mean not sure
what character's gonna go to I think I
think he still has a little Miguel in
there but who knows we're gonna find out
just coming up but this is gonna be a
good one winners finals coming up right
here best of five first to three and
this is gonna be electric of course like
we said before arsenaline no stranger to
the pressure you just saw how well Al
has performed over the last 10
appearances here at Evo so it's gonna be
good exactly he's very familiar with the
evolution stage but out here gonna be
one of the few players in the world who
has a win in a set over Arsenal and Ash
so arson as we talked about earlier he
doesn't have he doesn't have to call me
he doesn't have Khan here to go up again
so it kind of feels like it's his
tournament to win but this is one of
those players who cast off them in the
past yeah now look a lot of times what
happens in competitive fighting games
the better you get the bigger the Target
on your back arcelain Ash has the
biggest Target in Tekken I'm telling you
right now a digital Hitman every player
in the bracket is trying to take him out
because they know just how strong he is
but Al like you said before I think you
can count on what less than one hand how
many people of VR so maybe definitely
less than two in tournament and that is
something a major to say
man this should be good I'm so curious
about what characters we're gonna see in
this set here
Arthur has used the Safina a little bit
but primarily has been sticking to that
Cooney mitsu
I'm gonna get the characters locked in
all right guys while they're doing their
thing I'm gonna do my thing if you guys
would like Orson act to take this
winners final set Make some noise
or if you guys would like to see Al from
Japan take it makes them no
I like that I like the upset people
they're like you know what I want a
change of the Guard this arson guy is
nice but I want Al to take it I'd love
to see it I love to hear it I like the
honesty and look what we get here boys
and girls we get the mirror match we get
Kuni mitsu versus Kuni mitsu yo and I'm
gonna tell you right now both of these
characters well I want to say first and
foremost Al kind of excels at playing
these heavy Pope friendly characters
right I thought I thought he still had
the Miguel but sticking with the queen
Adventure is really good to the In and
Out game is very strong he's really good
at really annoying you right I mean you
gotta remember too remember Austin made
a tweeted a while ago where you talked
about how he didn't think kudovic was
that great of a character and then Al
kind of came on and see if they're like
look at what I can do with this Chanel
came out she said look what I can do
with this and then Art's like maybe that
character is pretty good let me pick
that one up
yo just rushing in playing mad
disrespectful
yeah we got arson in the purple this
time
oh nice gets the kunai yeah kunak from
downtown and now the step two back to
back that's the Doppler one three
interesting
quick side step playing the range game
just a bit
looking for you to reach the down four
two oh the top gets the counter hit oh
big damage here
damn
first round arson here
oh what a side step his steps have been
so good
look at the side there
yeah and sliced up right against
Cleveland's is pretty good but you have
to know when to do it against what
strings right the two just fighting
Revenge from doing it the bachelor as
well oh nice polks
oh calling out the high again and we
printed the downward one thing out ties
it up mine's doing strings
down forward one all day standing 2-2
all day but really it's been the size of
rights that really have been playing it
backward in this matchup
sidewalk right again
I like this give us the tick show us the
2-2 hours ready for the matchup uh he is
actually ready for the matchup balcony
still not broken but we're going to the
wall Arts line and trouble hey God damn
it look at that
before a Crusher right now from out was
ridiculous too this is what I was
talking about I'll excels at that
annoying pulp friendly gameplay gives
you barely gives you time to breathe
oh Mr pork I'll sweep there oh I get
this time not enough to have to kill
here 50 50 and now closes out the round
wow looking pretty good two rounds to
one right now in this first game
Winner's final
small pulley
oh the balcony is it broken ah get out
of here back to break it wow the hulky
was too far yeah and on top of that she
was head down uh uh face up so it's like
feet away
yeah the 1-1 arson had the sidewalk that
time
and just instantly answers back with a
set Dash yeah because these characters
because this character strings are so
safe you have to have the sidewalk
defensive options to counter the
followers both of them go for sweeps
arson's got the rage you haven't seen
the race drive yet from Cooney Mr today
that's actually true there it is there
we go
is it enough
the mix back to mix final round game one
and Arthur just never seems to go away
my man is always in the running it's
crazy it's crazy how good Iceland is
good 10 frame punish there on the
downpour one two
oh my gosh not a counter it that was
lucky for Arsen
house back to this wall right now yeah
the set Dash fakes coming out now too
all set three
slow pace game here oh wow he's fun back
yo these side steps are going crazy to
do two strings go big block
seeing it coming
the rage is there not gonna they both
have rage right now blue stuff
hey arthman hangs on for the first game
oh man it's getting sweaty
man the decision making of when to pull
out the risky attacks right owl pulled
out a very risky low there and arson had
the block against it then that's what
got him that huge combo and then Arthur
went for a risky High string and attack
but Al was not prepared got hit by it
that's what closed out the round yo you
heard what Cooney mitsu says when she
wins if you need a thief I'm your woman
they're trying to steal from each other
and accomplishes nothing
I'll keeping the stick dry I hear you
bro I know it's sweaty up there very
very close first game though
Vermillion Gates
mirror match on the home take on the
home stage on top of that
[Music]
all right
all right all right I heard y'all out
there yo Mandalay Bay I hear you out
there I'm glad you guys don't join this
Evo bro I'm glad you guys are enjoying
it it's amazing
game two here winners final best of five
situation and arson has the lead 1-0
over owl
man that black mask is ridiculous
[Music]
probably keeping the outfits here purple
for Arsen again oh no break uh-oh
trouble
and I love the way out excuse me I love
the way arson kind of staggers this
offense he really changes up I feel like
from game to game making the adjustments
like oh you really did swing here you
did like the duck here you did like to
get away here it just adds it to his
gameplay that's one of the reasons he is
so good
and after two two string that time out
duck there Arthur just checking to see
what his reaction would be
said two
great mid move out of that set Dash oh
and it's really starting to add up it is
and arson again that down back three
creates around him he goes with quite a
lot but usually you know he calculates
life exactly so you know this is going
to be enough damage before he goes for
it hits a button after the back turns
position throw and you can see arth is
getting comfortable now
oh God oh my gosh
just adding to the stack right now
damage on the wall big at that
all in trouble
[Music]
okay punished there though
I'll use that move for cooking my suit
gets the grab out of it
wake up the wall saving lives once again
still gonna get great damage and radius
there the blue stuff oh my gosh
oh
geez come on rip I was ready to turn
around and look at stuff it wasn't
supposed to pounce off like that
look at that that said Dash finishes the
string once again what a check yeah that
I think exactly what got our last game
right now
in Austin with the ducking lost that
time overextending just a bit too much
art from Ash senses the pressure since
there's a frustration and look at this
damage on the wall once again arson Ash
what a lead
2-2 find and smart now trying to fight
away from the wall that down back
through you talked about it this time
I'm sick of those
out with the low bang walls right there
though
damage
he sides up the race Drive Arthur Nash
oh man our foot
already
broken game two point here and it is not
getting any easier for Al have to make
some big changes
drop the combo nice punish there
man I love arson that does that on the
wall
gives you a little more damage oh
I was in the park right now
looking to run away with his arm
s Big Lots
Nash gets one more game Grand finals is
where he's going and he's looking so
comfortable doing it if you're out here
right you have other characters you
could go to the Miguel you mentioned
Back in the Day 2015 his main character
was Elisa back then right so that's a
character that's still pretty good in
this game and I don't know if it's
something he wants to pull out here I
would love to see it personally but the
cootie misses would have been rocking so
much I expect to see Cooney again no
that's the new Evo 12 vote that's the
first time I've seen that that looks
ridiculous new trophy design out here
this year and it sounds like they're
running it back with a rematch cootie
mitsu versus cootie mitsu
all right here we go ow in trouble
still alive in the bracket obviously but
he would be on that loser side we'll
have to make it back to the losers
bracket Genghis Don down there waiting
potentially
that two counter hit again
big damage goes for a reset instead no
break on the throw and look at Arsenal
and Ash right now yeah he's feeling like
he's planted through a little bit right
I mean right there was the bastard mix
up afterwards he didn't need that you
could have taken the damage I was like
no this is cool I got this yeah he's in
his head already right the med is
working out in his favor so you try to
go a little deeper into the meta right
right so I'm a little more off their
game yeah
back turn Spin Attack just to see if
they're gonna swing out oh small punish
there no wait oh wow tries to go for a
setup Arsenal says I'm not taking the
bait get off of me
10 seconds updates the kunai
ow holds in the distance forward four
two just enough with eight seconds left
on the club and you know when they
played the TDP finals Al had that crazy
key chart setup he did and Arthur had a
backflip away and he caught up with the
rage yard right so Al with rage is very
dangerous you can never predict what
he's gonna do
may my man Al has rage setups at sick
set two to get in there really closing
that distance a lot every time you see
Alvin pushed out he's like you know what
I need to get back in set pass away okay
back turn goals for the guests oh break
from Arson this time out with the lead
oh wow fake out and Arthur no he seems
to be willing to take full crowds low
mix
got em got down forward one drink is so
annoying
he might have got him
yo life really low left on the door
chunk of damage
the more damage the radar does
it's enough damage okay all right Al get
one on the board Arsenal don't seem two
phased though I mean he's got a two-game
lead right he's kind of chilling right
now
Full Throttle yeah
I mean all the Min mixes have not been
working out for Alice now he's going
back to the lows and that might be what
arson Watson can do if it's almost fixed
yeah and you can see right now that
setup that he's doing after the
knockdown you set Dash past him back
turn two that's one of arson's tricks
that was such a good win punish there
like
I'll still in the game
and arsenaline Ash going back to State
select you think he takes him in for
this year against another Cooney Mitch
in the mirror match I think so I don't
know
I would bet that he probably would
a lot of players seem to think that
going every state just you know limits
the amount of extra variables at Play
but I feel like arsenaline typically
goes to you know infinite stage he's
like you know what I don't want to deal
with this right right and I feel like in
the mirror matches more dealing with you
know what I know what this character can
do and maybe you switch it up maybe you
say you know what I do want these walls
and he's thinking about it pretty hard
here
wow okay oh that's the first time I've
seen him do this yeah Island Paradise
he's got two chances to take it out here
still ahead winners finals though Grand
finals is the destination you got to get
past one of the other right now if you
actually want to get there though and
you still got to worry about that loses
bracket one of these guys one of these
players will be down there fighting for
their life
yeah last year of course at evil when we
got to the top three Arsenal's fighting
through losers we thought we're going to
see the arson versus knee Grand bondsman
Khan put a stop to it right and it was
Khan versus knee in the grand finals and
now arson one step away one game away
from getting Grand finals himself here
we go
round one the mirror match Island
Paradise Arsenal and Ash up one game Alf
bringing it back yeah that was a great
job but it's there for downward one did
we get a float no it's so hard to punish
that man and just a little too late on
the follow-up right there so not gonna
get the punish oh wow it's getting wild
now just getting a little scrambly
down back three starting to add up yep
both of them both of them are using it
now yeah now actor was ready to dump
that time that's something that killed
him in the first game here and while
standing three we got him with the mix
no balcony at all Gonna Keep It intact
maybe break it on the next one arson
this match can lead to set point oh wow
finishes the Stream
oh we got answers right back at you
back turn guess goes for the low
going back to the folks down back three
once again Arsenal
invading the personal space
he's like yo you just trying to murder
my input I do that to eat it down with
it here's a humpty for you oh big damage
hella damage
pound jab wild standing for Al a nod
yeah he's in trouble it's that point for
Arsen
oh no break this time from Arsenal
uh is that what she says I don't think
so
as soon as you said that I heard it
finishing the swing oh
it's time to take some risk it seems
like I got it too speaking of taking
risk finishes the stream while standing
three nights oh gets a combo here
still those step one for arceland
give me that life lead him out
hands off
set three uh sidewalk two twos once
again tries to go for that back turn mix
Al doesn't take it swings in the middle
of that two string getting real Brave
right now arthan's back to the wall
quick side step left they're both
getting a little loser right now Lee's
late on the Jabs that's so cheap and now
Arthur looking gonna close down the down
back three's gonna do it in Arthur Nash
he's headed to the Grand finals
what a play right there Al definitely
looked like he was getting something he
looks like he was actually getting it
but then I'm telling you right now
arsen's round rebuttals are so good when
I tell you he went down that game he's
like okay all right I was getting away
with this I was able to do this I'm
gonna I'm gonna pressure this with her
the set dashes aren't working out as
much and we and he really took advantage
of that really switched it up gave him a
decisive game right after that out now
gonna go down to that loser side exactly
Al heading on down to that loser's
bracket now and arson Ash is in Prime
position to get that fourth Evo title
that's crazy winner side of the Grand
Final wow who's gonna have the
opportunity who's gonna do it can it be
done Arsenal and Ash are about to
looking at his fourth Evo title not just
in the States but in Japan as well white
the accomplishment that would be
incredible we'll see if he can do it's
not done just yet right we still have
some people left alive and determined
Genghis Dawn is still down there we know
now as well that we got um out down
there as well Al can still make the run
back I'll waiting at the Tail land
actually so what we got Genghis Don
versus Olson the next match coming up
the last USA representative yes going up
against Korea's last representative this
is actually going to be amazing and on
top of that whoever gets out now now out
of the running but we're going to have a
new Evo Champion or possibly a returning
one a four-time one with Arsenal Nash
yeah we'll see in just a second guys I
mean it's going to be pretty wild out
here though right I mean Genghis Dawn
versus ulsan
man look that's a tough cookie to crack
bro if your gang is done but you made it
here now you definitely got the tools to
do so but it's gonna be tough speaking
of tough this dude arceline Ash in this
last set versus Al really seemed like he
had a beep on exactly what needed to
happen and on top of that finishing the
string and like mirroring each other and
arson Ash is doing a little better job
there and that's the thing you know out
he knows that straight he knows you can
duck that in but in that instance right
there he did he got hit in that cost in
the first game that really put him
behind the whole set and that's it
really builds up momentum part to go to
up over him and that was just so hard to
come back from but there you see the
updated bracket Arsenal 3-1 over out
puts him in the winter side a grand
finals there just needs one more set win
to become another time evil Champion
Aldo in that loses final trying to find
his way back gonna be getting the win of
the loser semi-finals of Genghis Dawn
versus ulsan oh man we're getting to it
we're getting close to the end of this
Tekken seven top six like you said man
Al right there waiting potentially could
get another chance to take on Arsen if
he can make back to that winter side but
of course arsan waiting at Grand Final
side I know he's getting prepared
because he wants that fourth title he's
looking so comfortable he's almost like
he's like this is my time yes this is
right now he's definitely feeling it
right now exactly guys but we do have to
take a short break guys don't go
anywhere we're down to our top four
Tekken seven Evo 2023 continues after
this
Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients in real kitchens when
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurant pickup or
delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
it feels good
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we attendo are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each tenno product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
thank you
now
hello
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Tekken six we had Tekken six Tekken
seven we have the top six now we're down
to top four I'm here with the boy rip
it's the guy tasty Steve we're in
Mandalay Bay with an amazing crowd to
watch how this is about to unfold thank
you guys so much for joining us I can't
wait to get back to these taking matches
bro exactly top four incoming here guys
our next match of course going to be USA
versus Korea Genghis Dawn going up
against Olson and once again I have to
reiterate just how good Olson is took a
small Hiatus from taking yeah when he
came back steel just as dominant and
still just as strong which is crazy
enough no matter where he went was able
to get some of these top places like I
said before Genghis Don first time upper
on the stage but definitely a player
known in the USA especially on the
online side of things you talked about
how he took a little break but now he's
back again and look at what that is done
from look at what his gameplay has
evolved to to be on this stage in the
top four I mean I feel like I first
really got no Genghis Khan when we
started talking about the EU versus n a
rivalry right yeah because getting done
had that crazy one I think it was CEO
2021 maybe December but he took out a
couple of the EU top players and we're
like oh man Genghis Khan never started
memeing with him posting his images
right and so now he's got to his point
where we haven't seen him in as many
events really but now that he's here and
eu's not in the top six Genghis Khan is
the one still standing strong here at
the top four even and the first battle
the RPS goes to Old side
I like that that's become a part of the
meta right I feel like that's the first
battle like yo who wins yeah
yeah I think yesterday when I was
playing my match I played an RP someone
they beat me I was like well now I know
how you play right I see you're a rock
guy got it
exactly look at all song He's getting in
people's heads right he's wearing that
bang man since 2020 never using Fang in
his top six it's all Bob all the way so
far unless he switches it up here Steve
you know I wouldn't be surprised but
also he still has that Kazumi right yeah
Kazumi another character I talked to him
about this when he first came back I'm
like bro we don't see many kazumis how
do you feel about the character I know
they made some changes to her wall
damage a little different he was like
dude I still think this character's
really strong but I also feel like she
is a little bit more reserved we already
talked about Katarina over the seasons
of Tekken seven literally got better and
better and better and I feel like gang
is done is really putting this on
display much like this amazing Evo 2023
trophy oh my gosh to have that beautiful
house think about that you get to walk
in and the sunlight hits that bad boy
blinds you and you're like yeah I'm a
champ I mean think about it the evil
trophy hasn't changed forever right yeah
I mean I remember that trophy back in
like 2009 2010-ish so it's been over a
decade since they've updated the token
so that's the first major update to what
the trophy looks like with the sick
well we're gonna get a champion
potentially a new Champion here for Evo
but not of arson Ash has anything to say
about it waiting in that grand finals
but there's a few more battles left
there's a few more battles left who's
gonna get the fight Al who's about to go
home right now and now I have a question
if you guys would like also to take the
set Make some noise
oh man wow oh man I Like Your Allegiance
though I like that I like that rip ask
them the other question the other
question well hey if you guys would like
the USA's gang is Donna Take It Make
some noise
[Applause]
screaming like crazy I see you my God I
see you my guy
here we go
Genghis Don versus Olson
and the thing that's wild about this one
Olson's teammate from kdf boyo just
taken out by Genghis Dawn Olson also
plays he does a freak attacking League
tournaments where he has galgoni as a
training partner essentially for
Katarina and that didn't help moyo let's
see how he does here against Genghis
Don's Katarina here we go here we go
here we go to stay alive in this top six
for Tekken seven the next battle is
about to start let's go
and the character is going to be
Katarina versus Bob from Olson and we're
going back to the poolside stay Steve
what a banger of a son got Lee in the
background hanging out
you love this part right rep
the show begins talk to him Bob let the
show begin
here we go Wade was coming in
they dance just a little bit right now
lower started expected here
oh nice interrupt with the down four one
oh now oh yeah those questions
really good so far this is going to make
Gangsta slow down chain things up a
little bit finishes the string great
fun-ish yeah there's a lot of testing
going on side steps and the line for the
Harrier this time
Dad to finish yes sir first round and
we've talked about it right side to
Bright duck to beat the Harry option but
no one's really taking advantage and
punished big for it and that was the
first time we saw it that's a great
option too yeah right you said it yeah
and the attack on top of it though right
just to at least punish her once you get
that side step really fast mid really
strong that one right there is gonna be
a big game changer in this matchup
the strings crap stash one oh Crush oh
yo caddy Corner combos no not quite
get out of that corner
oh this is a dicey one the side sidewall
life preserversy
pulls out getting his dog ties up the
round count keep it close keep it close
such a good song Harry or low
caught swinging in the Mist there all
sign answers back when it down four one
while standing four Really Gonna Stop
some of those Harrier dashing options
especially if you do it early yeah
gangster got caught moving a bit there
but wasn't he puts it no calories that
works out for him
mid after the roll oh big time hit
counter hit this is gonna put him no
just a combo is correct but there it is
that extra hit and gotta be careful
[Applause]
gone two rounds to one versus Olson
yo gang is gone right now though what a
run ah not over here you're low
nothing yeah he's not reacting to
Harriet look at his caught the traffic
to prepare the side step my head up
barrier break for the balcony even in
the combo oh no also with rage here can
he make it crazy come back
gang gets done
you're putting me to sleep
oh my goodness what a crazy scramble at
the end there but Genghis died in those
scramble situations has it making the
right decisions and that's what matters
this year is a first to two situation
gang is not just needs one more game to
move in the top three also's in trouble
will he stick with the Bob here Steve it
looks like he's at the state select
seems like he's going to commit I talked
about the fact that I feel like Kazumi
definitely does a great job here right
does a great job here her down 4-1 as
well we're not seeing the switch it
doesn't look like but Osan definitely
has characters with tools that can kind
of counter this movement that Harry was
saying some of the options that we see
Katarina go for but jungle outposts to a
breakable balcony a breakable wall this
is good for Katarina but also Bob can
get a lot of damage in these situations
I think if your gang is not you like the
stage pick yeah
the breakable balcony another wall on
top of that on top of that he actually
has been getting old signed by finishing
strings we saw the early walls play at
the finish on the down four one two I
like the way he's playing right now I
think also just didn't expect him to
finish that string there right so he's
being tested anyways they're testing
each other in that first game but let's
see what happens here game number two
Genghis Dawn in the lead versus allsad
round one
fight
boom
nice option there to challenge that that
great grounded hit damage from Katarina
look at this sidewalk in the back that
back two string big damage hail Suite
first time we've seen that Behind the
Walls play re-wall is flat big damage
not dead welcome to Bob
yo wave away will give you one to grow
on after the round
oh
good break
nice string wow what a side step on the
left
usually that doesn't hit a pause at a
crowds he put in that stage just barely
flipped up and almost not taking control
here on this stage man that back to
string is doing work
look at the sidewalk again the awesome
question there back to the wall we go
tons of damage hella damage look at the
light and Ulta running away quick with
this one yo game two looking all also on
right now
nice area transition going for the low
really starting to tap the digital
angles
oh I said the digital winches
digital ankles the perfect
the laugh and I'll give you one to grow
on too Genghis God bringing the crowd
back to life here
goes for the 1-1 string I can hear
I can hear the crowd I can hear Mandalay
Bay get counter hit balcony Break battle
you know it that's one falcon
and then you take this wall oh very big
damage huge damage don't step
all right
oh whoa be careful oh stop trying to
close out the game and tied up here
oh that could have been big hop kid gets
stuck better
rage mode gang is done yo hit him with
the elbow drop I want to see it it looks
cool why don't you tell him that theme
not gonna happen old man gets the loss
on the big risky low there and now we
are tied up one game each
my man Bob just jumps back up to the top
of the station
one's on game of peace this is a best of
three scenario so somebody after this
match will be going home
yeah those lows are risky against Bob he
does have a fast launch of from
Crouching so got to be careful here
Jackie Chan back with the coaching here
Genghis Don
tournament life on the line for both
players here
who's gonna move into the top three one
game wolf decided we're going to the
Arena Stage this is the stage gang is
done and pick time and time again and
Steven time who's moving on we're about
to find out right now yo crowd you still
like Genghis Don to take it make some
noise out there last game potential to
make it to this losers to that Roar
here we go
now the arena in the arena hey round one
all right here we go
drop it on him yeah I love that option
not everybody has like instant answers
to get great damage in that situation so
Catalina really excels there lots of big
damage hitting lows
yeah they're both kind of bad matches
for each other in that way
back to YouTube huh
big damage right there one throw get off
going to the mid after the roll
big low out of the area wow goes for the
mid this time old sign at the ready
going for the duck doesn't duck that one
though life works very close here great
vote for all son Kingston has one chance
here look inside what not enough
got him anyways
gang is done oh man what's up he took
the jacket off the sticks he's like I'll
let you steer let's go I don't even care
of you you want to see it I don't care
if you want to see it shout outs to my
boy you want to see it
oh nice nothing big but the punish is
there
High getting his loving region a little
bit that time also check out the wall
after this carry there it is Big damage
that is huge damage way too correct for
Bulls on here power course belly's good
50 50. to close it out and there we go
Olson ties it up one round the piece wow
once again smaller conversion but still
very good damage for Bob
punish that
Parker's very good but don't say
chipping away chipping away with the
Jabs the Jabs keep our race is good for
the Hopkins gang is done wow you aren't
leaving me the blue stuff let me see
here it is oh look at this hella damn it
he punished him though that's risky
against Bobby's got some good Jam rage
and it's set point for all songs Genghis
died on his last leg right now y'all
nice Punisher wait a minute this could
be the start
this could be the start it's close it's
close
oh doesn't have rages yet though oh we
gotta find what is
it's not enough rainbow for rules on
gotta watching punish
[Applause]
oh
also takes it with the last
the last rage horse using the armor
speed and weight is gonna give all song
to set yo crowd do me a favor do me a
favor you're living in the USA Make some
noise
[Music]
first time at evil first time for the
first time and get the top it's foreign
don't write stories about you oh my
goodness what a crazy set there but also
gonna be the one moving on in this
bracket and once again this is exactly
what I was talking about a lot of people
see Osan in these situations they're
like what is he going to do his clutch
factor is so good the way he solidifies
his gameplay and there's the pop-off
oh my gosh the clutch rage right there
right like waiting for his hair
transitions obviously he had the side
steps very early in this act and at that
time he was like wait a second I have
rage right now if you do that hairy
transition that jumping low I'm ready
I'm gonna hit this button it's gonna
cast through with the armor boom damage
I honestly look I love seeing those
reactions because we saw how Genghis Don
was really taking advantage of the
Harrier transition she's like look
Harrier mid Harry alone he was really
going to work a lot and it was working
and then you start to see it add up
crouching Jabs sometimes just backing up
like you know what I'm not going to even
engage I'm gonna go for these with
punishes so you started to see the
launchers a little more from Olson and
that's what got the launchers coming
from genghisdon more consolidation he's
like you know what I'm not going to give
you anything old son clutches it out
once again one of the best to do it man
he's so good yeah this was such a fun
set here but Osan with us Bob the whole
way through what a surprise it's been to
see this but Genghis Daniel would turn
things around in this game Olson
answered back tied it up one apiece and
this one we had this title situation
this was the thing that kind of kills
him right he gets a little risky here
just a little bit it's all you needed I
don't think so I tried to go for that
Harrier transition he's been using it
every game they played so far and what a
call out yeah did healthy see that he
survived with there does actually damage
scaling to happen if you absorb damage
from a rage yard so if there was no rage
right then it hit it would have actually
killed no that's actually true that's
definitely true but now you see the
losers final is solidified Al versus
Osan Japan versus Korea and the Grand
Final player one of them is arsenaline
Ash and we're gonna find out who the
other one is after this next set that
this is absolutely wild here man
absolutely wild this loses final here Al
versus Olson Japan versus Korea you know
they were kind of Young Guns in the
scene right I mean still the young guy
in the scene essentially but you're
right over there trying to get this bad
boy thanks bro you got the arms they
won't let it get past all right too big
man too much work now it feels you know
yeah I know bro
but these two guys Japan and Korea you
know the heaviest Hitters from each
region essentially at this point you
know the youngest the Young Gun Heavy
Hitters essentially should be a very fun
match of kurimitsu from Al most likely
I'm guessing here and Osan of course
probably the Bob you know I mean just
you know a little side table to this
another like storied rivalry is Japan
Korea when it comes to Texas it always
has been you know and to say that we
have like the next generation of Tekken
players Osan a young player okay out of
a young player who's been doing this for
quite some time going up against each
other to claim victory as an EVO
Champion get the potentiality to face
Arsenal and Ash and it's about to go
down right now Al versus Osan somebody's
going to Grand finals
here we go
scissors
oh God oh God
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no they can't be Mutombo
paper piece Rock still on the tape right
here shut up
tail of the tapes right here Japan
versus South Korea first appearance 2014
is how long I'm in hours and coming to
these evils first appearance 2018 for
Olson and still look at the total
appearances compared 2014 for hours the
first appearance 10 showing up to the
top six tops for evil yeah I think
that's just the evil
excuse me but 10 appearance totally evil
it's still crazy it's pretty wild there
now I think it was back to Tech tag two
days yes he's been around for quite a
while just in second seven days he's a
much younger uh player of course so
we'll see how this goes and that's what
they're playing for that news designed
for the Evo trophy who's walking in for
the championship today and this wants to
be so good too because these guys have a
lot of history history between each
other Korea and Japan have a lot of Team
exhibitions that happen so these guys
have seen each other plenty of time
throughout the years as we get here into
our losers final this is going to be
intense guys losers finals this is best
of five first to three and I'm gonna ask
you I know we don't got any skin in the
game anymore but these games are still
about to be electric so I ask you
Mandalay Bay if you would like Osa to
take it make some noise
and if you guys would like to take it
from Japan give it up for Al
e okay okay they like they like the
growing temperament of Olson he's
looking real good
all right these guys getting set up here
I'm interested to see what character
we're gonna get from Olson Mike the Bob
might be the pick we've talked about how
it's going with it the entire time here
in this top six so I'd be interested I'd
be confused if you change now
yeah and it's wild I mean I mean the
coolest thing to me about this matchup
too of course this is in the top three
right now but we go back right the first
Evo Tekken 7 tournament out in that
grand finals got second place they're
now back in the top three point
protecting the last one and is it gonna
be the Fang wave from ulzan he looks
like he's locked in he's picking the
outfit yeah sir quick work
22. this is 2022 since 2022 we've been
here
and I would love to know what you guys
think give us your predictions twitch.tv
slash evil if you think you know you're
right I would love to see you proven
wrong here talk to us and you know of
course also in this loser back and
because he lost to arson ashes could he
mention earlier with his Bob now we get
longer sets for the rest of tournament
first to three best of five the whole
way through here for each of these sets
now maybe the Fang's a possibility to
come in the mix
I like that though you got to save your
cards for Less right you got to wait for
the last time to pull your biggest card
the biggest gun in the case and now Fang
versus Cooney mitsu multiple floors here
can be broken scream at it ah
man you guys are ready that was sick
this is gonna be an interesting choice
here I'm not really sure what he feels
is different because the fan can do
differently than Bob but think you know
it's seen as a very strong character
right now in the game as is
yo look at my hands
watch the birdie
this is my man Obama would say go watch
the birdie
said that to get in there runs into some
Jabs yeah these are very cold heavy
characters that 10-3 punching both of
them is gonna be three hits and a lot of
damage
ah
yeah full cross low right full cross low
gets four four two follow but you can
Dash it and put them in a blender
essentially just using a big Tech great
mid that down four one from Coney mitsu
try to go for the back turn mid option
oh my God
ah floor break too look at that damage
dude oh yeah we're going downstairs one
level at a time
okay
we're going down another one
give them the tour show them every floor
of the house
ah great low
slash kick to keep the pressure tracking
right yo back one talk to the hand yo
the back one
yeah oh wait a minute double raise down
by three
I'll run away early here
said Dash
trying to get away from that wall all
time being pretty aggressive right now
great duck we've seen him do that versus
arson Ash even with the different
characters he's trained on the matchup
so you see the duck yeah you can see not
much damage after ducking right but at
least you stopped the offense you get
what you get
again right nice and simple option puts
it right back to the neutral you see
Al's like you know what okay I see that
you're doing that now I'm gonna switch
up my pressure start to delay the
strings but it's getting closer to the
wall oh
boy oh
ah ah big damage on the wall get off of
me lady
oh oh they're like wow
yeah I'm back three here we go back turn
low speed and we're alive almost not
surviving
hello stuff
still got the hands under the cover
Steve
[Music]
I like these mids being used right here
that back one in that first round or
that second round excuse me really says
a lot about what fan can do to kind of
stop that pressure try to go for the
back turn mix nice size step left this
time did commit to the follow-up could
have launched
kills two no counter
they'll switch for that standing two two
and no throw break from now with the one
was doing oh
100 down to an inside final round game
one my man's beating up the door he's
trying to make a pizza bro
all right down back three
really starting to take the lead with
this pressure you talked about how Paul
camping this character is no punish it
all
[Applause]
the back one once again
Al made a huge error there had the block
but didn't get the launch punished that
was brutal
once again we talked about what being on
that stage means man you got to be sharp
the entire time and that doesn't always
work out the way you want it to
you and also
I told you that guy's clutch bro Al
dropped it all sounds like oh thanks
yeah I'll doubt it out
he had run away from him both these
players of course are gonna be capable
of hanging with Arsen Ash you saw close
the first set with Osan arson was
earlier so whoever wins here it's not
gonna be an easy walk through the park
for arson either
go at your service
scream at it
oh man
God counter hit on top of that
great damage
ah oh my God the damage
back it up talk to the hands
big track and move right there we've
seen that be successful in those first
games excuse me that first game jab out
gets the float I'm pretty sure that was
on this side step yeah exactly he was
trying to sidewalk up against the 1-1
block including mitsu that's the
direction you want to move
okay while standing four yeah small
input error there in that thing man
small errors here are hugely costly
oh wow
and just raw call out right there from
out seems to have some people want old
sign is trying to get accomplished here
for sure
oh they dancing
down for one counter hit this time
around perfect range for that back one
he wants you to over it spin and
speaking of overextending ow just raw
call out on the dashboard from all time
to drop the combo yeah I don't know what
these while standing threes are from out
but he seems to do a very quickly
there's a full cross low and now the
dash of mid no dash of longest time down
back three finds his hit
but lay on the string possibly thinking
about the potential oh wow that was a
good option but an even better option is
doing the string to catch the recovery
on the way back in yeah the Doppler one
two spring starts a good option
regardless right but at that situation
perfect
one thing too
bad news right now
for old side of this game
yeah that's not something you see very
often in neutral but now ready for it
oh patience patience patience another
one
oh I don't think so out of the way Osan
you genius
Soto
guess the one three
I like that whole time going a little
more to the low side step right
back to the lows once again
goes for that back turn mid optional
sign at the rate where what a whip
Punisher back one oh combo nice launcher
uh bullcrap sweep here Dash up mix up
goes to practice low again not enough
50 to tie it up
the delay right there after the back
turn just to see how Olson was gonna
react and then hits the button I like
that you gotta stagger it just a little
bit yeah we talk about the Cooney
right owls versus arson style I
was much more ready to take those risks
that full cross low sweep if block is a
full launch combo punish right so it's a
little risky to go for and Arthur he
does go for it if he needs it at the end
of rounds I mean so we can come back Etc
yeah but I was willing to throw it out
at any time so you can really have to be
guessing against him I mean you've seen
how Al like uses down four too he's like
yo you're gonna try to dash in he'll
clip you on the tail end just to try to
teach you right but Olson's now getting
aware of that start using the back Tempo
started going for more of the lows to
try to like call it out after the whiff
but still not easy to do and I see he's
playing at that range to get like the
back one the back fours and it's been
pretty successful so far and it's one a
piece here but he's sticking with Fang
Wade right so this could have been his
opportunity to switch characters and
bring the bomb back but this time he's
like no we're gonna bang another round
yo Mandalay Bay scream at it job
[Applause]
okay
oh counter hit takes the pressure get
believe in a nice side step left already
out getting a lot more active on the
offense
on point though
you know those old sign is really
getting comfortable hit buttons up close
goes for the Okie pack turn low up 4-2
to answer back
a challenge there for now with a while
standing four and he gets the first
round here in game three
loses finals guys remember this is best
of five first to three set two of these
counter it wall carry here
uh-huh
how to modify the combo so not optimal
damage but still decent still a lot of
damage oh you ain't Ducks right there he
saw it coming nice punish you were
talking about exactly it's risky right
and look at the life he's gonna lose you
from this early in the round and the
position and looking really good too the
down back three catches the back cash
back one on the counter hit big damage
on the side here for Olson running three
away from the wall working their way
away
wow counter hit on the low pickup to get
the wall tries to get the show to follow
up just a little too late there yeah
very dangerous to have your back face in
that wall exactly so you can see the
sides face out throw breaks good oh
without a Great Divide the rage drive it
did not enough damage oh my gosh
wow
round Ford coming and now has the lead
back oh thought with that range that
almost pulled up didn't convert well
enough off the sidewalk that big launch
caught get duck and dig launched on the
wall big damage on the wall likely
looking good for Al yeah that was again
another huge risk from Albert he works
out and also's way behind now
positioning though if you can get along
for the wall easily this round oh my God
and Al is up two games to one now
you think he switches Steve you think
he's fixed bank man 20 22. I don't know
where we going we're switching something
might be the stage might be the
character let's find out who knows
it's character select Steve who's it
gonna be though is it Fang is it Bob or
is it Kazumi
is pretty easy she has her own running
attacks as well running one running two
down four one I feel like really does a
lot here back four another two to
control the man go ahead the entire
tournament though yes usan has not used
Kazumi but this is the character he's
best known for leading up to this so now
the Kazumi comes out with his one game
away from elimination wow
all right here we go
yo Mandalay Bay you guys are ridiculous
Make some noise for yourselves thank you
guys so much
[Applause]
here we go potential final game of the
loses final Al needs one more to get to
Grandpa's get his run back with Arsen
but the Kazumi coming out from Olson and
you know both of them want to run back
oh both of them do no they want the run
back
yeah Arthur sent both of these guys down
here and look at this that jab of
Kazumi's is actually really good at that
too down 4-1 that's exactly what I was
talking about the Statue kick she has
the tools to control the neutral
we got both things
yeah yeah I'll force him to play some
neutral now don't go anywhere back to
him you stay in place
teleport I don't think so I'll just
block that both crowds green so we'll
take those risks to Corral honey could
have been more oh spins the blue stuff
oh the low
oh my God and that was one bad punch
from Olson that cost him that round
all in all was controlling it very well
but the minute Al got started it was
trouble nice we're all Rising 2-1 on the
punish and even better punish than he
had from with these other characters and
once again committing to the stream gets
the big launcher going to the wall
damn oh my goodness down back three he's
always in trouble we're doing it again I
don't think so but should have launched
sidestep punch string and trouble and
the delayed while standing four at the
end and just like that it is set point
for Al
so
needs this match he needs every the next
three rounds beautiful 4-3 with Punisher
from Kazumi
a tiger
beautiful use of the homie attack that
has stopped first step with it down for
two for now he's making a comeback after
comeback every round right now at the
tail end of the range here goes for the
Okie with the set Dash 2-2 looking for
the side step while standing for the
answer
two rounds to one now on the board damn
the Pokemon
I dropped those Tigers sometimes man he
dropped it down to that number still
running two running two yeah he's
starting to remember you know it's like
the warm-up period right those first two
rounds he didn't have all the moves yet
Danny 3-2 with ozone is one of his
greatest ones because we haven't seen it
the Wild Thing Before the whip punto
from Aldo okay no walls to go through
this time big damage steal all sign in
trouble big block you gotta launch it
for those who gets the downward one two
punish
I like how you approach that a tiger
approaches you you stay on the ground
up and down back threes all signs taking
his time different tally at this time
knows that while standing four it's so
scary though I could do a full costume
at any time
we've seen those High crashes oh my
goodness daddy three again and we're
going to final round still said Point
morale
foreign
[Applause]
all stopped in trouble right now not
tapped in the raid still that's still
unlucky oh my God this is the punish oh
my God can you find something though our
solid even doesn't duck that could have
been lost double down though not gonna
kill 50 50 for the win he finishes the
string
Al is going to move on two grand finals
eliminating Olson what a battle you can
see it right there 31 Olson out of the
tournament guys can you please do me a
favor Make some noise for old son
from Korea third place here at Evo 2023
Olson eliminated by Owl
man and that situation at the end there
right you see the full cross low the
fall up on the ground and then he runs
it for 50 50. usually just to downward
one of the low kick but this time I'll
hit both buttons right down for one two
it's a two-hit string there and in the
middle of that usan try to force it
raise drive out just to at least gain
some pressure and push him away but Al's
in there he's like no no you're gonna
guess right now yeah those advancing
strings really did help him out right
there and very close to try to call out
that rage drop so close right because
she does the point the tiger comes out
and I love the challenge of being like
you know what 2-2 you might try to do
this we've talked about first coonies
they do like to just bust out and use
that rage drive at a moment's notice
right so if you want to take some
pressure back which is what osai was
trying to do he used his early nice call
out right there by Al and that's how you
get the victory it's pretty wild though
right like you can tell that his heart
is with Kazumi because at that point of
the tournament he hadn't used her at all
we saw the ball throughout the
titleistics brings out the finger sticks
two games with the Fang and then when
it's on it's all down in one game he's
like Bob no no we're going with we're
going
mama and you can see she wasn't really
fully warmed up right he needed two
games at least so that's what happened
sometimes with players switch characters
in the middle of a set yeah and then on
top of it just you know how the stage
worked out right this stage goes from
you know having walls to none at all
right so the game got a little bit
slower and look at how Olson was really
just trying to force his way to get in
he's like yo I'm trying something now
but Al's defense didn't crack and what a
challenge right there for the rage drop
and here is the bracket for you guys
once again we saw this goal down right
here also lost to Arsen Ash arson goes
up to fight Al who pushes him down to
losing sides arson is awaiting and Grand
finals and then we saw genghisdom make
an amazing run up until Osan Osan taking
out Anakin and then takes out genghisdom
to one Al versus Olson goes 3-1 in favor
of Al he goes back to this winner side
to take on arson Ash in your Tekken
Seven Grand finals exactly this of
course will be a run back from the
winners final where arson took it three
to one
it's gonna be an uphill about rally so
you would think at this point I mean
look I can tell you right now we talked
about how you want the run back how does
it feel to be like you know what I could
have won that set I want the run back in
the same tournament that says a lot but
once again how many people have actually
beated arsene Ash in a tournament like
it's not many it's a very small list of
players and Al's done it at least once
this year just a few months ago right
and when you look back that first set of
winners final there's that one mistake
he made end of the round and final round
of the first game we didn't duck died
and got hit by it and caused an entire
game lost momentum things could be
different if that doesn't happen again
your nerves are very very serious things
when it comes to high level competition
I talk about the Tekken 7 ceiling always
going up no matter what the year it's
always the players but I hate to do it
to you again but we're gonna take
another break before we get to this
Grand finals and Crown a champion for
Tekken seven here at Evo 2023 don't go
anywhere
[Music]
all right
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
foreign
[Music]
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
oh welcome back everyone Tekken Seven
Grand finals of Evo 2023 incoming it's
gonna be Pakistan versus Japan this is
about to be a good one Al wanting the
run back and Arsenal and Ash sitting
there with the potential to cash out and
get his fourth Evo title what a way to
close out Tekken seven I can tell you
that right now especially considering
arson Ash is one of the people and
Pakistan in general is what changed
Tekken seven in the last like five six
years bro it's been all Pakistan look
man I don't want to say it but it looks
like this is arson's tournament to lose
right I mean he's in the Winner's side
of the bracket he's already beat now
three to one in the winners final just
earlier today he looks so sharp doing it
they ran the mirror match the cootie
Mitzi versus kudi mitsu earlier now we
get this run back here in the grand
finals though what characters are we
gonna see I expect to see the mirror
match again you think the mirror match
for sure when Al beat him in the past
the TWC finals it was not the mirror
match it was the Cooney Mitchell versus
arson zafina now now that Arthur's
rocking the cootie mixer against them
he's winning so why would you not run
the mirror match again and you've also
seen how Al is really trained up on the
matchup right ducking under the two two
strings going forward he's like yo I'm
not gonna let you keep that pressure I'm
gonna stop you from doing that the
interruptions are real when it comes to
offense versus Cooney mitsu overall and
he knows how to fight this we've seen
other characters we've seen the chanels
pick them up we've seen Al pick up this
character and do amazing things and I
feel like now we really getting to see
it come like full circle we got three
different great players that play
kunimitsu and arson is the one who's
excelling the most exactly he has a very
safe play style with this character
right he utilizes the post like 2-2 down
forward one two and one one very well
yeah you know use it down back threes to
close out the rounds and the full crowds
mix he rarely used it but he used it
when he needs to and he lands because of
that right on the other side you've got
ow but it's a much riskier play style
but it also makes it work for himself
because he keeps his opponents on their
toes yeah I really do like the way that
owl plays this super aggressive like
Pokey what are you gonna do style and I
feel like it puts even the best player
on tilted times once he starts going
it's really hard to get him to stop
let's not forget Evo 2015 Tekken 7 Al in
the grand finals second place back to
the Grand finals here for potentially
the last year of Tekken seven could
potentially walk out of second place
again but you know he doesn't want that
second not again after the last time
right he wants to close out with that
first and it's going to be difficult but
it's doable and this was such a clutch
rage already had Soul clutch and even
more so it was a great adaptation right
we saw the Harrier stances come out and
do so much work help gank is done get
that point on the board and waiting on
that cashing that last chip to be like
you know what gank is done you're out of
here we move on to Al versus Olson
pulling out the Kazumi at the tail end
after switching to the bank finally it
did not work out but this is the style
of how he gets the Poke he gets you in
these comfortable situations you want to
dash back into a rage drop 2-2 to catch
you exactly he saw that now there's a
lot that replay back actually that down
forward one he went with the end of the
Poke right that's kind of a mix-up but
there's also a delay you can have on it
for the second hit so he acted delayed
it to make Wilson think there was a gap
before he threw out the rage Drive
second it came out interrupting that's
where he got the victory there so close
enough to make it happen too that was
really good I love the adjustments made
right there and it definitely adds to
the victory especially if it's going to
cash your ticket to grand finals Al
that's the one to do it he's back in his
Grand finals going up against Arsenal
and Ash who is here for the fourth time
across Evo and now we're gonna look at
the tale of the tape oh yeah the first
appearance was 2019. four pakistans
arson Ash 2014 for out yeah but arson's
first appearance is what he won the
tournament as well he showed up and won
the entire tournament right six total
appearances across all the evos he's won
three of them which is ridiculous right
including evil Japan and the evil
vacancies are obviously best results Evo
2019 first with EVO Japan and Vegas man
I would love to know the Evo stats about
who's done that at all who equals won
four evos at all and who's gonna win
this trophy is what we're about to find
out after this next set man that bad boy
is shining you're gonna have to clean
that you're gonna have to hit some
Windex on that boy keep it shiny oh man
but here we go ladies and gentlemen hey
you guys out there still Mandalay Bay
Make some noise it's time for the grand
finals of Tekken seven potentially for
the last time potentially for the last
time I'm glad you said that so
potentially for the last time for Tekken
seven yo Mandalay Bay I got a question
will we get a four-time Evo Champion
here with arsenaline Ash if you believe
that make some noise
or if you're on this side that wants to
see a new Evo Champion for the first
time in Texas it makes some noise for ow
all right yeah
get ready for the next battle
loading in right now game number one of
the grand finals Arsenal National on the
winter side he's been running back to
mirror match Cooney mitsu versus Cooney
mitsu and we get an infinite State the
coolest infinite stage ever infinite
Azure number one
yo Evo this is Grand finals protected
seven Make some noise out there for me
one time
you guys are wonderful wonderful
fight game on this time the swap colors
Al's got the purple
oh what is kunai with kunai
counter hit on the get up kick
you need to see that the standard two
and look at the range game being played
right now and that's the screen that
killed him at the end of the first game
right Arkansas putting that reminder
there remember how you lost
I'm gonna do it again and you still
don't know how to put it right
and you were talking about how I always
like to call out some of these attackers
the Hopkins the wildstanding threes he's
still doing that in this matchup versus
but it's not working and the thing is
Alice playstyle you know it's very
defensively sound against Cleveland but
it's working but arson is just so hard
to put away man he's unclose out of
police yeah no it's really one of those
things ain't no punish right there
oh and look at this arson working his
way back in has the likely now with 10
seconds oh eight seconds oh real close
right here
[Music]
and we've been saying that pretty
frequently right oh yeah
doesn't care what color out he's wearing
he's doing the same thing right
oh that looked like a setup definitely
toe kick was a good option there from
how to stop the setup though
is so far back in time just waiting for
the opportunity to whip punish out I
just get that offense started 2-2 set
two on top of it and look at the range
he's playing he's like look I know
exactly what you want to do counter hit
pick up combo conversion for house
because
this is so scary man Half-Life bar gets
raising the problems
goes underneath
hard duck board and Austin waited before
the down back that was so good
dude
crowd you better do it
Never Gonna Get It Again Never Gonna Get
It Again infinite is your three bring it
back I'm calling it I'm gonna sign a
petition bro
set two set two watch
that's a chance we're out here you gotta
take advantage of a little options arson
gives you back there from the combo here
I know what this ends up still I got a
combo wow oh no she's small dude yeah
double raise again
oh my gosh I feel like I need to see
that what the hell out no no I'll
activate it first arson activated second
oh my goodness oh dude
what a crazy ending three rounds great
for Arsenal Nash in game one
what's the game plan waiting on the
character select screen
goes to the house Vermillion Gates the
mirror match continues
it looks like Al's gonna stick it out
couldn't admit to the whole way here
okay he's very confident picking the
character again and switching to the
stage I like the commitment I love the
commitment actually you know I mean like
most of the time I'm like 99.9 of the
time on my one character guy so I like
that
all right let's see what happens here
game two of the grand finals
best of five first to three obviously
but if owls can get a set
we gotta do it again and I hope it
happens I hope it happens I'm completely
okay with that
but arson is seems like an Unstoppable
Force right now
time and time again really absolutely
was just about to say I was like bro
he's always an Unstoppable Force at this
point
you're very select real players can ice
my man Arsenal and Ash I can tell you
that right now
adding up again
the craziest thing is that it seems like
no matter how much Pokemons outputs out
how good is defense is to add up at the
end arthnash always finds a way to come
back
almost every time set two to get in
after the close distance nothing on the
whip down back three of his own and what
a call off of our slime yeah
the range was incorrect for that launch
there
the throw stuck down okay back
to straight for Arsen Al yo this guy
arson we said it man it ain't many it
ain't many that could say they get the
leg up on arson Ash and Al has
definitely defeated it before but
it's not looking so good right now
dude this is wild
it's like Mark was born for evil man I'm
Sam bro he's it's like he's tempered for
it
insulated to be able to deal with the
pressures of any evil
I'm gonna get it on the board
yo evil how are you doing out there
two nights nothing funny I gotta punch
for this one we're down four power Crush
get stuffed
barracunai unblock does teleport to
forward but she has to be close enough
with this that you can actually punish
the teleport forward
settings on the answer back you see him
trying to close that distance they both
are using it to access it in a little
closer after a rich drink potentially
it's about full two two string that time
for Mal so willing to take risks with
this character right back at you though
you know transition into the set goes
for the slide gets the hit and once
again Arts those are slowly defense
keeps them alive in the set and his
house cannot find the tool that opens up
arson and you know owie he tries he's
full crowd sweeps right it works with so
many players he gets so much mileage out
of it but it's not getting a mileage
against arson Arthur's making a big call
let's get in the blocks and getting the
launches against him yes absolutely
counting it right now going straight to
the wall Arsenal with a commanding lead
with a commanding lead
this is looking like beat down and I
can't now find a way back and I don't
think so arsenash up two to zero one
game away from winning yet another Evo
title in Tekken seven we talked about we
saw what happened at the Nations cup it
was a battle for what region is the
strongest in Tekken Pakistan won that
tournament
they beat out Japan they beat out Korea
and everybody else for that matter
they're the best the best of men Evo
Champs from the beginning man we've had
nobody we've had Saints jdcr
Nationals knee as well and now will we
have another Arsenal match Victor will
he be the only one to two-time in here
oh my God across the history of Tekken
7.
a nice little duck but nothing big just
a small punch punch oh punch right there
interrupt wait a minute set three hearts
lands back to the wall tough to throw
[Music]
oh man and Out playing a little bit more
confident but look at Arthur he always
finds his way back and switches position
here has the right direction so he could
use the rage drive for the wall too but
nice nice come out smaller running this
time doesn't go for the launch good call
and we've been seeing it kind of like
all day when people have not been
punishing at set three right right we
saw what happens if you get a little too
antsy about any of your spaces you still
can't do it so I like going for the
smaller punch right there
yo the movement right now wow what a
counter hit
oh my goodness and now now defense kind
of falling apart against that 2-2 screen
back who's gonna work for that power
Crush
kunai arthane two rounds away three and
already stopped the momentum of wow
maybe but man went for the big damage
and Al's in trouble right now
argue with the defense as well the
interrupts are good teleport now twice
in a row
he's keeping the break up but now
defense hold up and get top of the
downward one two uh those three one
round away for Arthur Nash one wow
and arson Ash will claim another a
fourth evil title four ticket seven
alone big counter hit oh he's looking to
do it Thief
ah hella damage that was way behind here
75 lead for Arsen literally is
tournament to lose at this point how
could he possibly lose he's had such
good comebacks and now out in big
trouble one good version both conversion
Arthur did these one hit one it'll do it
and arson
survive the raid five attempt 16
there it is
your Tekken 7 champion at evos 2023 yet
again four times counting four times two
in Japan the states baby two in Vegas
Four Evo titles hit him with the four
wow I don't think you've seen that one
here at Evo before
unbelievable absolutely unbelievable the
Pakistan flag out there showing a lot of
love they embrace your Seattle Sean
gracious competitor gracious competitor
right there Pakistan waving the flag
once again not only Nations couple of
evil as well of course wow
unbelievable
man what a top six here for Tekken seven
potentially the last one I gotta say it
once again yeah he saw what's being
brought to the world with these new
characters sickly stages returning
characters but when we talk about Tekken
seven of the most dominant players of
all time you have to talk about Arsenal
and Ash you have to you have to talk
about it and when it comes to evil and
tekker 7 he is the greatest of all time
without a doubt nobody has as many evil
titles as this man right here and he's
done it again the consistency is
ridiculous 1500 competitors line them up
time and time again Arsenal Nash comes
out on top and let's not forget last
year third place as well top threes on
top of things top threes always showing
out and like I said before when people
ask and say hey man what was the big
changing Factor here the appearance of
Arsen Ash yeah the acceptance and the
showing up to multiple tournaments of
Pakistan and everybody's seeing first
hand is not just one player but there's
only one player that's the champion of
evil a four-time champion of evil
representing Pakistan that is our slim
Ash man that race drive for rage drive
there was such a wild end of game one
and it seemed like Al never fully
recovered from it right and all the life
leads it out builds up didn't even
matter arson always able to make The
Comebacks happen anyway you know at the
end here this is the final situation out
desperate raise Drive attempt blocked
Arts like all right I see one hit here
what do we do we just get it blocked and
you just saw him reaching for it a lot
of reaching right he's like look I want
I need to get a hit right now and prep
his offense a little too much Arsenal
and Ash is already in the shield he was
already holding the down back he was
ready to block the entire time and
that's how you know he's ready tempered
for the competition of Evo 2023 and your
new champion
and you see your top six up there right
now yo thank you guys so much man as we
see Anakin getting his first medal at
Fifth Place Make some noise for Anakin
people representing the USA of course
and there we have Genghis Dawn Of course
getting fourth place makes the noise but
Genghis Dawn everybody
third place coming up
you can see it right here on your screen
Make Some Noise guys for ah excuse me
second place for out another second
place finish for how out here at
Evolution for Tekken seven
but of course that third place from
Korea give it up for all song
and finally
fifth Mayo ill showing up giving us
great games with that great smile make
some noise for Mayo ill
hahaha back to back fifth blade finishes
for him out here at Evo
man what a beautiful top six here we had
the USA representation a lot of
diversity cool characters on top of that
and great play Chris I love you handing
out these medals has been a tradition
for so long guys make some noise for
your evil 2023 tickets
[Applause]
look at that Beauty look at that beauty
of a trophy right there
another Evo in the books maybe the last
one for Tekken seven so manly babe
please for the last time make something
foreign
oh man what a tournament every match man
we got to see so many players come in
obviously everybody didn't get here like
they wanted to but the matches
throughout evil have been spectacular as
we continue to hand out these medals and
these prizes on the stage man what an
amazing tournament Evo 2023 one of the
most ambitious of the evos I would like
to say on top of that look at that Anna
look at that gold big tricks first place
stick you see right there those bad boys
don't come cheap they definitely don't
come easy I can tell you that I mean he
earned that one man no high card for him
Arsenal Nash winning his way through the
tournament to get that you see out there
with the silver one old song with the
third place bronze wood as well yo shots
of dicks providing these awesome sticks
the competitors and shout outs to ATT
for giving out some lucky participants
in the crowd their very own Evo brand
winning sticks but with that being said
guys it is going to do it for Tekken
seven you know we got games left but I
just want to take the time to say thank
you guys so much and thank rip for being
on the comms with me bro talking about
this Tekken always showing love shout
outs to Evo shout outs to everybody that
came and thank you guys for allowing me
to my voice what's left of it anyway
because he's not talking about Tekken
seven because I love this game I love
fighting games and I love you guys out
there for supporting what we love
exactly the beautiful thing we've got to
be here for the whole way through Tekken
seven man yo every single yeah
hold it down every year anyway but man
it has been a good one guys let's throw
it on down to Li Joe to wrap things up
[Music]
guys please please this entire crowd Evo
2023 Mandalay Bay Mike my man Stephen
would say Make some noise for the Tekken
7 top six this may be the last time we
see Tekken 7 at Eva who knows taking
AIDS next year so make it loud one more
[Applause]
all right thank you everyone very much
okay so we are gonna cut to a break but
we are potentially going to have two
back-to-back announcements when we
return I'm not going to get anything
else away
but I would hang out right here we'll
see you back in a couple minutes
[Applause]
fresh is what you stand for exactly
[Music]
foreign
Pro Tour is now open over 2 million
dollars is on the line for the season
with the first place prize of one
million dollars to the Capcom cup 10
champion
winners of the online and offline
Premiere events will also Auto qualify
for a spot at Capcom cup 10. open to all
players in good standing so check out
capcomprotour.com for scheduling and to
find a qualifying tournament in your
area
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Hello everybody welcome back to
Evolution
2023. can I say first of all
wow there's a lot of people in it uh
it is so nice
to see everybody's lovely faces filled
since Marvel I woke up this morning in
bed staring at my phone and I was like
how is the arena full there's so many
people there at 10 A.M so can you all
make some noise for yourself here this
Evo
and real quick since I see them coming
down can you make some noise for rip and
Steve over there for doing an awesome
job with Tekken seven
incredible uh keep an eye just in case
rip you know his poor arm gets jumped we
might have to pull Steve off of him but
I'm here for a very special segment they
asked me they said you know we got a
little thing
we want to play some clips and a combo
is gonna get hit
and you know somebody might be in Peril
do you know anything about this and I
said Evo I stole the idea from you I
would love to come do this on stage so
they asked me to do some Willow kill
here at Evo
I said it would be my genuine honor so
without further Ado I don't want to hold
up any of the announcements that are
happening later let's jump into Willow
kill can we get our very first clip of
the show
[Applause]
[Music]
all right what do we got
is it gonna kill oh no not Kom
at
all righty then Mandalay Bay
do I hear yes do I hear no
I see a lot of thumbs up
is Isla dead
level two
bam
and the OTG
yes yes yes I killed you can never
forget the OTG
that is how it goes oh we got another
clip
is it time our second clip
the rewind the rewind
uh oh Nago mirror
okay okay that was the last clip bite
whips in the corner
BRC oh based on the first is it a yes
let me hear some noise
is it a no let me hear some noise
[Applause]
ooh this one's pretty torn
wall Splat right into the Super
dance oh I I think he's alive my baby
[Applause]
how's everybody's score how you guys
doing so far if you're undefeated
one of ones two and two and O's oh and
two no Chipotle for you you gotta go at
least three to get some Chipotle okay
that's how it works here
okay I don't have any cards they didn't
even give me any Chipotle and I'm in the
ads all right
I don't have a burrito let's see our
third clip
in seven hey that's the champ tall order
here
can he win four evos
is it a yes is it a no I'm seeing a lot
of no's in the middle here who thinks
it's gonna kill
a lot of you seem unsure
let's see the clue
it's nice to see Akuma dying for once
[Applause]
it's not enough
you know the worst part is I'm sure Kuma
got up and killed you know he like he
woke up crouching medium kick down three
he was like it's time
how's everybody's record did you get
three yet
I see Chipotle Gamers nice job you got a
couple more Clips to get it done let's
see our fourth clip
throwback moment
oh the command ground man I'm seeing so
many yeses in the crowd
everybody believes this is Marissa
before Marissa okay this is Marissa
performers
let's see off the backboard double back
heavy buttons
Abby again
man this is a really violent game
that's a violent game yeah it's season
two Abigail is pretty wild that's four
clips
I got one more clip for you Gamers now
before we play it
I would like to ask an expert in the
field to join me on stage can Tyler
Lansdowne please come up to the stage
from netherrealm Studios
he's gonna play a little Willow kill you
know how it goes
he's a he's a count expert that's what's
going on here
hello Tyler how are you I'm doing very
very well thank you sajam how's your
willy kill record so far I am I think
opher
that means that's uh Spanish for
undefeated so he's doing great so far
yeah he's doing awesome so I would like
to play our next clip and I'll ask you
if it's gonna kill okay
oh overhead connecting
all right vanilla Marvel
a little low hit what do you think about
this is it a yes is it a no what does
the crowd think
that's a no he's on a no he says no
vanilla Marvel it's a no she holds as
yives calls her Jenny from the blog
oh
we'll have to see little run Ready or
Not
So get our own show
DHC Wolverine Wolverine against Spencer
oh
it's not enough
Tyler's a professional
speaking of professional
I noticed the next clip has a little
character up there you might be familiar
with
I know that one that's reptile as a
reptile yeah
100 kills oh he seems pretty confident
let's see
reptile gets a blocks the wake of attack
oh that's a juicy starter what do you
think Chad what do you think audience
out here
seeing a lot of yeses you seem to
believe
they said I believe in Tyler
believes in Tyler you think it's going
to kill 100 1 000 percent
all right let's see the clue
oh the time stopped the acid spit
into the ball down to combo after it's
uh
[Applause]
reptile wins so your record on stage is
undefeated not bad that guy right there
thank you so much
I love you too now Tyler
I I have a question maybe it's a little
greedy of me
but can I see some more reptile
yeah I think you could see some more
reptile
[Music]
[Applause]
Earth realmers aren't ready to see the
real me
so how does it work you just
shape-shifting anything you want I can
shift only between this and my natural
form
[Applause]
yeah Freak come on my people I was
terrorized run out
you misread my intentions princess
[Applause]
most evil from my soul with my sister
demons were furious at my change of
heart
laughs
Austra and sizeos come the monks must
prepare you for war
except chaos by choice
[Applause]
foreign
oh yeah
[Applause]
particular chaos elsewhere
well
that was incredible
I love how reptile looks by the way you
know I said reptile but I should have
said reptile and a little bit more
because we brought a lot to this one
yeah you definitely did did you guys all
enjoy the trailer
can you give a round of applause for
Tyler and NRS for showing us out
thanks to all of you for watching and
playing along with Willa kill we're
going to take a little bit of a break
and we're back with more evil action in
just a little bit
[Applause]
your Chipotle order just got extra with
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
who gives you wings
[Music]
thank you
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
[Music]
this is
[Applause]
that is
[Music]
[Applause]
do you know who you are when you think
your words
[Music]
welcome back to Evo presented by
Chipotle is everyone having a good time
[Applause]
[Music]
well the good times continue because we
have up next Guilty Gear Drive Time
[Applause]
we will be bringing out the top six to
the stage but actually before then I
actually would like to introduce
somebody to y'all
we got director Ken Mucci and producer
Akira katano who have a special
presentation for you all
thank you
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
spilled again
are you guys blazing
all right I'm kimioti I'm producer of
yotiger yeah
[Applause]
nice to meet you
okay
so we were able to see epic battles
throughout two days of Evo
sose
we are so sure that during this two uh
top six match we will be able to see
blood boiling heated battles I'm so sure
about it
[Applause]
addicted
let's come up see it's like
so this year we have welcome 25th
anniversary of Guilty Gear series and
also for guiltiger's tribe we have
achieved
2.5 million players
[Applause]
we have break serious record of total
participants for fighting Guilty Gear
okay
so we would like to thank every one of
you for supporting us to this day and as
a piece of appreciation
we have a trailer
let's roll it
[Applause]
[Music]
that is
[Applause]
[Music]
Justice
[Applause]
[Music]
No Limit
s
[Music]
[Applause]
okay seasons
so once you're looking at the screen
right now is the original illustration
drawn by Daisuke ishuatore himself to
celebrate the start of season three
[Applause]
um
[Music]
so with the release of season pass three
in 24th of August we will be starting
season three
seasons
foreign
so throughout season three we are
planning to release four new characters
two new stages and with it uh the usual
the season three additional character
color packs and also with it we are also
uh including uh character colors for
season three characters uh the colors
which were released in 25th anniversary
[Applause]
so from here on out we're about to see
the world's greatest guilt-to-gear
players
battled Head to Head from here on out
are you ready
let's rock
[Applause]
all right let's keep this hype train
going new characters new mechanic
updates and more super excited your top
six for Guilty Gear Shriver ready
so hit the stage so let's go
Mike is not on there you go it was
listen y'all are Jerry's so loud you
guys cut my mic off that's what happened
but listen all that hype is gonna
continue on because we are going to get
ready for our Guilty Gear strive top six
are y'all ready
all right let's
age
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm touching everybody
[Music]
feels
[Applause]
your everyday
[Music]
thank you
to meet our Guilty Gear strive top
six
first stop
weirdo
[Applause]
[Music]
up next it's new
[Applause]
you said right is that it
too long
give it up for two
[Applause]
and we have love
good
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally we have their
dance
[Applause]
let's hear it for your Guilty Gear
Strife top six yes
all right everyone let's throw it up to
giuna and Rich to take you through all
of the action
oh my goodness you never would have
thought Guilty Gear would take you this
far but here we are baby Sunday finals
in the building wrench do you know how
you do it fast now look I'm very very
excited I'm so hyped for the matchup
Johnny Johnny here out of nowhere ready
to turn you into a car I gotta forget
about that gotta figure out focus on
these matches right here okay like you
said though this is crazy no I've been
around for a while like back in the day
guilty here always side tournament
status you know leave our finals on
Friday they unplugged the power during
Grand finals now got no more baby yeah
definitely would you close we too close
we're too loud oh we're spread out sorry
sorry sorry uh you know the production's
telling us what to do but it's all good
first of all I want to hear
[Applause]
we have some in-house commentary
experience you know what I'm saying we
know how important it is for the crowd
to get involved and that's what these
players are going to be looking to
thrive on as well right we saw how it
affected the players in Tekken you know
we have two players uh in America but
there's a lot of leopard fans in the
crowd too they probably showed on
streams yeah guys around like this is a
big Community event so if your player is
up there makes a noise cheer for them
they want your support they can hear you
it's going to power them up it could
affect the tournament who knows
absolutely man you know I want to see a
look at this bracket when we get that
chance because we have six of the
heaviest hitters Guilty Gear has to
offer yeah
introduced on stage but let's take a
look at the matchups right thorough Eno
versus Newman Heimer 20 years experience
it's like right yeah the starter was
driving here he is right here bro he
started out as the online monster I
remember seeing him at can opener they
were like no boy let's see what he got
look at him now top six Evo 2023 then we
got chihuara and Lapin on the other side
of course left in with a top eight first
last year he's your favorite coming in I
I
that match yesterday unfortunately
couldn't see it on the big stage but
against peppery yeah I think something
was snapping left him right there the
gamer Gene just came out I started
taking over here we got to talk about
him too this is the first time out here
in America first time at Evo winners on
top six yeah amazing a macular player
for sure definitely you're going to be
causing a lot of problems against the
opponents and of course we've got yeah
Barracks waiting in the losers back in
the full ride
already it's ending a champion it's so
funny she did it last year with uh Happy
chaos yeah let me get another one this
time let's try a different Cactus we can
go with Seoul that's wow the inspiration
and I love the way she kind of is soaked
in yes processing and Computing quickly
right so to take a character like happy
chaos which you need on the execution
wise and take it to just dismantling
your opponent with a simple Basics the
soul I love seeing the translation we
can't hold on we got to talk about
Barracks too I had not heard about this
player until evil so it's his first time
in America first time at Evo from
Senegal yes built on the net play right
been grinding the net code first time in
a major tournament like this and doing
great all hell roll back yeah shout out
say jam of course but our first winter
semis match gonna be that daru Eno
versus Oni numenheimer that's what we
talked about right eight total
appearances here at Evil versus two from
newmanheimer yes last year was his first
ever Evo right and don't get it twisted
we talked about his online capabilities
but he went to CEO of Taco his first
ever offline tournament and took the
whole thing so this dude is a threat to
say the least I love I want to I mean
everybody feel guilty or fan you know
all about daru but we saw earlier 20
years of experience that's 20 years of
Vino play Eno's in his name right here
this is the representation of character
love it doesn't matter whether she's
strong I mean early on people said she
wasn't that good but he stuck with her
the whole time and now he is you
we were just talking when he was making
his way to the stage he got that that
jacket right yeah he came here for the
jacket
stage he was tweeting about that I want
that that jacket here but he was in uh
Tope last year he finished fifth on the
big stage I remember that yeah
incredibly strong player right he was
part of the gear project beforehand as
well handing them people losses left and
right and he's very confident in every
decision he makes right he likes to
gamble on defense he's not looking to
sit there and React to what you're doing
he thinks he already knows what you're
up yes but it looks like the butt check
we saw the fist bump we saw the punch
check so here it goes first match of top
six winner sidear you know versus
neubenheimer Make some noise in the
crowd let's go
I like it I like it we're gonna get a
banger to start you already know what it
is this game is explosive to say the
least and we got a good way to put it
yes
we're gonna exemplify that
characteristic let's let these intros
Rock here right build the energy
man it's like watching anime out here
for reals
he's so good let's just build it let it
build
[Music]
[Applause]
character
oh
no we dropped two from thought all right
the magic pixel how much magic you got
in this joint neubenheimer blood back
down to zero
yeah no mercy for dark next hit we'll do
it oh the faith in the Amari 2p right
there we'll wake up with it we don't
need an alarm all right gutsy play right
there too you know waking up with a
match against a character like not gonna
kill you in one hit absolutely that was
the life flashing for the odds season
second hit the lane from newmanheimer
throwing off Eno's Rhythm yeah there's
so many little mix-up situations
happening in here right he's gonna grab
gonna go for a close F right here let's
take him to the DP rip that's already
stuff that we already tied up in the
first game I mean that felt like a 10
second round I was probably less than
that honestly but you see that's why
dar's been running away trying to stay
away from that so explosive when he hits
you and right there the air box then put
her in additional blocks on the right
though try to press buttons but it
wasn't his turn he had to do the air
block try to struck under the far end
but it trades likely it again for new
pickup
[Applause]
oh yeah this covers the full screen you
know it's a great tool against uh you
know cover dash as well right covers the
ground and the sky absolutely takes up
that whole angle that she's looking to
approach for us
for a second
well I thought Marvel was over I don't
know what that was
all day every day you know might as well
be one of those type of characters
shouldn't be on deck as well don't try
to challenge me thanks to that positive
bonus from the wall break was able to
build the 50 and confirm for the super
there or for the finisher here
that's positive bonus he's in a great
position to tie up the set YRC does
connect with now Newman trying to catch
a flinching and at first though he's not
gonna be able to survive a hit so look
for a Goldberg so a defensive person who
starts blocking instead of back dash
right here is always very aware of that
Beyblade spacing doesn't want to get
clipped by it and any chip will do it so
Dar switching on playing a full screen
zoning game hey he's got almost full
blood right so he can't really risk
anything he just gets decimated in the
process well done
exactly she just has so many ways to get
those additional hits that she needs
right that's what makes her still so
strong let's go chop his first and all
but the Beyblade under the HCL
accidental and no burst this type of
confidence
and you don't want to do that especially
when you're gonna reach like this unless
it's being taught from nubenheimer
Stanky Leg coming out keeping his own
and he's got almost had two blood
he does a very delayed RC and catching
through pressing a button it's a very
Guilty Gear mind game especially kind of
killing the power of a new player you
know these new trains to thought these
new tricks yeah exactly like is that
something you used to see in the gas
leaks of the old games right he applies
that type of log into the RC on the far
s
bars
there we go yeah so even with the
Beyblade yeah
just stayed on smothered him didn't get
the chance to play we've seen a lot of
blood verses from rumenheimer early here
that's just the pressure that evil is
able to put on you right and like when
she plays at a distance she's very
effective as well so he's usually not
blitzing it in I would have got it
exactly yeah all three out of five for
this top eight here the empty low
immediately my man's gonna pick one oh
no
you almost had an incident on the stage
right there exactly that's why we're
showing the respective should be an easy
punish right there and it very much is
daru one game away from winners five
yeah so there are three beyblades in a
row right there just held down back he's
gonna let you pop go and I'm taking any
risks
very important right you got to watch
your opponent's gauge as well as your
own I respect that
a paramer just because
units or get across
the man Zara was being very disciplined
right now
oh okay
the wall with highly damn sure couldn't
get a full combo but still huge likely
right now exactly and a positive and 50
meters and Darwin barely having a new
burst back as well this is going to be a
good position
a bit far away can they get the ball up
right now and now he's checked with the
air-to-air at that point you know just
keep your ground no need to spend blood
to go in that's a great falling button
for nagori Yuki 100 has all the tools on
Deck with his character he knows how to
use every single option that's been in
so much work to the delay jump d ude you
know the way you block you know is not
on reaction you kind of guess what the
timing here and dower's throwing it off
24 karats but yeah as you mentioned
Goldberg's only minus 10 Darwin didn't
get a full punch out of here but he's
still cooking we got the corner now as
well I saw jump Beach
come out so this is good
Advantage failure for dark
the fukio forward right there take the
cash of the blood being drained from the
super the slow walk forward is so scary
like he could press close at any moment
he's easily the most intimidating
character when it comes to walking
no meter for the pickup last and there
it is again right the delay like air
splits here that was clean right yeah
like you mentioned that delayed overhead
that was definitely a timings where you
usually have to clock low grade switch
up from Darrow he's on set point
it's that point in a great spot too got
the corner right now but the 5K gonna
create some distance for neubenheimer
there close and we're going to the wall
caught up sling shot on that cool says
set up but now it's very much aware of
the pukio pressure doesn't want to get
command grab and let that blood drain
he's been doing that a lot right 6p
against the uh the long numbers here
from nagoruki exactly not trying to hit
him just trying to not let him put your
blocks done exactly the upper body
invoice blocks that leads to chip damage
it leads to a blood train as well so
it's a little thing from Darwin right
now anyone's game here both plays with
burst
very smart
oh no
oh no I'm doing like that doll room
taking advantage of Newman Heimer
holding down back as he lands command
throw to get into winners final acting
out and on the big stage still trying to
I gotta finish with my signature move
right it's like the dudes I gotta go for
demon no matter what so there we go so
already
daru last year like I said finishing at
fifth so now he's guaranteed himself
right at least top three yeah it was in
game one or two where you mentioned that
his command throw super with Eno is his
favorite thing right that's the Hallmark
and that was a great time to use the
right A lot of times it wasn't a true
punishment obviously he could have got
it yes but who is actually doing
something that takes them out of the sky
it's like talking about character love
too right he plays he likes his
character he loves Eno but he likes the
move he likes everything about her so
you know winning in your way is the way
to our plays and you know showed off I
mean that's like a real heartwarming
tale when it comes to fighting games
right as well so I mean the character's
good but he's rocked with that character
for that 20-year experience he's had
thick and thin right no matter what not
me man I got no character pick the top
tier is all I gotta say yeah go into the
good characters I feel that 100 man but
what a way to start this top six
right now you know a new behind that was
a great air-to-air from newmanheimer
again yeah prioritizing that far as
sequence as well to lower the blood a
little bit almost yeah overextending
himself right there had the advantage of
course but you know with the likely like
that Tara's going to have to spend the
Goldbergs and there it is closing with
the command grab super and look at him
acted out right here you think he
practiced this before he came here in
front of the mirror in front of the
mirror he's pulling that in the moment
baby he is a conduit for this evil
energy I feel it 100 there we go so now
look at the brackets is a Dar moving on
here in the winners finals and yes that
was the winner side so numenheimer of
course one of the Hometown Heroes is
still in the bracket gonna drop down
there and face Barracks there oh wow wow
oh only one can survive at least it's
not happening your grandpa so he's been
following along with EVO so far this
year just everything man mirror match
mirror match mirror match every game
except for kof and two out of the three
characters in K1 for the same as well
yes yes so the next match on the winner
side we are gonna have two dollar versus
oh yes indeed
great one jump Pan versus Sweden indeed
that's of course trades with a whole lot
of the n a competition right I I wanna I
wanna just say like I feel like just
going to smash him I feel like blephen's
got at least inexperienced terms I think
he's got the advantage I can see that
for sure I mean he's just got a constant
grinder right he's one of those where
you look up his stats for like how many
hours and games he's played and you're
like how is that even possible but Kai's
super common character right in in Japan
just Asian General happy gas is not
really representative yeah you have
polka who's like a 15 year old that's
like the training party you got out
there it's gonna be interesting to see
how Chihuahua is really prepared for
somebody like left and right and you
know left in was just at the super noon
house before he even warmed up with
everybody and Aaron the mack had been
playing a lot of Kai keys there we go
you know what I'm saying so I'm sure
leffen is a really sharpened in this
matchup right now but here you go tails
of the tape right there as I mentioned
this is Chino's first time in America
first time here at Evo so he's got no
results right now so uh did he got fifth
place at evil Japan yeah so that was
good but now he's in Vegas completely
different thing and left
himself as you can see first place and
Super Smash Brothers Melee in 2018 but
also a top eight appearance in guilty
gears 5 just last year just last year
and I think what was he third place
right yeah third place last year so he
wants to you know he wants to get even
further this time uh with happy chaos
you know the fan favorite they love
happy ass out here loading up the clips
letting the shots bring out major
looking all that we're definitely gonna
see what left and brings to the table
and he's really stuck with this
character right we've seen some people
sold their Wild Oats we'll get to Umi
showing a little bit right picking up
the soul but my man laughing believes in
the tried and true I feel like laughing
2 is a very methodical player it's a
very logical player but he's gonna get
chirada if you're not familiar with this
guy is there's no better way to put it
he's a nut he's a nut he bullied up in
himself he plays with his heart uh
watching his matches yesterday in the
pools I remember he was kind of
struggling actually I said oh maybe the
nerves are getting to him but mid set he
just kind of remembered he just relaxed
and we saw the chidada you know we know
and love and he took it all the way
that's something that's so interesting
to me about the big stage right is
because a lot of the time that anxiety
is all about the build up once you get
in the game it kind of melts away
because this is what you do this is what
you train
Ed all right so we're gonna get into
this match right now crowd I want to
hear y'all who likes you are
okay all right we got a little pop but I
mean we got we got big left on us who
wants big left to win Make Some Noise
right now
taking over the American crowd I love
that left gets the the CM Punk John Cena
reaction like half the stadium Boosie
cheers them hey as long as they're
making noise
you want to do it go for it but here we
go second match here of top six that's
exactly what I want to see here are we
getting into it baby who is going to be
daruino in winners final fantastic her
over and we already gotta win punish let
me get that first out yes I really want
to see kid on I really hope he can play
his usual game you know believe in the
DP believe in the shenanigans
well you see the curse actually and he's
got the fountain pass too it goes under
the sun Edge but the top does
immediately right and you talked about
it right he likes to play like a nut he
will definitely test your reactions test
your insecurities early that's kind of
weird I love saying this word but like
the mental stack right yeah the blue
gray art takes down the curse at the
stage stage route start that was
ridiculous he can play a very very
aggressive very very offensive style car
with a lot of different angles of
approach as well so you can't be
covering everything exactly left and
able to get the curse on early and this
is a much better start from around than
he had last time
first time how dare you try to make me
block right how dare you put me in Block
Stein I warned you about those dp's so
I'm talking about something another one
full charges
using the Slowdown from the RC the sneak
in the full charge we talk again trying
to get down to back down
like that maybe it's time to wake up
here
being unloaded right now and the reload
off the Xbox 360
[Music]
exactly right very very cold play style
right oh I like that very calculated he
knows what he's doing no emotions
here man
to get in
yeah
all the shots gonna be landed auto aim
all day every day and he conditioned him
to sit there and blobs so let's begin
the dad just throw ex machina let me
reload yeah make it slowly but surely
he's whining us without his life he's
got first but might not get a chance to
use it oh the wrist Breakers right there
shout out to IFC yipes I saw a left and
connect with that like 40 times
yesterday like if you block he's new
you're gonna get unblockable don't tell
me that's a mixer that's an unblocked
that is in a block well first game going
to left and after the strong start from
Chicago let me just turn it around
especially wrong like that right he
didn't even set it up with a frog string
or anything oh yeah
oh we're right back at you
he died he did run that DP went into the
roll right here he didn't have a shot
lined up you just hit it to escape the
corner yeah he's actually empty on the
bullets right now so he's just gonna go
with the Xbox why not let me just get a
full flip easy stuff especially because
it's got 50 attention he's got positive
bonus this is all big left one more
William in the building right there oh
that's the best right you blocked it
picks up you think you're nice no but
he's still going man my God you're
talking about the McDonald's
I'm just doing it on the stage now just
playing like I'm at home this is the the
type of play he breaks to the table that
was Dominic that fights here right there
can I try being slick with the FB drift
left and is ready I get it gotta answer
for everything right now 100 he is
looking unpaced he's looking completely
composed he's an EVO Champion that has
he on the close players caught up
lynching and this is the best
you won't forget Pam
with Justin pixel and again that first
gonna be a non-factor who left how come
on life before we finna pull that plug
real quick
[Music]
like that
he knows it's like you said he's
practicing before this he's got the high
experiences knowing the pressure resets
are coming
yeah yeah this is super sick he's really
caught onto the rhythm of Suarez offense
entirely oh okay
you tried you tried he got a lot of
meter
yeah chihuahuas really gotta lock it
down he's gotta make him earn the smash
that right now he's doing it for
free and it is paying off big time so do
you expect right you expect a cack like
happy chaos you know he's gonna Zone you
run away and then all defense is going
to hold down back he's like very very
scared but let him know
[Music]
[Applause]
none of that
right there but discipline
it's gonna be pretty good at not perfect
but the thing is a couple rounds now
he's died with his bursts you need to
spend it oh and he catches him with the
second hand the sun Dipper for damage
that's on the table there and the 2s is
such a pony huge drop yeah not just
damaging wall break lines up oh yeah
momentum it all turned around that's the
nerves of the big scene and look at this
flesh they're gonna take all that for
himself now the super confirmed the
stage Change Plus frames we're looking
good oh stops on his own piece that is a
first one lesson in winners finals that
was a dominating performance right there
it felt like kidada didn't really get a
chance
he never had a chance to play straight
up it really felt like the difference in
matchup experience as you mentioned like
left it just looks so comfortable
against the kai yeah obviously in
addition to airing the mag it's just a
popular character so he's got plenty of
experience against it but for chihuahua
on the other hand Japan lacking a little
bit of happy chaos and because of that
you see he just never felt comfortable
yeah he never felt humble he had a
couple chances too like we saw that big
drop at the end yeah right we had a
couple couple slips up but as we
mentioned for like Evo Japan is big but
it's not as big as Vegas right yeah the
crowd with the noise and everything the
ad goes everything so maybe the nerves
did get there but he's still in it he's
still in it dropping down on the loser's
side and you might jump so I think it
might be we'll check the bracket in the
mega but yeah obviously left and he's so
used to this stage right Evo Champion
like all this empowers him up chihuara
you mentioned you saw him in
mid-tournament he got his bearings
eventually maybe we'll see that in the
load line we just saw it too with tech
with arson so when ours was up there I
was like it's like his home I feel like
it's every year how many times have you
seen him up here right Aura buff is real
for players like that going back okay
we're doing this again but yes congrats
to laughing guarantee himself top three
but I mean that's what he got last year
right he doesn't want third place true
exactly you got to keep on Rising in the
ring so that's exactly what he's gonna
try to do against daru and win his
finals and let's take a look at these
replays
yes it's from uh the first game right
there you know the first round should I
took right he's showing signs of life we
thought you know maybe maybe he could
surprise left in the left and just just
I used it instantly yeah that's the
thing you need very solid defense on
Happy chaos right that's the thing with
the character obviously no if it's more
reversal whether you have meter or not
so you gotta earn those choices that man
leftin was so on point with the wake up
buttons that 2p just hit time and time
again really checking to see if
Chihuahua was bringing the real compact
pressure the frame shafts were not there
it's so frustrating when we play
fighting game and they keep mashing out
on you and like it's not fashion bro
it's like it's like yeah make me stop go
ahead and sometimes you know a short set
you don't have enough time to really
adapt and figure out the answer and a
good play from left and moving on there
yeah so left hand was gonna be our
winners finals let's take a look at the
bracket when we get a chance to see how
it's shaking out in the loser side of
things because as you mentioned we have
our first round of losers in this top
six chihuara and Umi show neubenheimer
and Barracks for that novel mirror in
the second match of losers quarters it's
gonna be great Michelle came all the way
here uh with only Seoul but maybe I have
to stay in that matches
you know what would be cool though if
she doesn't do that we're gonna get the
soul
I'm super excited too because watching
Rex yesterday uh I was with C4 he told
me he doesn't play Nago like the
American flag he doesn't he plays him
like a Samurai Showdown character what
do you mean like that and then I watch
and say oh I see yeah yeah very very
patient very very calm very very
controlled against a more kind of wild
U.S style Beyblade you saw how many
times hubenheimer blood bursted in that
opening round right like he is looking
to take that aggression to another level
so we will see that but of course guys
before we get for the rest of the match
we're gonna take a quick commercial
break you guys been popping off for that
chipotle ad so I don't know let me hear
some noise but we back with more
gilligator strive top sick right after
this
this is
[Music]
new Chicken al pastor is fire on every
level the fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground achiode balanced with
a splash of pineapple all combined for
the right amount of heat Chipotle's all
new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
[Music]
foreign
Victory feels good
[Applause]
down to three
foreign
[Music]
all right so ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to Guilty Gear strive top
six here at Evo 2023 look at that trophy
man well that is the cleanest Evo trophy
to date I love the way they're stepping
up the game and yeah I want that on my
mantle at home straight up hey look you
think left can lift that I don't know
[Music]
you saw that happy chaos yeah so Juno at
the Rings how are you enjoying the
action so far man I've enjoyed just
being here being an evil being in Las
Vegas
if you guys want to know I've seen some
of the shots it is packed right the
tickets sold out uh it's just it's
insane I've been here every year this is
the busiest pack I've ever seen this
whole week my discorder was just people
clamoring for Sunday passes right
because yeah everybody is in the
building it is sold out and we are
looking for some more Guilty Gear action
you can see the next match on Deck we
got the nagori Yuki mirror baby newbit
hyper versus Barracks you can see total
appearances that evil this is the very
first one for Barracks coming out of
Senegal going up against lubenheim and
yeah so you mentioned earlier this is a
new behind the second up here yeah right
so this is Battle the new Bloods right
now so Barracks apparently too I heard
he'd taken a break so early on when five
came out was grinding putting up a lot
of results but then when Juan Hiatus
went missing it just came back I think a
few months ago two months ago period it
is time to come back right the best time
to Peak is of course
Evo 2023 and yeah both these players are
some of the most deadly nagoriuki
players on the planet and from what I
heard Barracks is a has a very similar
story
what is this story talking about I was
just saying that neubenheim Reno come
out of the woodwork this is like his
first second year of competition really
started with strive I heard similar
about Eric's where he really started
with this game and trained on the the
streets of netplay right but just
showing how good that play is that you
can come out and make it here on the big
stage I want to see the difference in
style though I was gonna say I want to
get into that but before we do crowd who
likes steubenheimer
the USA boys we're the emeap block who's
here cheering for Barracks Make some
noise
[Applause]
Barry's gonna be in the building here
and yeah as you mentioned the playstyle
a little bit different newmanheimer we
saw the blood burst early that could
have been the Eno matchup but
nonetheless he likes to get aggressive
barracks on the other hand so methodical
about the way he picks his spots to
attack I watched varick's player set
yesterday went down game five he used
bite one time fight one time he bit one
time the entire set so completely
different play style that blood
management is for real but here we go
Nago versus Nago
whose player what who's players do all
right I've got new bernheim on the
default Costa right here Barrett's
running the blue early burst comes out
he knows how Daily Now can be exactly
and look at the blood difference right
now right guys this has all the freedom
in the world human Heimer he does have
that rage Advantage mode oh the same
brain cell yeah those old guildier clash
videos right now he saw was that
neubenheimer being higher in blood that
2s very fast so he actually beat Bears
to the punch after the trade yeah high
risk right now for Barracks but we saw
the steps of band right he's not
crumpling try to Beyblade but no the
fires is already out there what in the
world most of the other side we're still
picking it up he knows right he's been
in this experience before PRC with the
back turn again and he's trending the
Shizu and round cards did the exact same
thing in the first round yeah but
there's back away you know he doesn't
play that opening Gambit very very
defensive Style
oh
[Music]
I thought he was gonna be able to
continue yeah so did he very very
unfortunate kind of goes around away
right there we take those though we take
those absolutely absolutely especially
in a mirror mask like that you don't
feel sorry for the other players
and again very familiar situation it
feels very excited is back to the wall
the entire match so far as we talked
about a defense he's not one of the
players really rushed down and go in
exactly what a throw Tech from Barracks
as well allowing him to reprieve in the
quarter now both players on three yeah
five eight yeah they both puts the same
frame but there's no clash in this game
yeah
better spacing
wow we didn't punish there with the
Beyblade from full screen good match
with the 2K lower that blood a little
bit and reverse though super the first
time he gets aggressive yeah
take any advantage and you know you know
when your opponent is at a deficit like
that especially in a game like strive
they are so thirsty for that offer right
you feel like you've got to go in and
that's the perfect time you know let it
rip with that reversal super very smart
from nubenheimer right here to take a
Ascent lead here
yeah 100 I know you're better you're not
too distracted
very hard to deal with
trying to see if neubenheimer's gonna
get anti about the defense you see he's
trying to ibsd the strings as well that
FRS sequence is so important now I have
to play a really cool in the trade on
the second hit of the DP here the nice
block by the Beyblade back row back
confirm thank you to be actually slow
down we get this full combo exactly the
BRC locked him down right there drain a
little bit more blood with that six
eight here what's moving on it looking
out for Bears just filling frisky with
the 2s hey there's the fight you've been
saving that
the Legacy continues
in the corner
oh man caught on flinching at the worst
moment possible Chris noonia is in the
building Japanese traditional tattooing
going on
oh yes and again this is our first
losers match of the day so it's
elimination game coming up here for
Barracks to go out of fifth place still
a great showing for this first attempt
but obviously you want to go further in
the bracket than that ABC nubenheimer
even with the wins right still feeling a
little shaky he understands the stage
that he's on right now another one
that's like a cheese to start in the
last three rounds it feels like that's
like the most mystery option and the
fight would have connected but just a
little bit too early there from Barracks
three punishment Heimer
not too risky able to recover in time
hey oh and yeah it doesn't matter if
you're gonna pop it at that point right
because you're gonna be able to kill off
the opponent before the pop happens it's
a very nice dude stay in the line
hit
oh and then just jumps the fight on
Barracks his side as well so new
benheimer gonna be able to lower that
blood with the full far as box street
trying to threaten with the cheese Zoo
coming up short right now just resetting
the pressure they're just blocking no
IVs or anything but there we go tries to
jump out hold on is that a real chance
for Barracks now let's go into the 84.
this goes low
still nice defensive but I'm not
cracking that blood is filling up her
better so he had to back off
hey you see a
50 meters
last chance right here for better it's a
scary side not going the cut
Eric Stone he's got a lot of blood as
well so he can't be too aggressive about
how he approaches oh and Newman
heinenberg picking out the pressure
perfectly gets the back throw and stays
alive in top six yeah so that will be
our first elimination but come on guys
yeah Barracks all the way from Senegal
first time here at Evo makes the lane
top six makes the noise for barracks
great show yeah all the way from Senegal
man incredible players sends Guilty Gear
shrines launched I love the fact that he
was able to make it out to Evo and he
let everybody that didn't know know
today and hopefully you know this is
just the start you know we saw like
dar's been competing for 20 years
obviously a lot more embarrassed in the
future BS new Bernard moving on with the
Crunchyroll to share it on yeah I was
gonna say he knows where our bread is
being buttered thanks to new bernheimer
right there for sure but yeah man again
you talked about it right we got the
dichotomy of somebody like daru and
chihuara that have been in the game for
so long against these players left and
obviously been a game in a long time but
obviously knew the Guilty Gear same
thing with Newman Heimer and man these
players are just trailblazing yeah it's
not just we got veterans and new players
we have every region right in top six or
there's two players from Asia two from
na two from EMAs we're gonna find which
region is the strongest and it's so good
compared to the old days guilty where
it's just like you know it's Japan's
game yeah you can never compete with
them but the level of play worldwide has
just gotten so like high that anybody
can take it today yeah that's what's so
impressive to me about these new players
especially because they're not even like
modeling their gameplay after a certain
player on a character right like
neubenheimer rank one uh nagoriuki
somebody like being right was doing it
with chip while people were sleeping on
the character so it's just super sick to
see them bringing their own style their
own sauce to this game and the franchise
yeah we talked we've seen the replay
right here but we talked about it too
you know the the more aggressive style
American Eagle and we felt like the
whole time nubenheimer just had Barracks
Corner yeah playing offense right there
but when he did at the Block he'll have
to block two I got my whole package
right now exactly that's the great thing
about doomenheimer and that's really I
think a testament to the na weekly
culture as well right there's so many
weeklies for every fighting game in
North America right now thanks to the
great Neko that these fighting games are
coming out with now that numenheimer I
mean he's playing four tournaments a
week bro like he's giving as much
experience as he possibly can so as you
can see paying off on this stage big 3-0
over Barracks to guarantee himself a top
four finish yeah it's a great uh we
gotta shout out to all the deals out
there and all that deals all the
comedians out there you know running
these events building up these players
that come out here on the big stage and
perform so on the other side of the lose
bracket we got tudana who we saw lose
earlier against the reigning Evo
Champion reigning a defending a Guilty
Gear stride Evo Champion Umi show
obviously last year she did it on the
happy chaos this year though has taken
her talents to the soul bad guys it's so
funny there's no reason too right it's
not it's not like oh happy guys got
nerves like I already did it yeah let me
try a new character and bring it out
here yeah she played the entire
obviously if you have a pocket
application you always go backwards I
did it only with Seoul a character she
brought up from nothing yeah exactly
right all on her own but here we go on
the big stage uh we mentioned earlier
though so two not fall against leffen
okay maybe not too familiar in that
matchup but yeah so it's Soul it's sold
yeah if you're from Japan especially
right you're guessing it's definitely
know this whole matchup obviously we see
what Mochi does on the character mama
bought a lot of the stronger Souls come
out of the Japan region so he should be
prepared for whatever Michelle's gonna
bring to the table but I'm telling you
bro the processing speed of Umi show she
really registers things before they
happen in fighting games and with that
she's able to stay one step ahead
constantly she's a Valor player
OverWatch that's why yeah the OverWatch
is OverWatch bro he's got the FPS for
real the brain right there but yeah so
this is loser's side so you know you win
the tournament last year you're the
favorite to win this year but find
yourself in a rough situation can't
afford to take any more losses now so
the pressure is on that's a great point
the safety net for UMI show right is not
there at this point cannot afford
another loss neither of these players
can The Stance is ready yes of course
give us your predictions on Twitch as
well but I want to hear what the crowd
has to say first let me see who is
favoring
Umi show
[Applause]
right now
I really hope you can show off his
classic High play everyone get a chance
to show earlier
they give you a peek behind the curtain
I was gonna say two hour at first but I
just blinked
five parted at the moment so I said it
will be sure yeah I think I think it's
fair to say we show probably the crowd
favorite yeah for sure for sure
obviously raining defending Champion for
good to get shrived as we talked about
before but you are has been such a demon
in this game since it's launched
honestly a lot of people have had
problems with this fella but we are
getting the classic Heaven or Hell
indeed Soul bad guy versus Kai let's get
it they even got they got the the
constant reversed and everything I don't
know what the hell's going on yeah
that's so sick but yeah running the soul
color Kai we'll be still running that's
the Canadian tuxedo song yeah all denim
everything
so yeah knock down getting the the H5 we
gotta get Jack thinking some freshman
he'll get on three frame no way in the
first knockdown there is that shootout I
was telling you about earlier not afraid
of DP yeah playing with his arm always
when we show a scheming on the media
right there but the vapor threat none of
the shock state was there great instant
block you can see tuara already has the
nuances in this matchup
yeah Misha's gonna have to approach too
right not like happy cash gonna have to
get him close and that's what you gotta
wants you that's what I thought of that
DT goes wow the hard beats come out how
to Ranger stun difference
and you see that pressure though um
already showed a lot of respect for
which Aurora is capable of allows for
him to get the dash throw yeah we start
doing a lot of Dash blocking a very
strong technique you gotta recognize
that Dash throw to counter to that block
threatening with the 6p right just in
case let me show us a throw out of the
bar s but right now we're throwing out
volcanic pipe I like that we show right
back at you what a DP means I'll DP
right back yeah is he giving them that
respect now
with his life but fakes the overhead
goes forward advertise
Umi show gonna take a heart from her own
self now Dick Sage send a message nice
yeah response after movie show had a big
drop on that throw with but able to
recover keep the pressure going one
round a piece here game one nice with
Buddy ridiculous yeah
already got the screen Advantage as well
but tomorrow very comfortable with his
back to the corner yeah that keep going
to catch out the back dash hit confirm
on that band of room over there yeah
that works for good ridiculous for movie
show right there volcanic Viper
defeating the life on cot you see the
first fate he was disciplined about it
but still he's showing control
all right I guess you know it's one of
those situations where you kind of you
burst and they bait it you don't burst
and you die yeah choosing choosing to
just hold on to it a lot of times the
players will burst there just in case
the player has the Executioner or
something like that right but Chihuahua
he just wants to get to game two maybe a
sign of respective
at all man game one and we should
defending Evo champ
advantage of that right after the
counter here right you know she doesn't
want to have to happen again
and didn't even spend the 50 right we're
gonna wait and make sure that hits they
make decision after that oh wow and uh
he did this with the RC off that has a
favorite thrust completely whipped umizo
trying to go with those birthday combos
again
let's slow down there with the piercings
he saw the 2p come out he chose to
swinging the juvenile punish right that
a slow motion was enough
wow
wow super early on that jump H tube that
very active hitbox shoot I just ran into
it precisely that's what caused you are
off guard right there right he was
definitely thinking he could respond to
something later and that jump age was so
active so quickly
yeah we're talking about being
comfortable in the matchup you know of
course I don't know what this magic
looks like uber show is a pro too
exactly and look at this
WOW every time there's a gap
that's what they call me show we talked
about the processing speed
RC into the wild bro you thought you
were gonna have to hold this but hey
you're not even he dad dashbox right
into the grab too it's crap you bought
the neck hold on now the 2-0 for Uber
looking very very strong
I thought maybe you know starting and
losers might put some pressure on her
make her a bit nervous but she's playing
very clean that was such a sickly punish
to start as well has been so on point
with that but just as I say does get
counter here trying to swing a little
bit too early what up beautiful I've got
the punish right here
nothing EP for movie show
what a wave punish as well from tomorrow
he's been looking super clean on his own
right even down 2-0 at this point spend
the 50 and make sure the wall bake get
the positive but you just made this come
back before six eight round start into
the faint what a combo the house
gonna break them back through the other
wall that's positive bonus for her as
well as you are though almost at 100
attention
oh no PRC back against the plane run up
delay close ass right there umizo smile
a little bit bro let me show him a
strike bro pressure has been 100 correct
so far even delayed it too exactly and
just delay it oh you should check now
you should press button now no get hit
and now Michelle got the corner trying
to swing his way out this is his last
chance wow Nation round right here
Umi show has not let a single whip go by
her right now
[Music]
on the other side and we've seen her
aunt here with 5p as well right so it's
working both ways we got 50 meter while
after we'll do it next in RC will do it
out your last chance there it is
fakes the high low and just goes for a
command grab you instead three oh
domination from Ubi show moving on into
losing side and chill out all you can do
is laughs right all you can do is
awesome all right you got me can you
beat my ass that time but pretty much
right we talk about the processing speed
from when we showed that in last
instance was a perfect example of that
she had established the fake overhead
it's a little earlier right you see the
fake overhead your mind instinctually
goes to the fact that you have the block
blow she switches it up again goes with
the wild Crow so smart playing against
her opponent's expectations but yeah
just like we saw the lyrics we have
another player eliminated there so you
know first time out here in Vegas going
all the way finishing fifth place guys
can please make some noise for churada
from Japan
sometimes those matches you just you
can't come up with the answer mid-set
yeah right just catch like this player's
got my number I can't figure it out I
got lots of tapes the tempo and speed
that she plays at it's so tough to
adjust the mid-set right like you really
need that matchup experience against her
or someone that plays at that speed to
really survive in tournament it looked
like fighting a bot right everybody
everybody you press is out of ranges
with punishes right back he's like what
is this level ACP that's what's going on
it feels like she's an input reader like
somehow some uh like a half uh second
step ahead of everybody I I love how too
I was hyping about Chiron is like a DP
monster he stuck with the DPS but umizo
Lane I think eight eight for eight
legitimately every time there was a gap
in the block strings chihuara like
exposed by uh the volcanic Viper from
Umi show was so good and is that band in
revolver pressure you know you can pick
the follow-up you can RC go for the high
low so every time you block that Bandit
right we should have had the correct yes
on the mix-up but now we're down to our
top four I love that they cut the replay
as he got spooked right that's all
that's all we need to see okay we can't
show it here but yes we got four players
remaining out of the top six so in the
winners final they got Dar you know from
Korea against big humongous wow so yeah
we got Asia and Europe in winners finals
and then it's an all-us affair in that
lower semis with Umi show and Newman
heinbach yes Argentina the top three
we're gonna have every one of them
represented so we could find determine
who is the strongest out here that is I
exactly what we want honestly that is
the ideal result of a top six so big UPS
to all of our players in the building
that have already competed in Guilty
Gear stripe but we still got a champion
to Crown but before we do that we're
gonna thank our ads I think our sponsors
for make it evil 2023 happen we'll be
right back do not go anywhere
[Applause]
using promo code hdkn 236 and received
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
you got this only a handful of people in
the world can do it
you could be
the best
these are incredible steaks
you're going to be forced to make Split
Second decisions that could cost you
your life get out whether you like it or
not you are in this race
Gran Turismo based on a true story radio
PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
foreign
thank you
I'm a cloud
y Skies
welcome back everyone to Evo 2023 we are
in the building Guilty Gear strive top
six we are looking to crowded Champion
crowd can I hear y'all
that's what I'm talking about maybe I
need that energy I'm feeding off of it
it has been tremendous matches so far
today already right we are seeing the
explosive action and Guilty Gear is
known for do you know how you enjoy
anything I'm enjoying it I I'm a bit sad
I want to chill out do a little bit
better but unfortunately this is the
level play we talked about earlier like
there is no dominant region anymore
right as we see with the results you
know we're gonna see the bracket in a
second but we got Asia we got n a we got
emea right these are the arc Revo before
they're all separated Now offline is
back we can have them in person duking
it out this is truly the culmination of
international competitions right evil
was always the champion showcase for
every single region and how they bring
their play style to the Grand stage and
right now we got all of them represented
right here Korea Sweden us all in this
bracket here Dono and leffen going to be
battling out on the winners finals while
Umi show at nubenheimer two Staples here
in North America entering damn near
every tournament they can possibly enter
gonna be battling it into the top three
yeah that's a good point right very very
you know they'll lose a semi-finals two
players very very familiar with each
other right so the match-up knowledge is
there the experience is there it's just
like how they gonna play today what are
they gonna do indeed indeed but before
we get to that action I want to take a
look also look at one of our players in
that Winners finals let's take this look
at a video presented by daru
[Applause]
hi I'm
past the sixth prayer of a kitty gears
tribe every year thousands of fgc
competitors try to reach the top of the
Evo Mountain to become the evolution
champion and this year PlayStation's
road to Evo offered Gamers a chance to
win a trip to compete at Evo 2023
representing Seoul South Korea daru is
no stranger to the Evo main stage he
finished top eight at last year's Guilty
Gear strive tournament knockdown once
again rinse recycle repeat guard break
fall
six on the grandest stage in the fgc
he's back this year and ready to
dominate Guilty Gear strive again but
the question is will the rest of Evo's
top six be ready for him
please
so good stuff and thanks to PlayStation
for making it happen in dark you know
out here how was God like you win a
tournament we get flown out to Vegas and
here you are in top four playing in the
winners finals on the big stage it's a
beautiful thing man the PlayStation
tournament series we saw Gene come out
here melted blood from that series as
well right so definitely pick up the
PlayStation I see you darwu the Three
Six Mafia popping my collar all right
bro swag to you and we're gonna see it
on pool display here up against one ball
William Lefton in Grand fire or excuse
me winners five I love this is a great
kind of you know we have Dar we talked
about it someone who all about character
love right I believe in my character
thick and thin and then we have the
complete opposite on the other side with
big left you know he plays a lot of
games competitive dying you know play to
win that's why I laughed in the middle
of your favorite right because I saw
where you were going and my man left and
he is like the loyalty is to the
strength that is it right yeah he's all
about playing in the the strong
characters the one that is going to give
him the best chance at winning from the
character select screen that's very
smart and if you put that much time into
the game like he does you know if you're
a scientist you're always working you're
always ground you want to make sure your
character can match kind of the effort
you put into it that's a great Point
that's a 100 a great point because a lot
of times these lab monsters they really
want to try to bring characters above
where they normally are on the tier list
right I mean sometimes it could feel
like fruitless rather than fruitful and
my man left it he always picks these
characters that has so much to explore
he was playing zato before he had the
chaos right the lab monster character
exactly the one that would reward you
for working hard but here we go winners
finals right now
this is David was a little pop with that
video earlier indeed indeed speaking of
which crowd who loves Zara
and winners final
[Applause]
I said cheer for me bro I know a lot of
left pants in the building who likes
leopin here makes a noise
no that that CM Punk John Cena reaction
gets me every time baby
let them know maybe leffen is one of
those
rights hand warmies here you know the
classic the classic smash make sure
everything is perfect you know on the
big stage we've seen we've seen accent
don't forget to set their buttons you
know it's half but you can't afford it
right now and of course it gives you
time to get your prediction in on Twitch
oh yeah well you know what I'm saying
bet those Channel points but I'm glad
you call it hand warmings because that's
what they are baby the button checks are
there on the character select you're
just trying to warm your hands up right
they test the execution right here but
yeah sorry so here we go the real one
check it you see look he thinks he'll
get notes or a picture you know I don't
even know
he's a relatively new Guilty Gear player
yeah absolutely Darwin's result 20-year
veteran so old school versus new school
character love versus
tearless enjoyer
tear Enthusiast is how I like to flip it
you know the river Sweden let's rock
yeah the big one is that he's also a
dragon ball player right but when he
does dabble outside of Smash it's
usually these high Tempo fast-paced
games
man we talked to about a matchup
experience as well so you know Zara
another player in the Asia region where
Patrick yes is not very common not well
represented zaru is a one of the most
World Warriors out of Asia though right
like he went to the Gear project last
year he's got more experience than a lot
in that region have him against happy
chaos and the other two is like when you
don't get started it does not matter who
her opponent is right she's gonna miss
you no matter what yeah he's on the
behind the back the Magic Johnson shot
right there from left mid off the stop
already off to a roaring start and just
walk toward it bro right the thread of
that gunshot at any moment makes you
want to block and Lounge it oh in a loud
big left to just run up and grab you and
taking the burst in game one oh goodness
bro put his burst on his mantle right
there ex machina empty the cliffs only
to reload him
get the focus back and everything get
the bullet ton of damage as well all of
the jump is so good right there catching
Darwin trying to backstash not gonna
finish the job just yet DRC slows him
down but left is still very disciplined
on the defensive end there
very confident playing today in game one
going away I really like the decision he
made after it looked like a whiff 2p
right he just went with a throw
afterwards he took advantage of the
unfamiliar spot that daru was in there's
that delay the Air Supply right there it
did a lot of work in his first match
let's see if we can do some work here
and win his finals a lot of backpacks
comes from left-hand too yeah definitely
clean back that's right there cursed up
again so even with the high mobility of
you know she's still gonna be locked out
but not when she's on the Block side of
things yeah so we saw 11 was talking
about how he was pressing buttons on
defense this time Zara says okay you
want to do that you want to match I got
frame traps let's see if that changed up
like his uh decision making now when he
hit the blocks oh yeah and Murphy you
want to close that distance with that
stage change BRC a very popular option
for players but chemical UPS down that
they told me that moves guys got got no
use what happened all right that movie
Stick double roll we saw that yesterday
a lot too from Levin
ouch exactly who wants that corner he
wants the biggest reward possible right
there so you get the plus raise the
positive bonus and left him just
smuggling right now same attack sequence
as last time right breaks the wall then
air Dash in there with the jump ass and
the bullet so even if you back that you
still get caught There's No Escape that
was straight up ruthless aggression on
the side of left and now
no stroke
reaction runs up low profiles with the
two ends with a dash throw from Zara
right there able to avoid the stop
pressure the fds I think kept happy
chaos in front as well great recognition
oh six speeds again though he knows all
the gaps you're not getting free
pressure on somebody like lesson these
are all you know what left me doing is
the correct choice but they all have
risk behind them right
wow oh chemicals immediately prevents
lesson from taking his eyes
OTG enough
and Method he was expecting Darwin to
immediately take advantage of that block
burst right you saw him holding that
deep for his life but daru was kind of
the delayed pressure con really hard the
Rhythm was just thrown off completely
yeah recognized I couldn't kill right
there he was not ready for the kill just
immedi got the Eno bring go for the
mix-up right away the Eno break for real
this is what the character lives for
nice job
I've been going for the the entire every
time to double jump the Dives in gets a
whiff on it
[Music]
sometimes people are not ready to punish
that like every time
nothing on a stage like this the type of
player he is he won't let that slip
through the cracks you
were starting to be changes too in the
approach from daru that's coming from
different angles different approaches
because life has been so good he's doing
so well and just keeping him out and
that's the big thing about having chaos
right he can stabilize those combos with
a gunshot so even these weird awkward
hits you get on Eno because she's got
the number Dash he's still making it
happen
oh the backache ERC and he got the side
stop dude my goodness I'm out here
jigging around in my chair he's playing
his own game this game and first just
after kid was able to hit very dangerous
but left him right back in him either
and he made that last little account so
hard but he's not reloading right now he
was still in the stand and no Cliff
doesn't matter back throw incident on
Deck lesbian taking a lead and two to
one right now that was a really big
chance right there for Dar right there's
no bullets anything he had the
positioning but no the throw gonna do it
two to one left one game away from going
to Grand finals on the winner side it's
a huge advantage
I guarantee him a better finish than
last year as well yeah that's a great
point he would be guaranteed top two but
you know he wants another Evo trophy on
his Manta garu looking to make that
dream a nightmare okay change it up
right he's been flying in so this time
actually good for stroke he's dead very
smart definitely not a lot of Strokes
being represented up until this point
good adjustment from Darrow even gets a
perfect on the board with it
sick on that bike definitely trying to
get back in the match right away
air-to-air Goldberg how's he gonna use
his meter that was 24K oh we got it all
right it has to be one of the last
frames to go possibly
he's not afraid
don't forget about his DNA baby he's not
afraid
good stuff that's a good waste of 50
meters too right that's Baker weapon and
again we're just getting the loop like
what's on the first game
knocked down he's got positive got 50
meter
still keeping the pressure up perfectly
timed on the frame trap now one round
away from her grand finals part three
July chants are
we've seen some annotations about this
set but again it might be too little too
late it could be the second shot is the
one I ended up catching daru flinching a
little bit wow he's on the chemical Love
Actually gets shot at the start of that
two two and a one and walk by possibros
again
moving on the grand finals on the
Winner's side I love that too because
leffen even hesitated with that last
shot right he let him FD ahead of time
and train before letting the shot go out
so smart you can tell he's a happy chaos
veteran and Wombo William brand finals
winners side that was I mean I don't
want to say it but after watching that
like I said that peppery Splash match
yesterday with Lapin when he made that
comeback is it something's different
about him this year right something is
different he wants this he's been
grinding and here he is on the winner
side he's one of those I really love the
fact that you highlighted did it the
Comfort ability on this stage right
leften is one of the best he thrives off
of a big world championship stage like
this and you can see it time and time
again that's why he was down to pick 3
2-1 and came back I mean the man is a
menace to say the least I was watching
with someone in the crowd and like they
put it so perfectly they just said yeah
leften's a gamer I was like no you're
you're right like this is what he lives
for the gamer right this is this is it
he doesn't worry about this right he's
been here before and yeah let's watch
some of the replays here dog had a
couple Signs of Life there but laughing
is so good at just you know controlling
the whole screen with this character
yeah and again he doesn't get this
discouraged we talk about that mental
composure so much and it's so easy to
start letting your mental crumble in
this game with how powerful the offense
is from daru from Eno but left and
always stayed very solid even right here
right he didn't get greedy trying to
punish right there he knew he was in air
while the super was going on it was
going to be tough to hit her before the
sound came out so we just took the
proper positioning I mean the man is
just making Optical look at his
attention here look at the tension on
daru he's just like oh man
oh man he smiling too he's like yeah all
right you got me it's kind of like a
Checkmate situation right there but it
was 11 had to work harder build that
situation up exactly right you uh don't
get into that situation without hitting
your opponent mad times first so
definitely big up for left and right
there Grand finals winner side Advantage
as we see who gets the face Eno daru and
loses finals that Umi show or that noob
in height so we got a team kill here I
guess we're at America versus America
last year's Champion versus
top eight last year so this is his best
performance but he's out here playing
very very well beating Barracks earlier
3-0 yeah man in the nagoriyuki mirror
right I think all people will probably
consider those two uh the best
nagoriuki's in the world at ubenheimer
able to come out on top but yeah Umi
show we talked about it they're gonna
have plenty of match-up experience you
can see each other and I want to see
when we show obviously going to start
with the soul but is that going to be
the character that she finishes there's
definitely gonna be some pride on the
line too where it's like you know I came
all the way here with Seoul I want to
you know go so the whole way do you
really want to bring a happy cast after
you've come so far yeah stick with your
guy I don't know we'll see it's one of
those characters yeah that can bully
nagoriyuki right that's why I think
about the happy chaos because it's good
at playing the nagoriyuki especially
when he's high blood and he's got a spin
meter to get in whether it be with the
fuku or the Beyblade and then he'll
burst after but I really think Umi show
wants to do this on the soul right she
has connected with this character
throughout the year she has brought it
into top six I don't think she's gonna
shake off at any time soon better tell
the tape here and they like we talked
about it before but it's so nice saying
all the different you know backgrounds
everybody has and so yeah two very new
players The Guild gear but two of the
best players in the entire world so he's
never too late to pick for fighting game
and don't forget
that took first place looking to add
that trophy to her mantle as well Toby
is sick I like it too dude it is a
really really cool huge is heavy I've
seen it looks great in the photos man I
want to get down there and get a closer
look here but yeah so we're gonna be
moving on here loser semis we saw the
fist bump oh yeah soul versus Nago you
know when you go up against like someone
you fight all the time what do you do
you play your standard game or do you
have any tricks you think you've been
saving like the Ace in the Hole for the
big stage what are we gonna see here my
opinions all these about that outside
the box thinking but first off I want to
hear a crowd do y'all like Newman Heimer
some support but I think I think the fan
favorite if you like Umi she'll make
some noise
[Applause]
right there when she heard her name I
think we talked about how weapons
confident too but Michelle also is
always smiling you know I think it's
really important as a fighting game
players being able to relax have a good
time you're playing games at the end of
the day yeah absolutely it is one of the
most important things to remember I
think her and Razz are so the two best
players that feeding off the ground so
we'll see how that applies here it's a
loser semi-finals
you know and both of these characters I
think a lot of the time not bought as
the best characters in the game but when
it comes to tournament three out of five
set two of the best and you can't tell
me different
whoa
you can't press and then he is the
car I would be close but I'm a
little further than you thought this is
just two hits by the way
to touch oh
that was a two-hit round right damn it
and then the back dash buddies right
here two tons of baby and then the Judo
top round let's start we'll adjust the
stepper side you land on
support
even with the wall break not enough dude
I'm working double perfect right now
let's see
who is that get pulled RC at the
end there he's even drifting back a
little bit trying to catch a counterpoke
Escape back in a way Bandit beautiful
spacing right there right out of my
Japan and bring her 5K pun double
perfect for game one but oh was it
actually double it was double probably
this is guilty is drive though all right
okay that's just one it's fine it's fine
a double perfect definitely does more
mental damage in almost every other game
than this one yeah exactly all right
well it happened again all right yeah
yeah exactly happened again and um it
doesn't even look like it's facing her
to be honest take a little break in
simple water
taking the adjustments as they come all
in stride for the shrive you know what
I'm saying yeah of course you know it
didn't work all right let me adapt let
me try something different this time
let's see how she changes up her games
so yeah establishing the gun flame as
well should be able to mix in the faint
later on oh the jump age we talked about
level four and a medium all the mechanic
Viper confirmed for the big damage yeah
that's super early jumpy just active the
whole time on the back dash Air Force
the first yeah
try to hold on to this first round he's
not going to immediate walls play has a
5k finishing it off that was like a Las
Vegas perfect that was like 99 right all
right right back at you all right we'll
make them going back and forth in
between these two and then jackpot on
that one new driver just ain't in that
combo with a double 5K was maybe looking
for a Twist media I'm not sure Bantu on
these different Michelle right she knows
how to deal with these strings they put
some second thoughts in their new power
and no fool but no punish
I mean it recovered so quick that you
really got to be on point with the
punish
we're gonna get a break here
ready to flood of the process
I got one of those two indeed then we
got the back road make sure to cover all
his faces with the OS because he knows
the wall break will kill very very smart
from nubenheimer right there okay
first time you're on the big stage does
not seem phase at all yeah for real
rubenheimer is looking as comfortable as
he is can't open her icfc or whatever
weekly he answers he had us yes is that
training right you you're playing
tournaments that you said like every day
five or seven days a week right now so
you just do it while you practice on the
big page
gameplay
to uh tailor it to his opponent and is
so smart the long distance
look at this
oh yeah she takes to the air he was a
sentient with the end of there and
there's the bomb is this huge from the
show it's not a big chance to bring
yourself back into the game tries for
the reset Mass back on oh
wait no no enough alone right that clone
always going through any projectile
exactly best projectile in the game
right there it costs some blood but man
is it worth it yeah you should put out
the full screen maybe expected a fukio
Ford yeah you could definitely see that
lubenheimer you can see him shaking his
head constantly though right there
because he knows that was so close from
slipping through his grass that jumped
it was super nice but then dropping the
end it put himself in it uh the blood
pop making a lot of damage Trudeau chop
again really just uh relying on that
upper body in full the challenge
the volcanic Viper comes up completely
wins but she's still pressing this is
that uh familiarity to know each other
so every DP has been getting baited by
new timers who got hit by every single
one of uh yeah and the Soul sliced in
two right there off the wall break now
neubenheimer on set point three shots if
y'all want to be shot already and make
some noise right now
[Applause]
gonna be finishing it at least top three
yes 3-0 very very dominating performance
there for neubenheimer okay but yeah I
want to hear y'all give it up for the
reigning defending Champion let's hear
it
obviously you know I'm sure she would
have loved to Win Again by two evos
first place fourth place right that's
amazing dude
especially when she's still such a
fledgling in fighting games man last
year was her first Evo skill Tigers
Drive is her first competitive game when
we see her on stage next year what
character she's gonna be playing yeah
next year or something I don't know but
yeah good good showing good stuff but
yeah dude I'm moving on and looking very
very strong too so oh man you know if
your daughter and laughing right there
like oh yeah
somebody's coming up lubenheimer is
warming up he is looking deadly to say
the least after dropping he started new
winners record right fell to the losers
but man he has looked Unstoppable since
then so we're gonna see a hundred
percent
it's gonna be good man but of course we
got a big left in Grand finals right and
of course awaiting now is that daru
versus lubenheimer in losers bracket
side of things there we go and that was
3-1 in Winter semis they had already
faced each other right but sometimes you
know you drop down into the losers you
get to play more matches especially that
performance into Umi show you're like
I'm kind of nice you might feel himself
right now exactly personally I always
pay for the person that lost in winners
bracket when the losers bracket run back
happens you get yeah you get the warm-up
you got the data and everything there's
less pressure on you you know you kind
of when you drop the losers you know you
kind of write yourself off yeah
everything from here on out let me just
have fun with it go with it nothing to
lose at that point right at newpenheimer
he's got that Intel from daru in that
winter semi side of things so yeah man
I'm expecting neubenheimer to continue
this momentum often it also happens to
be that neubenheimer coming from the
losing side of bracket wins to go into
this match while Naru loses to go into
this side right the emotional you know
the mental state for both these players
is a bit different there but yeah so
we're gonna have our losers finals and
then the winner not gonna face big left
but before that guys your favorite ad is
coming back so this is gonna be the last
break but before we finish out the Guild
of Gears Drive top six so don't go
anywhere we'll be back right after this
Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients and real kitchens can
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurants pickup
or delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
oh no
super Lola
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we attendo are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each tenno product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
do you know who you are when you think
you're worse
your birthday
[Music]
and welcome back everyone to Evo 2023
presented by Chipotle we are here with
the Guilty Gear strive top six and we
are all so close to crowning a new
reigning defending Champion Umi shall
bow down in fourth place so we are
crowning a new title holder here today
yes yes so top six but we're down just
to three players so next up we come with
the losers finals the winner of this
gonna go on the face big left and he's
looking
strong today oh yeah absolutely Womble
William in the building in Prime form
we're going to see him in a little bit
of course but first we gotta get that
winner semis run back in losers finals
now right at daru versus Lupine yeah so
it was three three one three one forget
it I think it was three one we saw the
first match of the day but you know
neubenheimer in the last bunch of the
only show played a little bit different
looked very very calm very very
uncontrolled so see if he brings any new
tricks to this matchup exactly we're
gonna take a look at the bracket if I'm
not mistaken but this might be the tale
of the tape either way we are going to
get one of the strongest players there
it is daru versus nubenheimer in the
building again we talk about it right
eight total appearances that Evo doll
has been coming out here since excerpt
he was one of the Staples in the Mikado
arcade even while being from Korea right
he spent a lot of time in Japan training
to get his skills up in Guilty Gear and
you can see a payoff time and time again
yeah and so we it's not on here but
years active 20 years active yeah 20
years active and on the other hand like
talk about guilt your veteran you got
Darth on the other hand we've got
nubenheimer very new player is the best
performance so far on the big stage and
you know you expect a new player to
maybe feel some nerves or anything up
here but he's looking very very
comfortable bro he looks like he's been
there before right he right he's
handling it
professionally and to be honest he
started as an online Warrior number one
ranked a new I was gonna say number one
Ray Newman
to start and then he took his talents to
offline one CEO Taco one Festival of
fights has constant top a placings no
matter what environment he plays in now
though he's got to complete that run
back if he hopes to get a chance at the
title yeah so we saw the fist bumper
there guys the guys are ready to start
so if you like gar you know all the way
from Korea guys makes the noise
all right all right all right if you
like America's Last Hope here give it up
for new binheimer
that is the hometown down here you said
it right this is the last hope for
America so we get into it yeah I saw
that on the little screen right the
purse is baited already instantly you're
down to like 15 hell in seven seconds
welcome to go figure Strife with a burst
from the great white North oh Canadia
salute you with that one but Newman
Heimer tied it out one good old Stripes
yeah the timing too on like the closed
ass he just delays it for that half a
second so you try to jump you try to
press a button and nope he always
catches you he just gives you just
enough
right there too it's so scary
that was beautiful conditioning and then
he tries another fight but has the PRC
to make it safe continue the pressure
going Darrow getting caught flinches
this Intel is paying off for neubenheim
that was a very fast game one oh that
was the game by the way that was not
around that was a game yeah that was a
game already in the books right there
newmanheimer taking the first game and
we just talked about it if you're just
showing us this was the winter semisback
3-1 adarro neubenheimer already got as
many games on the board as he did then
yeah you know you have mine after the
loss to think about what you should do
differently the next time you face it
now he's showing exactly and a lot of
time the person that won that set is
thinking about the next opponent right
they're not thinking about it let me
just do it again yeah
see the pressure just doesn't stop
neubenheimer had no resources no
personal YRC but yeah that air that
junkie that hairs but you know Doug did
a lot of work the first time they met
and they started when I was blocking it
right he's adapting now we talk about
resources
nice pop-up indeed because we just
talked about it the command throw just
landed you know nago's not gonna stop
this pressure when the blood bar is
empty yeah it's a very brave and it pays
off nice read on Dar with the reversal
super backlashing the DP super smart
right there though she was coming out
stuck in the 5K with a stroke as well
you see I believe that instant block is
what led him to that punish in the first
place right kept Darwin closed
throughout the block stream
nice yes
darling trying to figure out when the
Gap the new behind me strings are coming
oh my goodness yeah that was a little
funky right there I'm gonna be on team
but we're gonna pick it up regardless
nobody Heimer doesn't want to see more
of that yeah late first delay the
purpose of guard did not try to bait it
lock him into the right back in the
corner fakes the high lands go high
again
for real
that's when you can start to play
nice Jack but again the offensive burst
is keeping that corner
oh he is the block as well and six eight
no free pushback for you
the PRC he saw this fight trying to make
it safe and then just Beyblade in Gossip
counted gonna get to confirmed even with
the pop watch out yeah the pump was not
hit right so he's not gonna suffer a
punch or anything like that the YRC
that's all hitbox don't hurt box so it
didn't connect
yes the tip got the counter hit that was
a round one oh the Shizu from a local
that was Steph Curry
but whatever it was it connected it was
counter and again just the anger the
offense gonna hanubenheimer here
this is looking good here he's on the
verge of putting more games on the floor
they did last time he saw the instant
block allow Zara to recover quick that's
the fact that's brcs
see any combo after that as well
that was a wild man things oh my God
using your hyper dance to go over the
Beyblade but do not recovered in time
able to check with 2p oh I know Dara
challenges I'm gonna get the side swap
yup super sparkling girl right here you
gotta run a month over neubenheimer he's
gonna take the wall break need that
burst though you need to get it go but
you gotta do something
yeah that's the thing right going back
to the neutral and this is whenever just
needs one Beyblade worth of damage is a
little scary I need to do it too
anything to do it that was a beautiful
setup right there though using the nose
and the chemical love after knowing
Newman hyper cam Beyblade under it yeah
the zoning is working
he might want to bet on the Beyblade
though because that one will kill off
daru it's still gonna make him blood
work there it is it came out
he had to do it eventually right Gardner
that kept his assistant stayed in the
air so it whips
definitely earned that round oh and
again you talked about the splint Lane
overhead we're splitting
6h out of range not low the blood at all
and then stroking under the 5K low
profiling the stroking of the 5K has
become a tale of the tape for the set
oh and it confirms on the 5K allowing
that blood to drain it's gonna be a good
look and now he's day and night that's
the big thing and now he's in for this
pressure super doesn't even need it just
six H say it with your chest two to one
new but I'm already doing better than
they did in the last time indeed more
games on the board here we're just three
games in noonheimer he's got to take one
in the next two to get into Grand finals
yeah so the DP uh he's been doing a lot
of work on the opening game the dunk is
counted does not care just burst wants
to keep the pressure coming does not
work out Darwin's got the offense now
try the fuzzy what a block that was
ridiculous from Newman hyper he was
stuck standing and he knew it
Darwin though this is literally no
safety net now you cannot drop another
game so he is truly Unleashed at this
point taking a strong lead in this round
you know it too someone's been playing
you know for 20 plus years he's a lot of
tricks
he's ready for that jumps over gets the
punish from behind that one's super sick
stayed out of the range of it with a 2K
oh
oh wow so fast yes so the hover went
over the Beyblade drc5p
every cornered back the way because Dara
showed he's willing to reversal earlier
close as counter hit
that was such great patience from
neubenheimer right there because as you
highlighted the 50 tension it could have
been a YRC it could have been a super he
was waiting for that rubenheimer on set
point and it's a great start here too
that burst is gone Dyers quarter once
again
to
her soul
you got 50 he got Goldbergs he's got the
light please got the round lead
everything's done on the side right now
oh chance here yeah that could have been
it oh my God
last second to hold on no he's did you
see that crowd yeah Ducks under the
chemical glove Punisher the 5-h and
there you go dubenheimer gets his
revenge from the winner side 3-1 over
daru Dar out in third place fifth place
last year third place this year great
stops it down so everybody give him a
round of applause
[Applause]
that is a staple if you go together
right here man whether it be in Asia he
always streams as well one of the most
popular streamers for Guilty Gear strive
he is at one of the best in the business
to say the least and like we said he
came out here just to get that jacket
yeah he got his jacket and oh wait I got
third places
like bro I got this jacket I got a third
place consolation prize couldn't be
happier I think that's the best thing
too it's like all the players I've ever
seen so far everyone's enjoying the game
but also taking it very very seriously
it's the beauty of fighting games it's a
really a sick like camaraderie balance
that Guilty Gear striving specifically
has created right with the Great Neck
code all these players from every region
have really come together and gotten to
know each other yeah now we got season
three come we've got Johnny this game's
got a bright future ahead of itself man
so I'm looking forward to it but as for
Evo 2023 it's been a the biggest
tournament ever we had almost 2500
people the biggest Guild of gear
tournament in 25 years but we're down to
just two oh my goodness indeed the grand
finals is here bro leffen and Newman
heiner you can see the bracket on your
screen right now neubenheimer completing
to run back up against daru from Winter
semifinals literally reversing the score
left it on the other hand only dropped
one game to daru dropped at zero game to
tuwara he is six at one going into this
Grand finals all the momentum is in his
corner I asked you off Stream So I said
out of the people left who do you
think's got the best chance against left
and you said I think Lubin Heights and
the way he's been playing too after
getting knocked down and loses the
confidence decision making and with a
character like Naga all you need is one
right all you need is one hit and
neutenheimer he hasn't really strayed
from the path of nagori UK right like
he's used to fighting these bad matchups
that quote unquote these matchups where
you can kind of get zoned out as Nago he
knows the bets on when to go with the
Beyblade the forward fukio and he just
seems to be right more often than he's
not but he's got to go up against you
know humongous left who's sitting in the
wiener side of Grand Final so how did he
get here today what has he done what has
he shown us so far I think we got some
highlights ready and it's going to be a
lot of gunshots I think oh yeah yeah
letting the clips look making everybody
look and making them shook that is what
leopard does baby and then we talk about
how you used to the Grand finals evil
stage he is casually walking up the
stage like oh I'm back here again
another year but against this was super
one-sided unfortunately I didn't get a
chance to play like the thing about left
in the is that it feels foreign when
he's not on the top eight stage right
like that's when he's like what's like
how my trip doesn't feel complete but
this is where he belongs this is what he
lives for a grand finals winner side
Advantage is a huge one at that as well
yeah and he is like so far it seems like
he hasn't really been pressured no in
top six he hasn't really had any sweat
he's been in control of every match even
though they're laughing now oh you got
me all right fairness good he looked
very much more Disturbed on my peppery
Splash scent right like what he was down
to one he let that second victory for
peppery just slip through his fingers he
like made a motion of frustration but
you can see the way he gets it together
right he's one of those players that
when the emotions bubble up he's able to
thrive off of it and that is a special
talent yeah and also definitely one of
the hardest working players whatever
game he plays he commits his time right
he was supposed to play some other games
and he dropped out the focus on strive
and it looks like it was a good decision
here but uh yeah his opponent on the
other hand we've been hyping him up here
so neubenheimer one of the newer players
uh to guilty gears Drive popped up on
the scene last year in the game
yesterday I guess two years now it's
been a while yeah
like it honestly but yeah so making a
name for himself online but now he finds
himself here oh brand finals here at
evil 2023 Grand finals yeah I first got
familiar with newmanheimer via the can
opener weekly from yeah of course he was
the number one ranked in the Gory Yuki
online he took his talents to go up
against the other Pro players I was like
wow this kid's for real and then he took
his talents to the offline seat where he
won his very first tournament in CEO
taco and ever since then I mean the foot
has not left the pedal yeah so here's
the Highlight table beating umisho last
year's championship I got what takes to
be a champion yeah exactly what it takes
right now uh he's coming from the loser
socks he's going to be left in two sets
but either way we will be crowning a new
guilty gears Drive champion at ebook
2023. and when it comes to these players
that haven't been on this stage before
it's very easy to get enamored with the
lights right the crowd and everything he
has been laser focused man he has not
really acknowledged anything besides his
opponent and the bag he's gonna put the
body in and I was talking about matchup
experience too you know I mentioned
maybe out in Asia there's not that many
happy cast players but neubenheimer net
playing here in the States you don't
think he's familiar with this match I
think he knows a thing or two about
playing happy now right obviously um
played the character of pledge before
she uh switched the soul full time but
we got dende and a couple of other very
strong happy chaos players in North
America as well so he's going to be very
ready but that goes the same for left
and right I believe leffen has played
against Barracks plenty of times oh yeah
well that's my goat right there
that matchup is going to be firmly under
the belt hey we got the double Esports
pose right here with left hand and
nubenheimer tales in the game left in it
it's crazy to think he's an OG now too
absolutely all sorts of different games
but he's been around a very long time so
definitely is the experience Advantage
right now yeah isn't that wild the first
appearance 2013 that was 10 years ago
bro that is a veteran of double digits
at Evo and even beyond that as well
right so it's amazing to see how will
this composure and this experience lend
itself to Grand finals lubenheimer on
the other end still very new this is his
first top six experience and Evo but he
is handling this yeah like a future
Champion looking super comfortable super
calm right now but we'll play sitting
down ready to go in I don't know too but
uh you guys at home watching this stream
who do you like right give us your
prediction right there in the chat
twitch.tv evil I think it's up but how
about you guys in the crowd man I don't
know I can't even tell so how about this
you guys let us know who likes weapon to
take the whole thing Make some noise
all right all right that's the reaction
I like to hear now for the home
territory boy let's hear it who likes
newmanheimer
oh yeah
USA are we here the chance like we're
here with Tekken I don't know that was
quite the pop for neubenheimer right
here oh both of these players they land
those intros Rock we getting real
seasoned before we get into this Grand
finals yeah Focus what are you thinking
about right now you came for 2500 people
this is I just got to be one more just
gotta be one more you say trophy is mine
both rocking the black who Feud hurl is
it gonna be today
let's go
[Music]
now we have not seen this matchup yet
right we haven't seen nobody's had an
answer to him yet but yeah what team
never gonna bring that 11s oh man that's
the thing with having chaos right Aspen
at the distance combat as he is with the
Close Quarters
[Music]
mix up
try to beat the burst right there with
the curse but a little bit too close
yeah she left an immediate with the
micro Dash 2s right he knows that dude
was gonna try to press the advantage off
the first immediately cut it off ex
machina let's get the full advantage
here
yeah very very comfortable so far in his
first game right now for 11. perfect
first round working on a double perfect
right now BRC that's why I talked about
the is not over the mix is not
over if you saw the micro Dash before
the overhead off the fuzzy he really
made you think he was gonna go low that
was so cool double perfect in the first
game of Grand finals if you're left in
you have the winner side Advantage you
show you can just dominate right now
he's got to be feeling good just two
more just two more in the back with mine
exactly two games to go and left it I
mean that's gonna be two evil titles for
two different games that's rarified air
bro but Noob and army show me something
right show me something
right now moving Highway still trapped
in the score he's got his first
available is he gonna end up spinning in
this round we're back into the neutral
spice the Clone but the shots protect
any further damage nice job the second
hit yeah the SSS screen able to go
through the opponent hit laughing after
that super very nice new bernheimer
looking good Hammer still playing
coppolos he didn't automatically commit
to the second hit of Shizu or anything
like that still very much aware of the
optimal with 100 meter to work with
right now
[Applause]
likes to utilize after the sage change
and looked at him that was the Mamba
first phase yeah the Newman already hit
that burst Bud even before left and
drift away so nothing can do in that
situation
through that right
YRC okay yeah that's the thing is what
happened
he's Gonna Roll jump across and that was
nasty from 11. he did a really late shot
on the airbag that to kind of jail into
the end afterwards I see you I see you
left experience right happy gas is a
character he's playing his own game
right very unique set of uh skills nice
okay a little mistake from left arm into
the command grab another one I hit him
in a car crowd popping at the blood
fights as well but it doesn't matter
unless it's still looking for it that's
all right the first is out though I'm
gonna connect okay
Beyblade weapons in the air so it does
not connect
Ed
one person to wake up at the stop the
crashed it was kind of been you know the
the name of the game so far everyone is
guessing wrong when left is waking up
even though he's in a bad position his
reads are so on point he's taking
advantage and finally newmanheimer has
put the stop to the Amari right now
but no just follows up with that gunshot
a little scramble situation but again
that's that experience right leopard is
a veteran yeah in the scrambles is
already planning his next move good
recovery now 2-0 here can we talk about
it right when you look at his DNA when
it comes to fighting games and melee
that is what those games are built upon
the scrambles converting optimally from
them whether it be melee whether it be
Dragon Ball whether it be Marvel this is
what he does by now it is 200 one more
game and left will be your guild the
gears Drive Evo 23 champion
okay the yrc's right every wire she left
it does debating every time he wakes up
and match it connects his defense is so
good oh my goodness he was gonna delete
the rest of his life all right there but
left him so confident taking this 450
that's all he needed yep now last it
melt the 50 the fist pump is that he
knows one round away put it could it be
a shutout in Grand Final it is the cops
are nodding himself momentums on his
side I don't know
he feels very much in control right now
and when a player is so comfortable like
that it is so difficult to defeat them
fighting against very mental game right
100 he's got positive bones in real life
and that close is never gonna hurt him
yeah
anti-air close-ups right there my
goodness melting the light bar on the
weapons
chaos and likely it'll be irrelevant
that she is oh yeah I still respect a
little bit let's go to the closest
catches the season he didn't need to
commit to the second hit because the OTG
was there for the kill side he saw yes
I've been back dashing a lot so let's
see because he didn't have to start
reacting to that
triple back that straight some space get
the gun out yeah
right after the first bullet
so what you what if the guts are going
to keep him alive but this is it new
Panama whatever you got you got to bring
it out right now first okay you guys see
Beyblade in but don't wake up 5p check
from lepin he is undefeated your Evo
2023 Champion he did it he did it 100
this is two different evil titles in two
different fighting games like we talk
about rarified I Heir you're joining the
tokido you're just the Longs of the
world the goats of fighting games left
it putting his claim on that title
people try so hard to discredit them all
the time oh Tom he's not he's not a
guilty your play he's not at this player
he can't do it but the amount of work he
shows it every day he's streaming he's
traveling he's grinding he's improving
and here's the payoff but I'm so glad
you keep highlighting his work ethic
because there are not a lot of people in
fighting games that can come even close
to how hard this guy works he makes the
noise there for your champion leffen
definitely big off to Wombo William
right there he came so close last year
as you mentioned at third place finish
now a first place finish with an even
larger bracket the biggest Guilty Gear
bracket of all time left in is your
Champion I love it too right he had
happy cast last year just you know I'm
sticking with my character I believe in
myself I believe in my character no
changes and I pay it off and it was it
was it was pretty one-sided today was
weapons day that was uh left it in full
Prime form right though the lightning
was coming out of his eyes he was very
much in the zone and you can see nobody
was touching them today yeah and it was
a confidence too right so happy Casino
very very strong character but of course
you want to say oh he's a bit weak on
defenses I'm a reversal yeah was
pressing buttons and it's very risky in
this game but he knew when he knew when
he can Mash out very very confident make
those decisions exactly right we saw so
much confidence in the two P's the 5c
presses easily can get blown up for that
and as you mentioned if happy chaos gets
knocked down once that could be the
whole round and he just had so much
confidence in his defense right and
again it's predicated on his fighting
game DNA he's built the defense for a
character like happy chaos and you can
see it pay off right here this was not
only a case of him sticking with the
character but sticking with the
character that's right for him this is
definitely the kind of character that
will reward you putting as much time as
uh someone like leffen does I know I
think the Beyblade came out here yeah
he did such a good job picking his spots
with a shot as well right we saw the
hesitation even in previous sets letting
people FB their bar down before shooting
them like he's just calculated on every
angle yeah so this was the final the
final game here right nubenheimer was in
a tough spot he sold his burst he's got
meter he's got Beyblade you're never out
of the game with Beyblade but look at
this look 11 does 5p just wake up nope
I'm not afraid I'm gonna wake up I'm
gonna challenge you if that had not
worked out you know if new Diamond hit
him he might have lost the round yeah
he's not afraid that was great risk
reward calculations at that same time
though because all he needed was that
trade right so left it I mean he is a
genius of fighting games and it was on
display here big UPS can you all give it
up for Barracks here let me hear it one
more time I can't all the way from
Senegal first time in America first time
at Evo congrats to him big also 100 and
then coming from Japan yo y'all give it
up for tomorrow
smile I love it right yeah he's out here
got to show his style hopefully you see
him again next year
yeah definitely those stuff all around
here from all of or was it 2500 players
in the Guilty Gear stride back and for
Evo incredible stuff and of course
second place here give it up for
newmanheimer
the highest placing player from America
I like I like how everyone all the
regions showed up everybody did very
very well you know this is uh survives
anybody's game yeah man it's so great to
see like the competition on a worldwide
level yo y'all give it up for the
defending reigning Champion oh be sure
smiling hard for the crowds who's she
gonna play next yeah
I want to see if we show Johnny next
year yeah let me see oh one of the three
mystery DLCs oh one of the fan favorites
give it up for doruino
chronological man look at his jacket
though you got a jacket congratulations
oh yeah yeah
there it is the grand champion the
Guilty Gear stripe go give it up for
laughing delicious the laughing he did
it
I don't hear any more disrespect his
name that's the Evo champ right there
that is amazing bro the work ethic that
leffen has put into Guilty Gear strive
and fighting games in general
transitioning from Smash right he is the
true crossover talent and he cannot be
denied
so I just I can't believe this man I
have come from like like I said I've
been fighting games for a long time but
couldn't Evo for a long time as well to
see or guilty here Guilty Gear yeah
right here the biggest Tournament of all
time for Delgado across any version
right now on the big stage Paul lamp
winning got the golden stick two
beautiful sticks man I love that the
Golden Stick embroidered with the Guilty
Gear stride as well my man has done it
the job has been completed you can see
now at this point he looks like he just
wants to rest I mean he got the amount
of focus it takes to play stuff like
happy cows and also like to survive
against you know 2500 man bracket too
man the endurance is out of this world
all right and after again keep bringing
up that Pepe if you guys think of your
fans watch uh leftovers February
splashing yesterday like the fact that
he was able to go through that match
with his back to the wall coming all the
way over here and they'll win the whole
thing just is it's a testament to how
good of a player he is one of the
greatest sets to date in guilty gears
drive 100 man and all these players have
put in so much work with the characters
streaming constantly or grinding it now
constantly entering whatever tournaments
they can I applaud all of these players
here on top six and Beyond yeah and it's
been you know if you're Guilty Gear fan
you know the past like two or three
months kind of been a little bit quiet
right building up the Evo everyone's
just kind of getting ready but right
before where we had the announcement
season three is coming this month we
have new characters new system mechanics
so everybody have four new characters
throughout the year so I'm really
looking forward to seeing how guilty
your stride grows and you know we'll be
back here next year we definitely almost
done we definitely will it was so sick
right it was a pleasure to compensate
with you as well man we handled it be in
the house experience last year it's
great to bring it to the stream man and
the crowded General yo can y'all give it
up for Guilty Gear one more time please
and this is a game I never thought like
you said
you said it never thought we would see
it take it this far man 2500 bracket
Coleman events in the arena you couldn't
ask for a better top six yeah I just I
want to close I just want to say thank
you to everybody watching at home I know
there's tons of people watching
restreaming on the main Channel thank
you to everybody in the crowd your
energy has been ridiculous not just for
the players but for us commentators as
well so thank you guys make some noise
for yourself please
definitely make up support the energy
always helps us to power through that
top six man Big Ups to leffen crowding
himself the champion after a top eight
appearance last year but now we gotta
get to the main event but before we do
let's talk to our host for the evening
Aaron Ashley Simon take it away
honestly give it up for every single
person competitors attendees viewers
this is the best community
also want to give it up to Sony
Professionals for the cameras that they
gave us for today's broadcast without
them all the viewers would not be able
to experience the energy and amazing
competition today all right so you all
thought that we were potentially done
with announcements and some other stuff
well I'm gonna bring out Rick Meyer he
has some cool things to tell you all
about
uh we all don't
I need a mic that works there we go
how we all doing tonight
[Applause]
this feels pretty good doesn't it
so one of my favorite parts of last year
was standing on this stage talking about
the history of fighting games
and announcing one of the other places
that Evo likes to Host fighting game
tournaments
[Applause]
should we look at that again this year
let's give it a look
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
brand new venue
brand new event bracket format
which is actually the same one as this
one
but more important than all of that we
have a special guest tonight please
welcome rotozemen
all the way from Japan
[Applause]
is
Roto
Roto is one of the reasons we get to
host Evo Japan in Tokyo
so if everybody would like to join me in
Tokyo next year in April you also can
visit rotozemen
Roto z-man is very excited to be here
tonight
he's available for photos if anybody
would like to grab one with them
[Applause]
we're gonna have information about the
Evo Japan tournament list about more
activities on site at the event coming
soon in the meantime though we're gonna
do something tonight that we pretty much
never do at this show
we're gonna announce next year's show
you get an entire year to save for this
trip which means I would like to see all
of you that are here again many of you
that are at home
because you get a nice save the date
about it right now
we're moving back to July
a full summer of Evo
in two countries
we're coming back to Vegas because Vegas
has become one of the best places in the
world to host Evo's events they let us
all gather they let us play games at
hours that are not always reasonable and
they let some of us win money and some
of us not
I'm in the ladder Camp I know it feels
bad I'll see you at the crap stable
later to give it a shot
but
one of the great things about being in
Las Vegas is they appreciate that we
come here so I'd like everybody to put
your hands together for the Clark County
Commissioner tick second
Sega Blum I'm bad at names today I'm so
sorry
as he's going to come talk about Las
Vegas being here and Tom Tony Cannon are
you still here
Tom and Tony come up here with me
[Applause]
[Music]
all right tick come up here with me
Tom and Tony founded Evo if any of you
aren't aware
[Applause]
that's right you can be louder than that
though 20 years ago they made this
possible
and now tick is here to present them
with the key to the city
thank you so much on behalf of Park
County the sports capital of the world
we have the Super Bowl down the road we
have F1 up the road we have every other
sport but Evo is the most important
sport we have thank you so much
I'll agree with that
this is the key to this trip
no matter what else you want to do this
keeps you out of jail tonight so please
be careful
thank you so much dick
[Applause]
all right I'm gonna be very quick I lost
my voice from Guilty Gear and Tekken
um
from the behalf of the Nevada Esports
education League one of the biggest
non-profit here silver state government
relations and everyone here in Las Vegas
you touch the heart of Gamers here from
our heart to our controllers and to our
entire community
so I'd like to head it off to Sunny with
a word from the governor of Nevada
good evening everybody
just wanted to say a couple of words
first of all Governor is a big supporter
of e-games Esports especially Evo
congratulations to the cannon brothers
and Rick for anything that you've done
and for that effort because we are so
proud
the governor has given a proclamation
don't worry I'm not going to read all of
it I'm just going to read the last two
whereas by exceeding 20 000 participants
for this year Evo 2023 has set the
record for the largest evil
and Evo 2023 will be possibly be the
world record for most participants for a
single Esports competition
okay not only that
all right lastly
[Applause]
foreign
now therefore I Joe Lombardo governor of
the state of Nevada do hereby Proclaim
August 6 August 2023 Evo Day in Nevada
[Applause]
hi y'all
um
this is a wonderful surprise thank you
state of Nevada uh and the city of Las
Vegas uh you've always been great hosts
for us
um we are honored to accept these Awards
on the behalf of the whole Evo team
but really on behalf of all of us
because we are Evo
it takes all of us to make this event
thank you for coming
thank you guys
yeah thank you so much um for Tom and I
who have been doing this
um for over 25 years it really means so
much to see all of you every year it's
like a family reunion and uh I just
can't be happier that you're all with it
um with us together
um so yeah thank you very much thank all
you
all right
okay
we do have one more thing though
the fighting game Community this year
particularly has seen such incredible
growth across the world that it's almost
unfair to call it just one Community it
is hundreds of communities that truly
have developed a culture
and Eva wants to be a part of that
culture more regularly which means next
year you will see evil Japan you will
see vote right back here in Las Vegas
and then you will see e Evo somewhere
brand new
[Applause]
this isn't an announcement of an
announcement
but
Street Fighter 6 is coming up next
thank you everyone
we have our street fighter six top six
as well as other few surprises coming up
soon don't go anywhere
[Applause]
your Chipotle order just got extra
fighter coins from Street Fighter
using promo code hdkn 236 and received
250 fire coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
new hunting ground Creighton wants a
hunt I've given one he'll never forget
better take him out before they find the
lizard
gunship won't quit I do not want to be
lizard food
PlayStation
Red Bull gives you wings
oh no
super Rollo
feels good
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this summer PlayStation held online
tournaments for thousands of players
competing for an all-expenses paid trip
to Evo 2023
see how 12 players from PlayStation
tournaments fgc arcade road to Evo
fought their way to compete with the
best of the best at Evo
starting with the North America region
for Tekken 7 Joey Fury took down last
year's PlayStation tournaments fgc
arcade summer Community Series winner
Joe Crush in straight sets to claim his
spot at Evo Las Vegas enjoy daxif on
casting down for that might be enough
yes we're right to the balcony here it
is
Joey Fury your road to Evo Champion here
at PlayStation terms congratulations
Joey Fury was joined at Evo by kirakira
winner of the Europe region devil boo
winner of the Middle East region
and casuke in the Asian Pacific region
in the Europe region for Guilty Gear
strive tigerpot made his presence known
with a decisive defeat of jet stream
tiger Puck with their own gold first but
it's not gonna land and Jet stream's
gonna be able to essentially reset here
and keep the corner uh but you have to
be careful you can't let tiger pop get
out of it
you have it that's the hard part right
what's the what's the gun comes out how
do you not let happy cast get out he
just exudes it there's the close last
that's gonna finish it up and tiger pop
is going to Evo off the road to Evo care
package
tiger pup was joined in Evo by daru
representing Asia Pacific
and bean from North America
k-top topped all comers in the mk11 road
to Evo tournament including his twin
brother H dope in the quarterfinals and
routes to his eventual tournament
Victory oh no that's the game that's the
game and that is gonna be k-top taking
the tournament and the hospitality
package for Evo 2023 that my friend is
all yours well done
k-top was accompanied by agamoto's eye
from Latin America
after finishing second in Dragon Ball
fighters in the 2022 PlayStation
tournament summer Community series and
missing out on the evil Hospitality
package gropas would not be denied in
this instant Dragon Ball Fighters
classic
groupies
no more you don't have to go for
anything difficult right now simple here
we go into level one groupie Stakes to
win ladies and gentlemen after losing
the grand finals last year and narrowly
missing out on a big flight to Evo
gropis confirms his win and will get a
flight and hotel to Evo 2023
and our final two PlayStation
tournaments fgc arcade road to Evo
Champion's hail from the Asia Pacific
region Korean wrestling man claimed
victory in the melty blood type Lumina
road to Evo tournament
and the undeniable dominance of M
conquered the King of Fighters 15 road
to Evo tournament
congratulations to our PlayStation
tournaments fgc arcade road to Evo 2023
champions
these players faced Unforgettable
moments during Evo 2023 and will
continue on their journey in the fgc
subscribe to the PlayStation Esports
channel for more fgc content and learn
how you can compete and earn prizes in
PlayStation tournaments
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
is
baby
[Music]
foreign
that Sizzle that's the soundtrack of
Chipotle the soundtrack of Chipotle yeah
you come in you're gonna be hearing that
Sizzle that's how you know we always
have fresh food
fresh is what you stand for that's
exactly
[Music]
oh no
super Rolo
Victory feels good
[Music]
foreign
Pro Tour is now open over 2 million
dollars is on the line for the season
with the first place prize of one
million dollars to the Capcom cup 10
Champion winners of the online and
offline Premiere events will also Auto
qualify for a spot at Capcom cup 10.
open to all players in good standing so
check out capcomprotour.com for
scheduling and to find a qualifying
tournament in your area
thank you
[Music]
foreign
championship series one of the best evos
ever
here
what happened
they can't hear me
[Music]
all right all right as Aaron said Not
only was this one of the best evos I
just heard this was one of the best
Esports events in history
and because of that I mean we got to
celebrate this moment
oh the mics it's cut hold on
here we go do we gotta do Aaron check
check
[Applause]
I guess we're gonna share right which is
good all right Aaron you good I don't
know everybody good
whoa so we gotta share you know what
there's mishaps that happen all the time
but we need to celebrate this beautiful
moment of making history do y'all want
to take a photo with us
all right
let's go three two one
[Applause]
can you guys hear me now yeah
all right thank you guys very much for
that picture and sharing this moment
with Aaron and I but
you guys better stand back up because
who is ready for some Street Fighter six
God I love it listen the hype is real
but hold on we gotta wait we have a
special guest we need to bring out the
man the myth the legend the voice of
Street Fighter 6 this is yes
[Applause]
y'all have no idea how humbled and
honored I am to be before the fighting
game Community here at evolution 2023.
[Applause]
when I saw those entrance numbers I was
going absolutely Bonkers and I'm sure
each and every one of you have as well
we've had over 7
000 competitors filling out this Arena
even from all over other games but
you're here tonight for some Street
Fighter six I want to give it up to you
one more time Make some noise for some
Street Fighter six
before we get into our top six I know
it's getting very intense back there all
the players getting themselves primed
and ready but I do have a couple of
special announcements and some very
special guests
I have a team that has traveled all the
way from Osaka Japan
[Music]
they are the Capcom sound design team
that have formed the in-house super
group the super band
cap jams
[Music]
I have them here tonight on stage ready
to perform and they've got something
real special for you all right they've
got a couple of songs to play for you
but I need some participation for the
crowd as well I need you to take a real
good listen as to some of the songs that
are about to play because we have
something upcoming
in a big collaboration for the battle
Hub and world tour mode
so without further ado
get ready to take a listen it's cap jams
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
they're Heroes
[Music]
twitter.com
what's up
[Music]
boys
awesome
[Music]
music
[Applause]
[Music]
he makes me
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about let's go
you saw it here first it's going to be
available this Tuesday for all you die
hard fans out there from Capcom
to the fans out here
this is their love letter to you don't
ever forget it
now
for the moment you've all been waiting
for
day in day out these guys have been
competing their hearts out
to this very moment to become
top six competitors
but we're looking to see who's gonna be
the champion
that'll be put into Capcom cup from this
qualified evil
so ladies and gentlemen I need your help
to bring out all of the competition one
more time Make some noise for your top
six Street Fighter six players
enjoy the show ladies and gentlemen
oh
[Music]
I forgot my bad
I forgot
we got one more present from you from
Captain
let's take a look
[Applause]
which one of these was the herbal
medicine again
[Applause]
oh yeah this one
probably
[Music]
now
[Applause]
airplane
they are
no
[Applause]
some poisons can kill people in the
thousands without amount
like body line and toxic it inhibits a
subtle calling police causing loss of
muscle tone lethargy
dizziness
visual impairment
oh
[Music]
heavy Island intense thirst loss of
speech vomiting diarrhea stomach
is breathing difficulties
respiratory failure
[Music]
man oh man has been revealed after
reveal announcement after announcement
and more importantly this audience has
been taking care of us especially with
our Mike situation
[Applause]
for the last time
let's see the intro video
[Applause]
[Music]
you already know what it is
about to cash out everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm too risky
[Music]
you already know what it is
alive
but for me
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
come back
all right let's keep
all right let's keep this energy High no
no sound
Mike
all right you guys hear me you with me
Mandalay Bay you guys hear me now
let's keep this energy up we're about to
bring out our top six First Street
Fighter six
and first up please come out to the
stage
foreign
[Applause]
let's make some noise for
Angry Birds
[Applause]
one of the five Gods hi Tony
and now the god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Make some noise
foreign
[Applause]
and we got one more of the five Gods
Make some noise for our last competitor
all right this is it one more time Make
some noise for your top six Street
Fighter six Evo 2023 finalists
[Music]
all right now I'm gonna send this up to
my boys on commentary give it up for
sajan nifc
everybody to Evolution
2023 our final top six of the evening
sageam joined by IFC ice and boy I would
just like to say it's nice to be back
welcome everybody hopefully you've been
enjoying the action all weekend we have
our top six competitors and it's gonna
be a bloodbath out there 7 5
people competing in this and all of them
now in the stands making a lot of noise
as we narrow it down to our first Street
Fighter 6 Champion here at Evo and
before I even get to the gameplay look I
know I've been hearing everybody show
love to Evo man shout out to Evo Day
first and foremost but I need everybody
in the building to say fgc fgc
fgc
[Applause]
and I gotta say they started singing
that TMNT real quick people picked it up
they're like wait a minute is that
turtles that was kind of crazy I'm here
listen to it you know I'm bopping it's
cool and then I was like wait a darn
minute in there there you go that's a
cool ass announcement yeah that was
pretty good I gotta say Aki does not
seem like a nice person I'll tell you
that also she seems I saw a lot of
people down there already like I could
fix her no you can't don't do it don't
even try it's not worth it yeah I won't
talk to her on the first date for sure
yeah that's 100 don't recommend it you
can do better all right everybody well
hopefully you've been enjoying all the
action all weekend me and you've been
vibing hanging out checking all the
games and everything has been fantastic
we're gonna be taking a look at our
bracket in a minute here checking out
all the action and again this is the
first Capcom Cup qualifier event one of
the three offline events that this tour
will have yeah man and look already we
already had some familiar faces you know
I was I was kind of hoping for the dark
courses but hey I'm not complaining
these guys are killers we're gonna have
a good show we got cockro versus Angry
Bird
these guys have been just stepping their
game before I actually did not know that
our Cockapoo was the artist formerly
known as yeah he was a Ryu player in the
last game and everybody was like dude
this guy is so good how does he do it in
this game picked a good character and
look at him he's in Winter side top six
of Eva which is very impressive Angry
Bird I'm really happy to see here too as
you mentioned right like you know a lot
of shine gets put on Big Bird all the
time obviously red vocal Potato Champion
they play round one at Rebel Kumite I
think if it had been a different bracket
right and instead we had seen Angry Bird
win I think he could have won the
tournament too is that good on the other
side and punk obviously I know that a
lot of people are focusing on haitani
he's the modern gamer here the yes uh
interesting one to watch right he's been
the Terminator walking people down all
weekend one button reactions looking
very impressive up against Punk who has
not lost the game yet in this tournament
think about that he went through 7 000
men and he made it here to top six
without losing the game
yeah now the thing that uh well I'm a
little upset is because there's so much
that we was doing at Evo I did not get
to see not one match from Punk all I
keep hearing on social media that he's
just watching Everybody hasn't dropped
the game yet so I'm pretty uh hype about
that one of course men are the men are
really Dominican de la Mio is in the
building yo let me hear my Dominicans
real quick you out there
oh I see the section back there I see
him right there I see them okay yo that
jacket the bull yeah we saw we were like
what is this yeah and then tokido you
know the interesting thing about this
bracket right is that when people talk
about Street Fighter V three of the
players they talk about us like some of
the best to ever played that game were
Mana pong tokido all three of them in
this top six all coming full circle man
and it's crazy because you know
everybody's so familiar with each other
we've seen Punk and tokido which should
be fighter five you know what I mean men
are D of course making history with two
Capcom Cup championships so I'm excited
man I'm excited for this top six guys
are you ready to get this go own
it is time I am ready I cannot wait to
see all the action here this weekend and
I gotta say you know all day long this
place has been packed it's been a while
the crowd has been going absurd and I
see the characters already up there on
the EVO stage behind us I'm ready to see
all this juicy action we have here top
six of the tournament so far it's gonna
be a good one and it's gonna be our
first time having this game here and I'm
sure of many years I just can't wait to
get the first match going do we even
have our players setting up okay button
checks and all that is cool so we're
just going to sit down and play right
yeah
right but uh no we had a point in the
game where like everybody's getting
comfortable we're getting familiar with
the matchups people are actually trying
uh are starting to react to drive impact
past 3 A.M you know yeah so exactly
everybody's starting to get comfortable
look at this right here the young God
kakaru was such a great defensive Style
with JP like you know there's a lot of
differences with JPS like you know you
got the ones that got the good flow
chart in terms of the projectile game
spikes the Shadows but then you have
those JPS where they Panic once they get
into that low forward ring he just uses
all his options from the air throws
he'll never overextend and he'll always
fighting proper footsies to stay on to
stay on his feet yeah he actually has
footage he can play neutral in the
mid-range with JP which is impressive
and Angry Bird too you know fun fact
about these two they got back from
Kumite and on 200 Ms online cockadoo is
running matches with Angry Bird and big
brother he's like yo you're trying to
play You're trying to game and like both
of them were like yeah I'll play I don't
care what the connection is I'm trying
to get the best experience possible he
had been streaming for 12 hours and
angry bird and big bird could pop up in
the chat they're like yo you trying to
play no complaints huh and he was like
I'll play you right now 200 Ms I've been
playing the game for 12 hours straight I
need all the training I can get and here
he is in top six of Evo that's crazy
well now it's uh no lag obviously at all
yeah no Ms no Ms yes yes so we're uh
cutting that ethernet cord and we're
gonna get this live man who the hell is
going to win the first ever Street
Fighter 6 tournament you know I'm
looking at it like me and say jam we
just gazing into the screen we're like
yo man this really is the first ever you
know Street Fighter 6 obviously right
but this is going to not only like
really pave the way on who is the killer
games like officially going into the
next tournament right but just a new
wave of play is that this is going to
inspire right here is going to be
fantastic and I cannot wait yeah I mean
I've been sure a lot of people right a
lot of the people in this very venue
maybe weren't even watching or
interested in fighting games before the
pandemic and then now this brand new
game comes out right it's real shiny a
lot of new players are here for Street
Fighter six this is one of those games
where you know it's going to define a
new generation of players right and
somebody who's at home watching this
right now might be an EVO next year the
year after Etc geez that's a lot of
buttons that is yo bro everybody has 27
buttons on their arcade sticks what is
going on what are they you don't even
know what they all do I'm sure all right
there's no I bet you if you ask them
he's like I don't know this one's
probably driving fact I guess yeah yeah
but water comes out of it yeah when I
hit this one it's Nitro it's going to be
fantastic and we in Vegas so right round
number one y'all open the game and make
them nice
we go all offense right away angry bird
I think is one of the most aggressive
players I can think of in almost any
game yeah and and Ken complements that
aggressive style very well already with
the amnes I'm trying to forget that that
was a throw Loop in the corner
oh nice confirmed ready on that Spike
and he's gonna set up the od1 recovers a
little faster so you get the setup here
that was pretty smart for manually sorry
dated uh to escape matched on the back
dash landed and Perry just doesn't just
uh alleviate some of that pressure to
hold the igloo button where are you
going good sir this is a closeout let's
Cash Out do we need a spin ball no we
don't
nice and easy side swab Dragon latch
sure you can round one Angry Bird
looking great there and you know even
though his offense may not work he's
never just waited he's like he gets up
and he starts fighting right away he's
hitting buttons he's parrying he's
backlashing he never sits still lovely
usage of the standing short okay good
Perry looking for that perfect Berry no
dice though so it's all good you are not
holding up forward my friend that was a
good check on the jump oh yeah and Ken's
jab is so good it goes so far really
really good for keeping you locked down
nice we almost got to confirm that that
drive Rush was sneaky spends the level
three he's gonna beat up the drive gauge
here for Angry Birds so he's almost
burnt out already now shocked that's
understanding me the key go for standing
so he probably didn't notice it was a
counter here but that was in the past
it's the president
it is time for the parkour tour no we're
gonna dance forward I like that the
overhead on counter the combo
drive heavy in the corner early is there
a counter or not wow that was me
um
we need some electrolytes wow we faded
out the very good oh that was ridiculous
head Fireball we're going to the next
game ladies and gentlemen Angry Birds
game number one the awareness was Unreal
he knew it he's like oh I'm gonna go in
a burnout might as well just throws it
runs in run DP level three confirmed
damn he's good he's good oh there's good
they're real good it's real good shots
might be at that pretty sure he's
watching right now in his uh in his
boxes he might be yelling as we speak
oh yeah I love both Digger combos five
pieces that lead into Okies works for me
throw Loop cereal
oh it should be on the jack and he
caught him with that real bad clock
though but perfect for Angry Bird here
can he be stopped that's the question
right like he's one of those players if
you cancel him down he'll run you over
in three minutes you know that was a
beautiful shimmy day from Angry Bird
he's on one
respect to throw the Tumbleweed
yeah it's been like that for 20 years
nice move all the way the U-Haul but I'm
talking about here holding that Perry
and I like the shallow Spike from
cockadoo there trying not to give him
any extra Drive Gage
oh
okay oh that was the funnest way to
happen getting a little too aggressive
Dragon Lance of course looking for that
throw Tech no dice I like the counter
poke there from cockatoo yeah he's
willing to swing I think which is a good
sign that his defense is feeling a
little sharp he's not just gonna let you
get away with it nice stuff on the
driver oh
easy peasy pickup right there punish
counter on that gets the OD after we
gotta round a piece after that first
round was kind of a Beatdown yup we're
looking for that one knock down I
haven't seen like a sweet Throne yet
from either players that's how you know
they trying to really hold down a uh
Health ball
he's fishing for that Perry nice he's
got the meter to spend here I imagine
we'll see the level three yeah this kind
of fixes the drive gauge so every time
you spin a level three you gain about
two bricks and your opponent loses about
freaking a half two bricks though it's
really good nice exchange for you oh the
ex the ex bikes won't have to take that
good good awareness yeah you want to set
the situation a little bit before we uh
want to cash out
no Fireball game at all we're not even
trying to like risk it huh oh good block
on the overhead Angry Bird is condition
him he's trying to hit him with the
overhead level three hundred percent man
then that's what's up the the Run Stop
too just go low stuff like that start
the condition up a little bit more no
check there that's big Angry Bird has a
chance he can win a one good hit that's
why the throw is real scary here that
was so me I like the Walk of the Michael
Walkers to get the perfect one perfect
on the actor back to frame open a big
drop right there that was the round and
now instead full screen burnt out
against JP it's gonna be tipped on yeah
it's a raptor I've got so much cash
he was playing shmups yeah did you see
the minion was beating him down while he
was doing the level one he's like yeah
it's over pack it up buddy boy that's a
drop and that's gonna hurt angry bird
there should have been 2-0 instead we
see one apiece that was a big drop
absolutely and you know he's done that
combo a million times so you know man
that big stage pressure man oh yeah even
the best players he's been in Capcom Cup
finals you saw nine that Evo damn that
was so media on the heavy kick all from
a sweep
probably reading the throw at the right
time oh yeah and then next time I wonder
if he'll try Harry to beat the strike
you know what I mean just mix it up a
bit I'll just come back and just do
Dragon Land short you can but that's
just me let me stop being a backseater
here backseat gamer and streamer do this
we'll jump away from the pressure
doesn't want to see that throw or not
man he is winning the mid-range so well
so far cockatoo he's been fighting
uh he's baiting out these parries too
trying to get that drive gauge load of
the confirm level one
feel the deal very nice goes up ahead in
the set yeah I want to highlight that
man he's like staggering his pressure
that way he could uh Force Angry Birds
to burn the drive gauge early yeah I
mean you mentioned it yesterday right
JP's win condition is run out yup really
wants to put you in Burnout so the lower
your drive gauges the harder it is to
win against this character you heard the
pop on that I heard that I think the
whole crowd agrees that was close
they block you always I see you nice
I think it was in range off the counter
you can get standing short into a Shore
you could with can
no throws okay so I'm sorry I spoke too
soon Captain tight for a second though
right that Crossing jab punishes the
throw with Corner pressure Angry Birds
so smart choice that he's counter
political in the Jack usually a lot of
people counterpart with no forward right
I can stand in fear yeah
another stuff on the drivers there cocky
was doing a pretty good job snapping out
that crashing medium yeah
not walking back over here uh-huh no
Texas tornado we're going straight into
the general
one more hit I'll do it Knocking thing
there's the bait and it's enough no
meter span round a piece game a piece
for these Gamers we'll see what's gonna
happen here wow I like the Run Stop you
mentioned earlier the overhead a lot
right now he's looking low yeah still
laying it too for the counter hits
oh I like that yes Chuck the plasma the
outside suit
gotta wear them down oh
spends the bar big damage on this too
and puts you in a really bad spot the
igloo button connects the whole family
could live there all right here we go
what's next
Fireball game are we just worried about
the level three we are trying to play
Optimum here Angry Birds
I like the Angry Bird back off a little
bit though he didn't want to press too
much in the corner risk getting hit by
that uh Perry which is a smart choice
nice punish and I'm just gonna confirmed
level three on this yeah Miss baseball
he had the right idea but just a little
too close yeah oh man that hurts uh
we're even Steven's here I think right
pretty close anyway pretty close well
most from the drive games right yeah
early Perry
oh wow when he Dash under I like that he
recognized he was going over and he just
went for the uh drive to get right under
ah my favorite string jab go low jab
sure you can oh did not block the over
there wasn't ready for a combo I'm
pretty sure was surprised that even
landed to be honest with you exactly and
I love that awareness from Angry Bird he
saw him set the portal that portal takes
for a hammers because drivers hits the
Jabs you like you like that Ken Masters
up there yes I do I do
reminds me you know it fits you well
Angry Bird I ain't gonna lie you saw
that there was two cans on top six and
you were so happy oh yeah man listen I'm
very kosher when it comes to the uh
world of Street Fighter in general right
it just brings me back home man from the
laundromats of the bodegas I just can't
I just could never forget that
oh good check on the drivers ain't got a
combo wow the awareness right there to
know the portal was there was really
good from cockatoo because you know he's
grinding he's ready for it oh Target
combos big button starters I agree turn
that butter keep them honest oh had the
hand didn't believe a lot of pressure oh
a nice whip punish on that that's really
good awareness good damage not enough
but really good spot yeah Angry Bird
gotta start checking them more and then
walking them down with a low forward
because what Kaku is doing is every
street he's just walking back little by
little inch and away so he could get
those types of foot punishes exactly
yeah angry bird chase him down with the
driver's side I got him big damage on
that oh he backed after he tried to bait
it didn't work out and now in Burnout
but he keeps oh the pressure chip so
scary yeah it's beautiful the right
Spike for the occasion that was the
right Spike the land mine
oh well it is the igloo born I need more
that oh yeah clean jump in from that low
forward range
try to hold up forward yeah I kept it
tight exactly yeah we got hit on the
ground there with no counter hit
probably trying to jump
okay good punish yeah just take the
corner and get the positioning and
scales from perfect Ferry oh is that the
first yeah
in the arena the first D.I
in there oh that's a big one here he is
in CA range I think he might this is
enough I think this might kill survey
says will it be on the show we'll have
to find out but he's in the yellow I
think slow
oh no man huge damage on that our first
set of this pop sticks two a piece the
rematch so fast we barely saw their
faces frame one I like it thank you
Capcom thank you for it that's true
all right we are optimizing we're still
looking a little uh healthy in the drive
game so we setting up like oh my God
that's the setup over that you can do a
gym rise too but it depends on how you
hit him on the jump in but that was
crazy man that was mad high too weird
spot he was in the air so caught him
angry bird down on Drive gate and
there's a whip punish to lower it even
more because of the punish counter nice
nice bro yeah good Awareness on the
ferry do it again just do it again oh we
held up over the time but good cross cut
ow too far at the counter and wins level
two please yes Optimizer you gotta make
sure every time I see that super all I
hear is let's go Dustin
[Applause]
every time it's that boy here for Angry
Bird
Chuck the plasma I like that range on
the plasma Chuck it right there don't
listen to us
backseat gaming
so scared of the Jumpman it's just so
much on the line right to make that one
mistake yeah it's been really good oh
it's gonna reach no I didn't so dry
fresh for the punish yeah see the
ballerina toe so elegant
a little early this is a good spot now
yeah delayed pressure he was scared of
the ex reversal right there nice Santa
yeah yes oh and the whip Shadow just to
try to burn out a drive Perry in case
you try to do it
portal set up and there's the throw to
combo offset oh no maybe the police in
the timing oh open the counter hit
double sub tougher combo proper sequence
even get this knocks down you try to
hold up for it again he's getting opened
up are we gonna do it again got rid of
this ground just to get the cross up
maybe an empty low yeah and I think he
was looking for the empty low exactly
what a driver's confirmed maybe level
two on that so last game last round
between these two in our first set of
Evo top six out of the range the portal
wasn't there Andrew Bird was shot that
even even pressed the button there
give me that we at that range we was
just talking about that that's what kind
of nullified JP's game plan overall oh
he was waiting for that one and then the
up back on wake up delayed throw Angry
Bird trying to bait something out maybe
looking for that counter harassing in
the middle of the screen and the Perry
was perfect
like that from Angry Birds use the
Fireballs the Poke people don't realize
you can use it as a zoning tool but it's
really best used as a boat yeah exactly
nicely done and this will be a number
three
that's what we would have done oh yeah
get that bar back cockadoo big lead now
but Angry Bird full resources he'll be
below enough Health to have CA here as
well that's why you see the yellow on
the light bar oh he's out oh trying to
cast it inside with a delayed Brown
House there you have ladies and
gentlemen this is one of my favorite Cas
my mama loves this one let's go
let's back
okay burnout all right now this is great
great opportunity right here for Angry
Bird to make something happen dry rush
off the gate
no stop Dragon Last get it close to the
corner he's got no meter for the driver
oh
[Applause]
and just like that Angry Bird books his
ticket into the winners finals after a
scary little drop but he cleans it up in
the end that was winner so he is going
to sit comfortably in the winners final
that was a great way to start the day
here for Evo 2023 for the end of night
was a start streak you know what I'm
saying part of our day the start of our
day there you go that's what I was
thinking ah my God yeah man this is this
is excellent but this is what makes it
even scarier right who got what it takes
to take it to Angry Bird now I can be
biased here and I just want to see you
know the lore match with Angry Bird and
punk but Punk is gonna have to earn it
right he is yeah and I mean he hasn't
dropped the game so far we'll see if
that starts here in our top six win our
side nicely done there from Angry Bird
damn that was a nail biter that was a
good match man a lot of adaptation you
know again uh that match up specifically
JP and Kenya get in that low forward
range no real shot battles are going to
be thrown out there unless of course you
got the spike in the air to set up some
pressure just to alleviate some of that
worry right but that's how you shut them
down a little bit you know but in
kakaru's case he's just so good at
covering all options I've seen I think
he's like the JP that gets the most
aircrafts from what I've seen oh yeah
definitely and he's his crouching medium
punch uses really good too he snaps that
button down and just finds so much
success with it so I love watching him
play I think if you're looking for a JP
player you know obviously he's a great
example of someone who's really complete
right he's good at everything basically
so I want to watch of course and that's
why he's in this so we uh we're gonna
take a look at the bracket here in a
second and back at some of the
highlights of that match and it was
close like you know it could have gone
either way I think okay let's see some
highlights though of uh this fancy
footwork from both of our players here
yeah there's a lot of clean play in this
one I mean it was it was really back and
forth It's kind of what if I I expected
from both of them yeah that was so
ridiculous Angry Bird I think no one has
like better situation situational
awareness with this character than him
right he's just so ready for everything
he gets the point when you want to get
aggro if we're going to use cash to get
in there and stay in there you might as
well and he did it in a situation where
he knew he was going to get burned out
anyway so like you said great
situational awareness
the scramble at the end he had the meter
and then just the trade not there soon
enough Angry Bird obviously feeling very
good about that and again you know a lot
of people there's a lot of shine on Big
Bird for his great performance at Kumite
which is awesome of course but I think
shine equally deserved on Angry Bird for
how impressive he's been playing our
next match we'll get is the high tonic
Punk match which is I I can't wait to
watch this it's like you know Punk will
used to joke like he kind of was Modern
by himself right like he doesn't even
need modern controls right and he's just
that clean he reacts to everything he
confirms everything and then haitani one
of the Gods playing Modern Chun Li in
top six looking like a machine so he's
been really really fun to watch that
sense of our loses match cockadoo versus
tokido is our first loses match that we
have down there set up so it's gonna be
a good one of course okay well guys uh I
think it's safe to say we're going to oh
no this after this match right
yeah I think so actually that's a good
question yeah so we're gonna have all
these uh matches coming up for you
Gamers hopefully you've been enjoying it
so far that was a good nail biter to see
it I love that there was only one drive
impact that was like not when there was
a stun there was like one regular Drive
Impact he didn't react so don't feel bad
if you don't react at home happens to
everybody they don't want to play uh
filthy but I promise you it's going to
get later and later in the night where
people are start are going to start not
reacting to it but yes we are going to
throw it to a quick break go grab a
snack go grab some drinks we'll be right
back with some more top six action right
here in the arena Evo 2023 when we
return
[Music]
[Applause]
using promo code hdkn 236 and received
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
buy something
oh no
super Rola
thank you
Victory feels good
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to Evolution 2023
hope you've been enjoying all of the
action and all of our top sixes so far
we got one match of Street Fighter 6 so
far which has been nice of course
hopefully everybody's been enjoying it
we're gonna take a look at the bracket
again in case you missed it since we
went over it right over the break but
you know maybe you just tuned in you're
like I heard the matches are wild here
we go we got high Tawny versus Punk we
were talking about that's gonna be our
next match should be a good one meta is
going to be playing the loser of this
match I don't know so that'll be a
gnarly one I don't either way that's
gonna be a juicy one down there and then
cockadoo of course up against Taquito
our first losers match that is settled
and we know what's going to be going on
down there so lots of really talented
players of course in this bracket and
this next match there's a lot to talk
about of course we're gonna be getting
into that in just a minute here yo dude
let me tell you something the fact that
of course it's a run back from what
happened on on Saturday they played a
first to ten right uh Mena won 10-6 yes
so you would think you know you play
somebody in the law and say you're
saying to yourself probably ain't gonna
bump into this dude right but it's Mana
he's the bull he don't really care he's
a killer yeah but the fact that they're
going to play when it really matters the
most but that is of course if uh pump
loses I mean Puck wins yeah exactly
which we'll have to see in this match
right I mean that's one I'm so
interested in this matchup there's so
much to talk about for it and of course
we're going to be having our
introductions for the the lovely Gamers
that are coming up these are the two
here seven evos versus haitani's Eleven
by the way and of course yeah you see
that best result Punk that's second
place in Evo 2017 up against tokido one
of the most uh famous or inFAMOUS
depending on who you're rooting for
finals I think an EVO very very uh Wild
Side great story there yeah pretty
throwback too man to be honest with you
hi tiny of course with the Makoto I like
when he always switches his Styles yeah
it's a bit of a weirdo in a good way
though the last time I see these guys
play was um like a dream hacker a while
back but it was Street Fighter five that
was literally the first time I seen him
playing like man look at the old school
versus new school you know what I'm
saying so it's pretty dope to see him
play in this freshman game we call
Street Fighter six yeah definitely and
for us we've been talking a little bit
about them we're gonna head down to the
stage for the cap jam band introduction
alongside Long Island Joe
foreign
all right everyone let's get ready for
this next match are we ready
[Applause]
please help me bring out hi Tony
[Music]
[Applause]
and his opponents
foreign
[Music]
clear
ance
[Music]
listen give it up a cap jams one more
time y'all
that's fire
these guys are fine I appreciate some
good music I'll be in the booth a lot so
I would love to uh experience that when
I whenever I have a chance but
let's get to the nitty-gritty
we already passed the curtain call with
the first match this match right here is
pretty spicy I mean
these guys that kill is high tiny of
course Making Waves with the modern
Chung leave everybody's like man what
the hell is this you know I thought High
Tony was an old school head you know I'm
saying we're supposed to be classic out
here but no
show the way that's what I love about
this everybody talks about modern and
they're like yeah this like 15 year old
guy who doesn't even know a street
fighter is going to use modern and I
love that it's the old school legend the
god of Japanese fighting games who shows
up and is playing Modern here and he's
like the damn Terminator if you watch
his matches he walks at you and he's
like what you gonna do I'm in a one
button reaction to everything you do
it's terrifying and then the other side
there's Punk right who obviously is in
the running for the best player of all
time in Street Fighter 5 and then has
had some close calls on this very stage
second place at Evo back in 2017 and you
know he is the modern person on classic
right his reaction time decision making
the snappiness of his play is something
we've been talking about for forever so
is there someone that can stop the
modern gaming from haitani will it be
Punk right or is he just gonna Cruise
right in against Angry Bird in this
Winner's finals we'll have to see well
good news is he has Cami so you don't
got to worry about throwing too much out
there where you have to we could react
with the with a level three although the
spinning knuckle is punishable but we're
gonna see that story told here
Oh yeah and when there's no meter for hi
Tony this is when he is the least
dangerous right like this is where you
know jumping and trying to approach him
is the best because he doesn't have
super counter he confirms standing jab
for chunley is such a ridiculous button
and punish counter you get crush and the
handshake the standing strong yup shake
my hand the knot down
about the thing about this game right CA
very important of course just feed him
in general right but that's why you see
a lot of strings and offenses because it
does build the C8 bar pretty fast oh
yeah he built meter really quick in this
game you build about two bars per round
or so so you usually always have level
three by round two and uh yeah hi Tony
using the air legs immediately damn I
bet I think I definitely attack
everybody in the building Texas
I respect that what a privileged
reversal you're out the corner every
time it lands yeah they're really good
it is really really strong every time
you get it oh throw back into the corner
honey drive good yeah I was just gonna
say a little low so if he burns out but
he has to run by the super so oh
now he was looking at the toes he was
looking at the toes the whole time nah
bro he snapped it outside shake my hand
shake my hand you know what I want to
cook when you see her confirmed that
good you're starting to think man did he
just commit or do you actually confirm
but it doesn't matter you got the job
done oh no ah spider almost hit the wall
but we out of there good job
trying to Parry man drive games really
low here for high Tony
oh okay can't do it this is a modern
gamer I'll take that back you can't
react to a lot of stuff oh yeah come on
you see that three ass little uh side
swap under there from itani on the super
oh for the chance here there's no Drive
cage so he's gonna Loop him and there's
an interrupt great match of knowledge
you can hit a button there but yeah yeah
no cash to really make some count oh
yeah no meter nothing you can do about
that drivers confirm pump cleans it up
round a piece let's go look at this
young man
is so dangerous with meter here right
because modern allows you to do supers
so snap reaction you don't have to do an
input so without that meter he's much
less scary yep
oh looking for that with punishments
trying to set it up try to play a good
old-fashioned game of hot hands that's
the high level footsies man who's gonna
press the button first exactly yeah
hunk's so Snappy with his reaction from
the flip punishes there so the air Lakes
again it's really good especially it
beats throw right so if your opponent
starts to throw you get punish counter
and you can combo off of it
are we gonna reset no we're gonna spend
that cash designate that ass I respect
that I want the burnout oh yeah but you
have to be careful right because you
cancel driving Fighters for free so Punk
instead I think we'll take safer
pressure here that's the jump in faked
out the Dodge yeah
that is huge this should be the cleanup
A1 goes the pump
come on
[Applause]
come on hi Tony not on stage
he is the outfit oh yeah that was cheat
code
throw looking for it yeah trying to
snipe it and his defense held up so far
but punk I don't think anybody's better
than doing strike throw than him he is
just so good huh Snappy choice on the
jab yeah really good really good that
condition of you to detect the throw or
take it to be honest oh yeah
lightning legs no knock down unless it's
heavy so oh he baited it wow that was so
smart for my Tony yeah it was pretty
good nice wake up crafty medium kick
level one and try to get the kill here
finish not enough but chip burned out
though oh what a back that just to avoid
block stuff by any kind but we got it
Punk is he looks kind of clean yeah yeah
I must admit you know and he's just so
capable to play any character as well so
but I love this pig
yeah definitely I think candy fits them
perfectly she's a character that's
extremely well-rounded she's good at
like everything but she there's nothing
that she has that's so like oh my gosh
she can't like that you know what I mean
she's just wow
we're looking for our car keys it
between the cushions yep oh my God hi
Tony is spacing man's been trying to
make it happen oh almost made it over
that fireball too not quite could have
been air legs there I feel like no
ground ex likes could have got the
conversion
oh wow I'm trying to walk all the way in
double drivers confirmed
nice little pick up there for mytani
who's fully loaded with meter by the way
dive kicks anything you want to do he's
going to be on the level two or level
three and on reaction yep which means
when I have to keep it honest all the
way through unless of course he spends
that cash
shake my hand please we looking for that
counter hit oh those Drive gauges are
healthy stuff that's wrong head oh yeah
I need to see blocks done please
that low forward plus the walk speed
it's like you could check somebody
walking back every single time oh nice I
love that negative frames there so he
just goes for the uh air legs beats the
throw really smart
all right we are going to save those two
bars in case Buck want to get frisky
with the dive kicks
everybody wins don't worry it's not just
you
it's not you it's us it's us yeah it's
all of us man next step for Bunker kill
here he's got level three and tons of
Drive gauge
when he got the hit I thought he was
checking in the yellow level three easy
peasy two games for Punk and he has not
dropped the game yet this evil
[Applause]
what the hell
all right here we go the car
looking happy out here see when you have
a healthy mentality I feel like it could
take you a lot of places yeah and like I
feel like that's how he was he was the
best player in Street Fighter 5. he had
that attitude all the time he was
confident feeling good healthy you know
yeah good mindset knock knock okay man
you know I'm seeing a lot of people
holding up forward but I feel like in
that case he was trying to go uh air
legs finally on the hard read on the
throw and man he's done air like so much
and look Punk just threw him like five
times he was just like yeah I don't care
I'll still do it why wake up dive kick
and there's the punish for my Tony yeah
I can't believe it DP pump around away
from cleaning this up 3-0 yeah
yeah
I would love to see this uh stretch but
you know we can just move forward along
with this I like my ass
he let it rip first the eye of the set
and it works out for Punk stop holding
up man
he is not trying to be there yet he's
trying to air legs trying to get out
right like he doesn't want to deal with
it and Punk's pressure is so
overwhelming haitani on his last legs
here that is true though I can't I can't
play him High Times
mmm
[Music]
but with much to work with of course the
pump just want to throw random spin
Knuckles we can't get up on it
yeah oh and the one button right into it
here this is huge Titania's driving is
Gonna Come Back first and pumps his
stall
oh my God so we're gonna get a lot of
block strings just to buy sometimes we
can have access
[Applause]
that is I think like the second round
he's lost his Evo so far or something
like that zero games dropped and he is
in winners finals of Evo yeah that's
crazy you know what I'll have to look at
The Archives of uh you know his his uh
Road in the bracket and obviously all
over the place and we can't catch it but
the fact that I'm hearing that that he
hasn't dropped the game yet that is uh
pretty pretty good good if you ask me so
I can't even say he has a chip on his
shoulder he has something to prove he's
playing the game because he's a
competitor and he's having fun and
that's all that meant yeah exactly and I
mean it's funny yeah you see him in in
like events all time during the week
he's just playing on online matches
streaming and stuff just hanging out
like oh yeah wouldn't it be funny if I
use hooligan and like he's just goofing
around and then this is how good he is
Punk to God well advances forward going
up against Angry Bird but we still gonna
have to go to the losers side of the
bracket I'm going to look at a couple of
highlights before we go and check the
bracket here I ain't gonna lie I thought
hey Tony last game he was going to pull
through with it but Punk is just that
type of boy where he just won't put his
uh put himself in danger unnecessarily
unless of course he wants to take that
risk or come back but if he knows he has
to Pace of the match in that momentum
he's going to walk you down so that's
the name of the game when you play that
man Victor Woodley yeah I mean I don't
think anybody else is better at like
just walking up and being like I'm gonna
throw her now what's up like he you know
years and years of doing that with Karen
like nobody else is better at
conditioning people than him I think
with that style of gameplay you know
what I mean yeah it's kind of cool that
it it's Punk and Angry Bird because they
like really good friends but they troll
each other competitively but they have
so much respect for each other so this
is going to be a good match but up next
though is that nice are we going no no
we're gonna think we're gonna I imagine
we'll go downstairs to the uh cockadoo
versus tokido match right so that
haitani has I don't know four minutes
before he's gonna play again or
something you know after just losing on
the same there one of the effects of not
having uh as many players in this
bracket you got to play real quick here
if you lose so you got to turn around
extra quick this Evo if you lose that
match up in winners you got to play real
fast hey man listen man shout outs to uh
Evo because I like the little things to
be honest and true and I like a lot of
sports so uh can we get the tail of the
tape I just want to see how the
introductions look for tokido we're
probably gonna see the murder face the
classic the patented uh oh not even he
actually got a smile on his face you
know what I like that it suits him well
he always looks pissed off wow do you
see this number of total appearances for
Evo down there wow that is a wild number
19. I'm guessing it's Evo Japan as well
included yeah so that that is a lot so
many years 19 years in a game 19
different hairstyles 19 different arcade
sticks this man has been in the game for
a while he's he's personally in my Mount
Rushmore so it's good it's great to see
that uh he's still in the mix of things
showing these young kids what it's all
about in kakuru of course four years
that he's been here for four businesses
well he was playing Street Fighter five
a lot so it does make sense oh yeah and
man it's wild to think that tokido's
been around that long coming here all
the way over to the US and then
obviously competing in Eve of Japan as
well 19 performances and look at that
Evo 2017 we talked a lot about that he
played punk in those finals which was uh
really really fascinating to watch it
was a fun one I'm sure a lot of you
remember all the great moments from that
so I'm excited to watch these two play
of course we're gonna head down for our
introductions it's pretty cool that they
get their own song every time they walk
out to the stage like well you got a
personal band following you around
that's pretty good I gotta say I was
about to say once I heard the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles I thought we could
just like request like old school uh
Cartoon music but that wasn't the case
that was a big surprise well let's throw
it over to cat James and Ella Joe of
course for the introduction he's taking
away my boys
all right everybody let's welcome back
to the stage talking
[Music]
[Applause]
and now back on the stage
[Music]
everything
that's pretty good
I'm very impressed I'm not gonna lie you
know if I was like a gazillionaire every
song they play well you know at the end
of the concert I'll just tell them to
break everything in the back just like
smash all the guitars smash everything
yo it's so ill
bam just yeah that'd be sick just do
like an elbow drop on the piano that's
it yeah just take it out that'd be that
would be sick you need a lot of money
for that though seriously
oh man what you just all you got to do
is one Capcom cup bro you get the
million you if you just win Evo win the
Milli then you can smash as many
instruments as you want
no shot you know things I'm gonna be
online watching and Bodega again imagine
your Capcom Cup champion just that's
gonna be me I believe in I believed in
what you said yo but man look at the
Asian don't raise no no the Asian don't
raise it shout out to James Shannon put
me on to that uh to that term a while
back still young yeah how is tokido look
so good does somebody fall oh my God I
was scared man yeah I was like what
happened to the camera
let's get a barrel roll he's like it's
time My ultimate move barrel rolls with
a big camera imagine to the front I got
it because the that's the how you get
the best angle of tokido right bust out
the tape measure do a barrel roll
I got it
hope that didn't bother y'all no I think
they love it I think the more you Vibe
the better the commentary is Imo
I am a firm believer of that actually
that's what happened yesterday yeah we
were having a great time up here making
noises oh man they didn't tell us about
that
was the crowd going yeah yeah
[Applause]
no I can't hate
here we go JP versus Ken saw this match
if he just played it against Angry Bird
right and I think his answer looks
really really clean the difference I
think is tokido you know he doesn't like
white as aggro as Angry Bird right he's
not as aggressive as the player
generally I think
I'll tell you this he looks a little
fast they're walking on the left right
left right too I don't know what I'm
talking about I'm right there with you a
button for every occasion oh aggressive
already with the igloo Bunch trying to
score that punish counter for the big
damage
yep that's that range of the fireball
use it as a poke I love it
now like I said uh yesterday when we see
tokido's matches I was like tokido's
more of a freestyle cat even though I
feel like he has all the right setups
yeah but like he'll do like a sure you
can at the like General UK it could be
like a medium puncher appears he's just
gonna go for roll but yeah but again
there's a lot of visual cues that you
get a media overhead yeah he just picked
this character up right he was playing
Luke at the very beginning of the game
Pride modern try classic then went over
to Ken immediately oh I like it he tried
to drive us into the dragon lash pick up
there cockadoo nice spot here oh it's
gonna hit yeah and he gets the pick up
the awareness to block the cross up and
then knows like oh the Portal's gonna
hit him cool I'll get a combo yeah that
was amazing he banked hard on the car on
the tops we probably thought it was
gonna hit naturally right right the
defense these guys are both uh typing
papers they're right in their papers
yeah
oh big jump right over
okay oh yeah pick them out caught that
Perry bait nicely done all right gets a
little pickup on that takes a bit out of
the drive to gauge from tokido as well
uh-huh back to the schmuck meta
now man got a full screen overhead wow
you've not seen it before but I never
thought I would have seen an industry I
played a lot of interest games and I was
like oh I'm right at home huh time to
die
oh was it in range for the standing
short for short count ahead medium kick
it does work out that way but we gotta
be closer
Batman cockatoo is holding the space so
well look he's not getting walked back
in fact he's walking tokido down even
though he's supposed to be the zoner
right
he said yeah he's saying aunts in
Spanish when he kicks you in the angles
oh spend that cash I loved it the Texas
tornado
how do you get ducked in the stomach
then the chest and then the chin that's
crazy
unnecessary a little three piece all the
way up that heat is one of the coolest
level threes I think yeah I love seeing
it oh the fake we trying to fade out the
drive Perry yeah looking for it doesn't
find it nice stuff oh he missed I think
it was supposed to be crouching heavy
and he got down down heavy the spike
instead
yeah his like confirms are really scary
too you can just check check check all
day look below that time so keto strings
him up I like it that's good yeah I get
the burnout
oh it's gonna be tough are we in there
yeah don't give him too much space I
like that Dash and Wise Choice from
tokido yeah even though he's burnt out
he can still fight right so you gotta
come to the distance so he doesn't have
any super meters so yeah that's one
correct
the breakdown oh you're holding it up
all right you're holding forward
sneaking in the overhead watch the
ankles nice air throw we was just
highlighting that and you called that
out earlier level two is there a Perry
from tokido there is a Perry jump I like
that didn't take much damage at all for
that level too
oh that was cheeky I like it a lot I
could do sneaky in the driving pack oh
and he's gonna go back
[Applause]
for the natural reaction you're like oh
Drive Impact I gotta drive this bike
back and you just don't have the life
yeah see certain instances uh if you
know you're low on the drive gauge you
just instead of driving impacts just go
for the pair you'll build it up and if
you have an option as it builds up you
can drive reversal in the midst of the
animation of the drive there yeah
exactly
double jab no it's just the one okay you
want to save the bar I see him yeah yeah
at least they're too easy a little
pickup on the wall again right
good positioning too yeah he is he's
keeping it tight right he doesn't want
to deal with the uh the counter right so
he's not going for as much throw
good check on the shimmy attempt
cockadoo just trying to buy some time oh
the Tumbleweed the barrel roll that's a
barrel roll
I'll take it
not enough but driving is getting a
little low for tokido as well oh I like
that to lay down forced to burnout right
into the drive impact and he has a super
right there he's gonna take all the
damage a sweep for the timing
here's for the kill very nicely done
it looked like a light starter too
wasn't it huh yeah big damage better now
makes sense
all right we're thinking about it
tokidos having a bit of a tough time man
he has the right idea but it's just not
quite finishing the job
yeah I like the Outback who's been doing
that a lot block up back try to get out
of there he's been trying to jump away
nice Angie just far antier on that
really good spacing he's from the space
exactly oh we're in trouble I drive Gage
is suffering tokidos gonna have to do
something to get out the corner ex top
so he's just gonna push himself out man
sounds like a bull whip
cracks him and right after that you're
gonna be burnt out too so this is a
really bad spot
wow that sucks he just pulls up on you
he really did say well like that well
well have your game ggs you're dead well
you know what I love about tokido's
competitive experience man that this
dude like he'll put a smile on his face
like man that was good I got something
for you oh yeah he definitely is a true
competitor he's not going to be up here
like oh man you got me he's just he's
fighting for it right trying to fight
for every inch oh eyes on the prize
indeed kid oh yeah
the category five oh man another throw
way more throw in his offense this time
oh the perfect Perry he knew
into the corner bad time now jump over
Spike's still on the screen so he
defends behind he just back that just to
use that as a little bit of a shield
okay standing out of the range of that
Spike okay successful Landing a lot of
throws on driving test barriers excuse
me nice way to switch sides miss the
combo though that's a Twitter combo yeah
he's trying to hit him with the fade
away at the end I like the idea double
Drive pick up there for cockatoo they're
both a little low on Drive gauge
on the spike with the work for him he
didn't have to do anything like a real
bad guy but the drop
lose their friends he went for the
challenge a bigger cockatoo will back up
just to heal up a little bit Drive Ferry
a bit but no one of the stay there
challenge look for that whip on us I was
gonna say you know that situation too is
such a Checkmate he's in Burnout I
thought it's either gonna be level one
super or he's gonna get chipped right so
pretty rough spot yeah true true I
concur
anti-airs he spaced it out last time
pretty good but good chance with the
keto yeah I like that he didn't empty
jump this time because if he empty jump
you probably just would have got smoked
into the corner really took you to here
stopped again yeah he knows not letting
him get away with that anti-air looks
clean every single time we try to Parry
the follow-up on the Gin Rye very common
response you block the general that you
try to perfect create the low I love
when he gets fits in the corners like
are you gonna jump are you really gonna
push yourself out the natural way yeah
oh yeah speaking of which you're over
here let me go
second level three
three speed up and tokido he wants him
to spend the level three back right if
you lose this round but he's fan that's
fine oh no it's time to take the
impression a little bit gonna have to
make some executive decisions random
amnesian five strings let me see
no good question ourselves out oh good
punish give me some dab give me some
love
could have had to hit the kill there he
just didn't want to drive from us again
that rip the drive impact same thing in
the first game there if cockatoo wasn't
ready with the super he had the Parry or
something like that otherwise he would
have died if he died back
you know
I know a lot of people hate Canada in
this building everybody knows that that
drive impact is coming it's just wind
yeah and he just goes foolish and he
smokes you and you're like dude how was
I supposed to know a two-in-one that's a
spinal yeah
it's a 26 frame move that's what they
call it you know 26 frame man just hit
the buttons back
smiling like oh yeah I should have
reacted yeah you got me imagine that
drive impact for the million or for the
Evo Championship right like that could
be the Difference Maker right there yeah
sleep before eight o'clock yes most
definitely I'm not trying to play this
game tired
like the uses of the genre kicks from
tokido using the medium kick one main
one so frame trap if you try to press
the button between you need a reversal
yeah exactly and then he could just use
the low or no follow-up right maybe
catch you trying to Parry waste that
drive gauge gonna throw
a little bit dangerous but it's like one
of those situations where okay I'll
yield I have no choice let me find that
opening off of this offense
oh that's what happens one drive Rush
you're a little late man his perfect
Parish been doing it so consistently and
cockatoo's been doing a good job
fighting for in this middle of the
screen I feel like he's been winning
this a lot and then tokido opens up a
driver up dragon last jump something
like that and he makes his way in
really the important Tools in this match
have caught the jump there with the
Pierce and now walking him down not a
combo but
good damage on that jumps away
nice stuff he could have dry brush one
more time to get the kill but now it's
okay with a Chance damn Kick The Shins
on the way in check the shoes never has
creases I can't believe that
I like that idea oh one of the first
ones we've seen actually I kind of like
the idea mates the throw doesn't get the
pickup but it's a good idea for cockatoo
I like that oh so I like to see you
gotta make sure that his defense is
correct
I like it so you know hammering away
with that heavy gun doesn't find it it's
gonna be burnt out here for sukito are
very close with the level three
yeah I agree that's a burnout right or a
picture no that should be a burnout
let's see
oh close now we're gonna have to think
about it look trying to avoid it by any
means necessary but didn't make contact
with the drive Perry very unfortunate oh
now this spot is so bad as you mentioned
this is the win condition for JP right
he wants you and burnout so that he can
do this kind of stuff whole quick
soquito finds his way in he's got full
meter aren't available
to make it here in the first place I
will not let it happen
well to be fair I think tokido should
have sniped a little more in terms of
collecting data because uh about nine
out of 10 times playing Angry Bird he
blocked that overhead right right and
you know you're right 10 players let it
rip they just do it I promise I never
lied to you yeah yeah yeah I'll do it
yeah I did it all right do it again
see ya my aunt
and he really does say that I hear it
yeah
I like more Fireballs something we
didn't see as much in the Angry Bird
match right so keto you know he's played
Shadows for a long time really heavy on
the fireball game compared to some other
Ken players nice little drivers right
under into the DP
that's how you know he's Snappy right
his reactions are on point wow that's
ridiculous gotta open too but good
defense though yeah even managed to
fight this mid-range so well there's a
lot of crouching medium kicks heading
out the portals baiting yeah that's like
the first time he's done it the whole
set how could you ready for it that was
a pretty sneaky way to do it too I can't
even blame him yeah and then Perry right
into the reversal not that common so oh
man he is doing such a good job yeah he
is beating him up here in the mid-range
now he doesn't have Drive gauge so he
can't even really Parry although he can
pair now so he does coming back a little
bit at this point I feel like
see in those situations I've seen a lot
of players do it if they know they're
gonna lose at least just try to string
them up as much as possible to build as
much uh super CA bars and that way you
know you need to get to drive against
back you get some offense going so it's
definitely here for cockatoos to
eliminate tokido former evil champion
see if we can keep up the pressure nice
jab into the medium right after caught
him hitting a butt
sets up the portal and it's there so he
has to respect you see Tokyo backing off
the defense
gonna crack an impression the whip
crouching medium kick right into the
crotchy medium punch after the caught
tokido flinching trying to do something
on the whiff soquito smells blood that
drive gauge is low on through the
side so he's trying to look for it just
trying to move in there make something
happen don't want it with nothing
straight silage nothing yeah he's oh man
he is clean and neutral right now he's
not giving away anything for free
although the burnout's big now tokido
has a chance if you can make it in we'll
have to see
just because he burns out doesn't mean
he doesn't have these great projectiles
and buttons oh he actually jumped and
he's seen the drive game sticking with a
fireball oh
whatever you do mad damage antokido's in
Burnout it's pretty close oh my God this
is tough look and he's pennies healthy
on the drive Gage this is gonna be Club
this might be over tokido can you get in
here and finish the job
critical art damage on this sit down and
shut up
oh and look at cockatoo's face man he is
going through here that was his round he
knows it and now it's the last round
between these two tokido you know he's
feeling good I cannot believe you
brought that back you know had that face
like he's running he's running low on
Steam oh yeah now you gotta guess is it
counter time or not trying to hold up
rip the drive
sure are you on that Topeka with the
pressure
oh it was too early lots of drops now
cockatoo feeling it but the stuff puts
himself in Burnout but important to slow
things down
yo I'm forgetting I'm confident I'm so
sorry guys this is too good
um
trying to slow things down so keto he's
gonna try to close it out
zero on block too try gaze back now he
can fight in the mid-range with the OD
ghost and he brings one out so Tito's
got it this is very close now this is a
very winnable round for cockatoo and the
level cooler reaction is that gonna work
he parries and he gets the promise he
dashes in oh the overhead
[Applause]
oh my God you know I should have played
more Schmucks before I came over here
huh man so he's beating himself up he
was so close but tokido was ready he was
like I should have known you know that
situation was probably not looking at
the bar right right yeah but such a
smart choice from tokido he churned that
butter and everybody's on their feet for
tokido this is a household name 100 part
of Mount Rushmore of the fgc on the
competition side but cockadoodledo man
we not we can't take nothing away from
me you had an excellent show guys a
round of applause for cockatoo y'all
what a step between those two and that
was just our first losers man
that was the first one cockadoo I have
to say like watching that I'm sure
everybody in this building is so
impressed with cockadoo too right he is
so this guy is unreal he's so good and
like after watching that all I can think
is like man I can't wait to see him at
the next tournament oh my God bro that
was very clutch for tokido now yeah was
already a Roundup so you think I'm about
setting the losers in a pixel in Burnout
just found a way to get into jumping in
those ranges or the anti-airs with and
he just got a an opening just to get his
offense started so yeah that was wild I
mean you know how it feels everybody
who's ever played him in burnt out
against JP you're like oh my God I'm
dead like it's such a bad spot so
impressive play and finding those little
spots and not panicking to get in there
is really difficult tokido how many of
these clutch scenarios have we seen them
in right like that set against Judo and
all these other matches it's it's unreal
how he manages to uh you know clean
these games out it's yeah look at I mean
look at his health right it's a
miserable spot to be there's like no way
he should win this round right his odds
are are just Dreadful but he found a way
here with these General kicks gets the
burnout walk back there was so good you
know you know he's looking for the throw
I've seen what happened here that's why
he was harassing with the general I
didn't notice God crew that it had no
bar and of course the burnout right so
going for the franchise switching it up
for the overhead of the low that was
crazy and and here this is when it got a
little bit tense dude I did not even
know you could do that the level 2 on
rack action like this he goes with the
overhead reset here and the spike didn't
hit him oh man that is brutal the worst
part two is if he had done a projectile
like a ghost right there it would have
stopped the level one right so he just
went for the Kane Spin and instead it
just wasn't fast enough to get the drop
down invincibility so keto cleans it up
what a set dude that was ridiculous you
know it's all part of the plan at this
point yeah I feel like the universe is
just throwing it out there and say you
know what tokido I'ma just throw you
with Mo yeah here it is now in the loser
semifinal awaiting the winner of Minna
Rd and haitani I want to see the lore
match you already know what I'm talking
about I do I want to see it too I'm very
interested in this you know tokido has
history with a lot of the people in this
this time stick it's so seriously look
again uh when before this top six was
even you know set I thought there was
going to be more Dark Horses you know
people that we don't really see the the
not the household names right with a
splash of some of the ogs or the new
guys that we learn uh to know in Street
Fighter 5 in multiple fighting games but
man this is a good do you agree my
beautiful people
hell yeah it's been a great time so far
these matches are unreal and we have so
many more to go right like that was just
the first losers match hi Tony versus
Mana is going to be our next one of
course uh yeah it's looking juicy out
there we are of course going to go to a
very short break we'll be back with the
top six action here for Street Fighter
six in just a little bit
foreign
store is fire on every level fresh
chicken hot off the grill a rich
marinade of seared Merida peppers and
ground achiode balanced with a splash of
pineapple all combined for the right
amount of heat Chipotle's all new
Chicken al pastor is where fire meets
flavor
[Music]
don't kill me
oh no
super roll up
Victory feels good
morning
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen
tomorrow's Street Fighter 6 Action here
live at Evo 2023
we got some fire magic can y'all make
some noise one more time let me know
that y'all alive and well out here in
Las Vegas
good good absolutely and we're gonna go
and check out the bracket real quick for
those that just missed out maybe get
just tuned in but a lot that's going on
but we got one more match before we lock
in the official top four of the
tournament yeah hi Tony versus Mena of
course this is gonna be a juicy one
right here I finally I think it was
Unstoppable until he ran into the only
person looking more Unstoppable and Funk
so far obviously played extremely well
in that 3-0 set so far in this
tournament a game rather and then Mena
who you know he made it in the loser
side here I think a lot of people's
favorite to do really well in this
tournament I think a lot of people ask
for sure they expected him in top six of
the tournament and I think to a lot of
people meta was the favorite right so
it's gonna be interesting to watch it
off against titani in this and I'm
curious what character he goes with you
know obviously you mentioned the rerun
here these two played alongside and Luca
Blanca always is the question for him I
think he's excellent with both
characters yeah I mean it's all about
style checks right I usually see I'd say
if it's a really really good uh Ken
we're gonna see the loop depending on
the level of like a guy or something
yeah you probably see the look too yeah
I'm saying but yeah Mena's just that
talented that you just have he just has
that many options to you know figure it
out yeah and he's somebody who played a
bunch of characters in five too right
like especially the hit uh birdie with
the Mena patch they're like all right my
bad you're winning too much we gotta
Nerf your character so you know they
were like you won and they're like nope
are bad we got to get rid of this
character they couldn't allow Mena to uh
beat everybody up Evo appearances
between these two six and eleven and men
are actually surprised I didn't realize
when he tweeted this yesterday he was
happy when he made top eight right
because he's like I've never you know I
wanted an EVO top eight you know if I
make top six and I'm at the arena that's
great but I'm just happy I got this far
obviously now in the top six and playing
against yeah he's like he could scratch
that off the bucket list now like okay I
finally did it you know not to say that
he's gonna relax but yeah man hi Tani
one of the one of the Gods of a a Japan
fighting games you know what I'm saying
we've been knowing this guy for a while
I've known him on the Makoto side so but
just to see him still here aging well
and just still being here for the spirit
of competition and us on the microphone
man yo y'all cool with us on the mic
right
I just want to make sure yeah I just
want to make sure it's nice to be back
it is good to be back yeah I'll tell you
for the both of us it's been a while but
of course all these lovely intros so far
have been awesome and this will be us
going down to Li Joe who will be taking
it away with the cap jam band bringing
in our last walkout for our players
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
that was pretty cool the techniques
that's how you know you put out great
music as a video game Studio when you
have an in-house band yeah man they're
like all right let's let's Flex a little
bit let's play some of our Tunes but
yeah we have our match here between
these two haitani and Mena and you know
the one thing about Mena is very few
people grind like this dude right not
only here but he used to fly out and he
still does he flies out to places like
Japan and stuff and it's like yo I'm
gonna be out here for two weeks who's
trying to play so a lot of the Japanese
players when I see them at tournaments
and they see Mena they're like excited
to see him they're like hey what's up
because you know they've seen him in
Japan and training and stuff and I think
a lot of people really appreciate that
he's one of the people who is like I
will travel the world and try to get
strong yeah he's he's not faking Jax not
one bit man you know there's a lot of
people that play casually you know play
tournaments and stuff like that but when
you have somebody with that much hunger
that wants to send to the next level
you're gonna have to do what it you're
gonna have to have what it takes and
you're gonna have to do what you got to
do to get to that level you know what I
mean and Mena is a perfect portrait of
what we're talking about right now yeah
and he's a two-time champ and you guys
couldn't see it but when he came out hi
Tony had a big smile on his face to get
him hit him with a fist bump excited to
play him
yeah this is crazy so again that that's
why it's so risky to play long sets with
uh players and certain things in this
case for people that don't know in the
end zone Booth they played a first
attention they're not one 10-6 but again
that's a long set this is tournament
setting let's see how we do in a three
out of five though
that's my that's my dude right there
server shout out to Alex wherever he is
Deuce deuce
shake my hand the walk-up blocks yeah
big thing about this matchup too is Luke
has big gorilla buttons against Huntley
on the ground he is really good against
counter poking a lot of characters in
this game including Sean even though her
buttons are some of the best in the game
that is a down down gamer and on this
one button beautiful punish there for
Mena and his offense is so smothering in
this game I think very few people are as
good as him at just running you over
with one kind of sequence yep he's good
at really forcing you to walk back to
huh oh yeah yeah so we'll flip the legs
short nice conversion that was nice big
damage awesome oh my God that combo was
so clean everything about it driver's
jab and then Crossing heavy is punished
counter only by the way and not only
that Dash level two right there is a
very tight link and he hit it that was
clean that's punish counter only on his
counter only punish counter only
confirmed the driver's job oh nice oh
man that was so dude his pressure is so
good Lucas yeah damn he's good the
turnstile Drive reverse so oh we've seen
the Swiss cheese it wasn't solid there
was a lot of gaps a lot of holes there
on the offense of Minnesota that's all
right knowing that drive gauge so it's a
bit dangerous the handshake he's just
taking all the hits he's with it with
the scramble yeah he's trying to get out
he doesn't want to get burnt out his
Drive games are so low he said I'd
rather get hit than blocked
um
nice counter folk I like that my turn no
your turn my turn yup name of the game
hit yeah the double legs combo that
gives you a safe jump after so I like
that from my tiny
the throw he was all in on that right he
puts himself in Burnout which is a
pretty scary spot but with modern you
can reaction Super is the eye a little
bit easier so it's not as bad yo that is
so gang so yo credit Savannah I ain't
gonna lie he got uh OG Tendencies my man
got no headphones on stop it I know he's
playing in this loud arena with nothing
a little drop there for men on so he's
backing off trying to get away he wanted
his Drive games to come back I Tony with
the chase down
we are not trying to go into that
burnout the sentry gun
dude
man here again in this arena is wild now
there's no meter oh I like it yeah it's
a decent attempt especially the OD
version is really good when your
opponents run out oh that's a huge base
man I gotta dump some of this meter
missed the perfect knuckle
he doesn't get the completion again that
was supposed to be level one oh my God
man a lot of drops men are definitely
feeling a little bit weird about that
one those jab Jabs into the uppercut
whip that was level one super I dab dab
Fireball a level one super I see okay
you're about to get hit with that
Crayola Rock snow we out of the corner
oh and a big ant here too yeah I like
that Loop for a minute but I finally
found the right spot to jump out Harry
not a perfect timing so takes that plus
one oh wow so surprise drive impact I
know man it's like okay notice oh yeah
you know he's gonna be ready for it next
time
I like it throwing the shallow sandblast
so you can bait out the Perry and get
your drive Keys down all right Tommy's
just trying to get out of this
aggressive pressure about to go to
burnout so we're going to counter poke
back I'm pretty sure we have access to
that exam blast
no perfect knuckle yeah so he doesn't
get the completion on that
when he waits it out Mena being a little
bit more patience and then he explodes
oh my God barely missed
ice and he found that crouching medium
punch very very good that's the one
thing about men and I think it's so good
he can really be super patient and then
suddenly boom all offense all offense I
like that's all I like to call him the
bull Lee no no yeah yeah you're right I
mean and that's one thing that's so hard
to stop about I love these driver
reversals on drivers by the way every
time he does it he's willing to take it
yeah not gonna be a completion there
all right at least you get closer and
closer to the corner raw throat yeah
condition them early first I like that
when people go over instead of take
throws it kind of makes it obvious and
you're giving them my opportunity to
walk back from the throw yeah exactly
interesting there men are trying to use
the air flash here but didn't get the
punish after
[Music]
they're beautiful jump timing for my
time
another day on the job I like I like my
Tiny's facial expressions oh nice he
says I'm minus why don't you throw me
air like pizza and he gets a combo oh
and he lets it rip
man not ready
oh we're getting oppressed here trying
to hold up forward just to get out of
this situation here you're absolutely
right that's what he's probably trying
to do again maybe looking for it and
haikani keeping that offense nice and
tight level one he just built it in the
air beautiful meter management there for
my Tony Izzy time lit up one of these
yeah you know what that thing happened
there I think he tried to actually DP or
try to read like The Empty jump low or
every jump grab into the throw I think
it's all right yeah because a lot of
people try to perfect Parry whenever you
do a safe job so yeah empty jump throw
is pretty common
trying to make something happen in
neutral and then what's funny is he
throws all these fireballs and then he
just goes driver's job right he
surprises you he jump scares you with it
come on overhead put the nail on the
train please on the train tracks
I like how you matched up yeah I just
said that out of nowhere oh
gotta add quick says Chung Lee High Tony
the owner prowl he is getting his Maul
on place he did get the punish but I
like that attempt for a minute he's
really good at using air flash knuckle
like that the perfect this time goes for
the heavy knuckle after beats the throw
he does that all the time that's
something that he's really really known
for let's spend the level one in another
Bay and he gets the DP that was so clean
from Mena it's like the more he plays
the more comfortable he gets high tonic
gonna have to slow this this man down
immediately oh yeah and I thought he
even had a little smile like all right
you got me love it man that's the loot
combo aka the Kurt Hennings reactions
oh watch your legs try to jump out no no
no that's the patented Luke right there
all right condition no shampoo I see a
lot of dandruff on Chung Lee's head
on the Buns yep right on the Buns
he jumped the throw really good there
from Mena perfect level three time to go
to work taking them straight to Memphis
you thought I was gonna let one rip I
wasn't ready
I was not too wonderful
yeah man that's that that's the that's
the safe word yes
the legend damn that reaction was Snappy
he was ready
no reactions yeah it's hard when you're
letting go up Harry trying to do di is
really difficult
number one no just 10 show kicks no kill
oh this is dangerous wait a minute
maybe not
oh chance he could have DP'd but instead
trying to get the Okie
yeah man I'm trying to force the corner
here
oh no one was stuck though he just
barely got the driveways back Mena could
win and one more good hit oh God that
was scary
such a big problem can he avoid it and
they come back
[Applause]
oh
the suppressor right there no one heard
the shot yeah that is just depressing
[Music]
Angels put them in the dirt put them in
the dirt sand angels round for men a
genius choice right there on that back
heavy punch through evade that was
ridiculous yeah it was like the perfect
attack it was the universe told them to
do it
nice right through yeah
but then I didn't even try
you know what Loki I'm pretty sure what
high key man it's telling to himself you
know what that was worth it oh yeah
I finally despite a really rough you
know loss in the last round it looks
great here yeah keep the pressure tight
lightning legs again heavy 10 show after
whip that back medium punch set up there
oh turnout that was a gift from the gods
the back throw no uh huh that is the
bodega special proud Fizz holla oh is it
the life he finds the counter hitter
beautiful confirmed from meta what it
does it here whether it's low regular
hit anti-air again in the corner doesn't
let the drive-in pipe rip puts himself
in front of level one confirmed it's
enough and he eliminated titani from the
bracket the modern Menace sent home
uh-huh
give it up give it up that was a fire
match of course the ball banned its own
Mena Rd moves forward but please give it
up for one of the goat goats for real hi
Daddy
but yo this one thing I want to
highlight hopefully the folks back on
and Mothership will put it up there for
us but notice how men I was doing
crouching fish the whole time yeah it
was off the strength that he didn't want
to risk doing a rising upper and then
hitani doing a air leg so that way he'll
go right under so he's just keeping it
solid all the way through with a
crouching beer you are so right that is
a good call out right there yeah
crouching heavy punch was so smart and
you know what's funny is he did the same
thing to haitani in Reverse he was
jumping using the air flash knuckle to
go past the the 10 show kicks that's a
really smart choice for Mena and a
really good caller from you actually
noticing that too yeah crouching heavy
punch is very smart there yeah man that
was uh pretty close we might see that on
the highlights who knows at the end of
the day I just want to be reminded that
men Rd is really that dude he is really
that dude you look up that dude in the
dictionary and there he is he's just
right there smiling got the bull jacket
on that back heavy punch right there
that's what Set It Off I feel like that
was when the Snowball Effect started
kicking in yeah that's what's up for the
suppressor you know what's funny as a
loot player I've been trying to find a
lot of uses for that move and I found a
lot and I watched that and I was like
you're so much better than me like I I
was like astounded by how intelligent
that was from Mena that was so smart and
yeah right here you know he puts himself
in Burnout right so he extends with the
drive rush you know it doesn't work out
for him using the evasiveness yeah with
the driver reversal using the
evasiveness of the back heavy punch here
is so smart look at this oh my God man a
stop and he just does level two and look
at how much damage that did
yeah he is so cool with this game man
that was really smart and in this
position too the crashing heavy punches
here you're so right yeah he's trying to
you know make sure he doesn't get hit by
the air legs beautiful call out from
Mena and really smart to think of that
during the match you know yeah he was
very worried he just wanted to do the
the low like low risk High reward in
this case of course keep that corner
pressure that was so nice for men RT
credit to the man yeah and that's the
level one he missed a couple of those
level ones in like the first game I
think and it didn't dissuade him he
right there he just said boom boom light
light super all right he's just good set
and he's like yep I'm good I don't have
to worry about it so look at our match
the Capcom Cup finals from 2017 Mena and
tokido right there in our loser semis up
in the winners finals of course Angry
Bird versus Punk a battle of the homies
really angry bird and punk so I got some
Intel from the homie Range man shout out
to renja they played two first to fives
as soon as they got to Las Vegas I Angry
Bird won the first one I believe 5-2 and
punk won the second set five four I
think you're right yeah I saw a bunch of
those sets when they they first landed
there was a stream from two birds which
is great I highly recommend checking out
their streams fgc underscore birds and I
think like basically everybody in this
top six streams actually I've watched
all of their streams so check them out
if you're looking for some action but
yeah they were really really good sets I
encourage everybody to check them out
there's some like Sonic Fox Angry Bird
sets on there too and then they had to
play in tournament which is pretty funny
we talked about hitani Mena and they
have to play in tournament again what I
love is that all of them were like I'm
in this bracket this weekend against you
I'll play you anyway that's a fact man
nobody's ducking man but look before we
go to this break man let's just throw it
over to cap jams for the ones man the
last time give it up it shows the love
to them guys man they are looking so
cool up there ready to play these jams
but we're gonna take a quick break
we'll be right back with some more
Street Fighter six top six
[Music]
I feel like I'm all alone
friends
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
visit chipotle.com sf6 for detail
you got this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
be
best
it's dangerous
these are incredible steaks
forced to make Split Second decisions
that could cost you your life get out
whether you like it or not you are in
this race
these small based on a true story
reading PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
thank you
PlayStation
hahaha
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to Evolution
2023 there was over 7
000 people for Street Fighter 6. we are
down to four and it is time for our
winners finals of our very first Street
Fighter 6 top six here at Evo man and
what a top four we have let's take a
look of course you sold them the boys on
the on the stream just now on the stage
Angry Bird versus Punk cannot wait I
feel like that's gonna be like the next
Saga of Street Fighter these guys are
gonna be seeing each other a lot more
down the pipeline so I'm excited for
that and of course we got the classic as
you mentioned the Capcom cup I think it
was 2016 was it 2017 17 okay yes finals
Mena Rd versus tokido man these are some
dream matches I am not upset at this top
four hell the whole top six was
beautiful the whole 7 000 was beautiful
right yeah yeah these matches have been
so good all weekend like I think it's
wild that we we are not done with this
top six right but that tokido kakadusa
is like already in all time right that
was so good already and then that high
Tony medicine was wild too and this one
I mean it's gonna be a wild one I'm
really excited to watch Angry Birds Punk
these two have looked so clean all
weekend I feel like they've looked
Unstoppable almost right so it's finally
time for them to butt heads here in
winners final of the tournament over 7
000 people already out and we have R4 up
there on the stage very very impressive
to them of course we're making it and
appreciate everybody who answered the
tournament whether you got 7 000 place
or you're in the top six here that's a
lot of Gamers to show up and play in our
very first Street Fighter 6 here at Evo
tell a tape between these two the tail
of the tape you're right it is it does
sound pretty good right for real man uh
the throwback man of course yo Punk is
old Smiles they both look happy listen
hey don't be fooled by Angry Bird he's
creeping me out right now but I'm
telling you right now that's a happy
fellow okay that's his happy face right
there that is yeah he's smiling right
there like big smile and that's his face
that's how he looks but yeah actually
very sweet I don't know if any you've
talked about it for a bunch of the same
thing with me every time I talk to him
he's always super nice to talk to he's
really really clever about the game in
and out and he's always got a lot of
interesting stuff to say I love talking
to him about the game so it's very very
cool to see both of them here look at
their Evo appearances 2018 2017 Punk had
that breakout year 2017 and these two
are so good Capcom cup finalists many
time between the two of them as well
obviously been on this stage many times
for punk I see him laughing on the
camera right now they're on stage these
two are game and of course we're gonna
go down to Li Joe right before our
winners finals here at Evo
everyone in the house can you hear me
[Applause]
you guys have been getting high for
Chipotle yet have we not
you guys have been getting really high
for tripolia have we not
thank you very much want you all to know
besides this wonderful backpack that you
see right here that's been giving up
give it up for the backpack
[Applause]
you guys still have an opportunity to
win a free burrito or a free ball I want
you all to take out your cell phone to
put them in the air quick take out your
cell phones put them in the air
up top all right I like it everyone's
cell phone out all right now look at
your cell phone and I want you all to
text SMA
828 and that is going to go to 888-222
the code should be right down here oh
look at that right down here somewhere
SMA 828 to 888-222
and if any of you want a free burrito I
want you to take a picture with me and
your phone
that you won the free burrito or a ball
do we got a deal
got one we'll take a picture later he
won one see it's real we got another one
we got another one
[Applause]
all right all right I owe you guys a lot
of pigs I'll meet you outside after
Grand finals yeah stay Jam yeah it's
take it away guys let's go
Joe you are the man of the people you
know how many pictures your kneecaps or
ankles are gonna hurt but it's all for
the culture I promise you we all love
you so we do take those that time out to
talk to the people okay he's like the
mayor yes yes he's like the mayor of Eva
at this point he runs around does
everything I love Li Joe as the host
because he's just happy to be here you
can't ask for anything better right he
actually just loves his job
I like how Bob Marley talking to uh
to Angry Bird like hey man do you like
El Pastor you're an El pasore fan you
got to get a bowl white rice black beans
fajitas corn guac lettuce of course
those are the Staples get the hot salsa
I like how they had a little pep talk
man how was your day today man you know
I was just eating Chipotle
in the top six
casual conversation but now all of that
goes to the side who will will earn that
right to go to the grand finale we start
right now yeah punk so far has not lost
the game this Evo just for reference
here in this Winter's finals Angry Bird
on the other side has looked extremely
offensive extremely solid every
interaction he is all aggro and they're
running over a lot of these players as
we see an early pick up there from Punk
into the corner and this is where he
starts this is where he cooks honestly
this is how he beats the best players in
the world yeah the good old walk down
that's it he successfully won the
neutral now the question is how is he
going to open them up beautiful stuff
there from Angry Bird with the
counterpol just against the pressure no
open up but at least you push yourself
out the corner yeah look at Ken's Corner
carry all the way close to Coast
will be category five throw Loop cereal
Punk with the jab stack trying to get
out drive Gage in trouble so a drive
Rush put him in Burnout the time the
timing and it was right in the middle of
that oh she doesn't get a completion
here for a kill and punk you know he's
churning right here waiting for a dragon
lash waiting for something got a whip
and he finds it for the punish counter
and a pickup with the target combo
I like the attempt from Angry Bird to
just wake up with low calorie just so
you know psych out punk you know Punk
looking probably for reversal or a throw
exactly all right here we go we got that
zone don't want to really throw
Fireballs we're gonna have to condition
them that spin knuckle is available so
you're a little bit of checkmate
a little Miss time there on the throw on
the pressure so it gets back under the
corner nice I like The Roundhouse into
the far just crashing medium punch a
buffer under the drive
[Music]
we interrupt the interrupt oh my God no
ants here from Angry Birds very rare but
good fight now has level three available
ladies and gentlemen it's that drive
game so I always appreciate when you're
when you use that CA real early oh yeah
and it's very close to a throw killing
right here right so good position to be
punk though now in CA Oh I like it every
single color right there green into the
red immediately just catch them off our
drivers drive impact that's my son calls
it Crayola rocks yeah when I like the
back that's trying to be to throw that
watch I've been arrested
more dive kicks now
let's go
wow you saw that that's a plan right
there yep gotcha from moving forward I
like it buffer punish but a little too
far for the crouching medium punch oh my
God Punk is looking Snappy that's like
the best cross cut you can get right on
the cross-up tattoo it's like guaranteed
really man Angry Birds and stuff like
four times he's still does Dragon Eyes
like he cannot be just waited for
impressive okay with Jack standing here
snow we're looking for the shimmy Stan
Pierce
bro babe picks up a clean combo after
Punk one hit away here with his level
three yeah one low forward for sure a
low forward and a dream a counter poke
and a dream oh he tried it but God met
with the Stan jab level two that's what
I would have done every Ken M player in
the building would have done that
question is does Punk wake up but oh he
wakes up level three and a block damn it
did a lot of tip but still to kill Angry
Bird puts the first bit of damage on
Punk's perfect record so far here at Evo
that's true First Blood remember these
guys played in some uh some sets before
all of this went down he made probably
on a Friday night not too short but
regardless that's in the past this is
the present nice Snipes are walking back
now we get the knock down throw
conditioning
man that's how we saw the start of the
last round too game one round one
similar spot side swap for you for the
pickup
we're gonna do it all right we're gonna
reversal now I smell it no try to jump
out you're riding economy enough to link
off that job
the heavy Bunch right into the standing
jab pick up oh and there it is he tried
that last round and missed it stuff on
the driver finds the punish counter dive
kick over those crushing medium kicks
double digit numbers on that punish down
up back throw good technical
locked down I love the tap with the end
of The Crossing medium kick Punk
shutting down those options not enough
he saved the level one and he finds the
jumping light kick
greedy with the meter but it paid off oh
let's go I want to be biased but I can't
all right knock down early on Raw throw
no he delayed the Crouch and face was a
little too far from the garage to Jab
oh no answer maybe that dummy heavy one
from Canon is just so high it's really
difficult fans here sometimes yeah it's
nice out like the delay DVS right yeah
which is what most people do because
it's like it's a good way to answer oh
no whip punish Angry Birds taking
advantage might spend that level three
yeah get rid of the drive gauge
respect that early on gonna have that
drive gauge opportunity to be nice and
healthy punk though however bleeding a
little bit
wow look how much that took that took
half the reactions that is a proper
finish Angry Bird stop uh as soon as
that hip Punk already was taking a drink
gotta do it
yeah try to let it rip didn't find a
good spot and now he drive rushes
forward lots of offense early it's been
a lot of Drive gauge though
you see the like the plays on the kicks
yeah the trail close enough nice I got
the jab Crossing medium punch he's a
little too far for that last time wow
the whip punished
the jump back while that hit I'm so
surprised that was so good that's not
that's probably like a thing like
they've known each other right yeah
they're gonna get that money that fade
away jump heavy kick so far it just gets
that Medium kick into the Target right
out there
oh both buffering some lights here wow
sidekick was so far away still connected
an up back from anger bird he's done
that a lot
waiting for something else maybe not
ready
okay let me get that we're on a low
forward in a dream range right here for
Angry Bird and we got a level two that
is guaranteed finish I like that from
Punk a whole lot of nothing his way he's
trying to find that opportunity
being patient not even trying to antire
he want to stay on his feet all the Dome
that could have been a level no actually
I'm not too sure but what I do know is
he's gonna get hit with the ca
this is big here too it's a guess for
the game now huge damage on this still
in Burnout near to the corner so driving
Pack's a little scary as well doesn't
let it rip just yet you know he's
buffering
scary Spa pressure from Punk Angry Bird
puts him in Burnout now
wow that was so smart there for Punk the
back that spin knuckle
I like to transition into the trophy
like I don't know who's gonna win here
but somebody's gonna take it I Punk did
a little Birdman hands right after going
nice and warm fan this time an early
start from Angry Bird down on dry Gage
because of it
somebody gotta potentially deal with
Mena and Tokyo are you sure that loses
back and look at gnarly
wow wake up media punch you feel like
that yeah beats the Stagger attempts
right
but you got to be that confident you
gotta be sure yeah that's a good reason
that is you got to be ready oh whiff
yeah side swap that's the privilege
right oh it just gets flipped meaty try
to hit a button or throw something down
so this is high level right here and
it's only about month two stop
and catch those low forwards I like the
back after Proctor too I think he's
waiting nicely speaks himself nicely to
Perry yeah no Drive uh impact wall
splash
oh dry brush of course all right
standing heavy the classic
level three no he didn't have the ball
went for the safe jump would have been a
little safe of course it'd be neutral
Tech but he back recovered yeah
background was really good against safe
jumps in the middle of the screen for
sure
Punk one hit away again level three
locked and loaded Phantom reversal crap
it goes so far to catch that walk back
I love the wide shorts are doing to the
Run DP into the ca that way he don't
lose the court off with a dragon latch
that was pretty good yeah and you put
him in the corner right and get that
extra space he walked up nothing
huge meter advantage
to hit the brakes with the stand jab
after the drivers that was actually
excellent oh Punk can't lock here he
gets put in Burnout yeah he might just
rip the super no he wakes up Jazz
that was high level he was ready for it
oh no way that two-piece
Angry Bird goes up two to one here
so he's getting hit with the driver's
Jazz right it's stuffing either a Crouch
or jab or a low forward but it looks
like Buck is trying to uh you know
probably react to it a little too late
but the range that he's doing is
standing jab I feel like it's stuffing
out the local time yeah oh he's looking
for that that's counter hit only stand
like kick driver's standing medium punch
from Canada
we are spending cash early trying to get
that Advantage right push to the corner
gets off him nice jab check that stop
sign from Punk
something
this is the only person we've seen so
far our Punk can't slow him down right
he can't stop the drivers to the dash is
the offense wow scary spot rip that
Dragon latch almost caught the recovery
that crushing medium punch get that good
old-fashioned combo the loop take
advantage of that hit Advantage into the
throw after the gym right that was
pretty good unhand me woman who was fine
thanks for trying to almost confirm oh
great project here jumping and then dab
buffer wow so good everyone has level
two here yeah
remember technically jazz in this game
with the attention to Zan keep of course
it does not have plus frames right so if
you wait for like a three hidden change
you can always take your turn back you
know and that buffer right after the
drivers is really good yep he's doing
extension he's gonna combo so it's that
point here for Angry Bird to try to make
it all the way into that grand finals
winter side
they are swinging yeah and I think that
favors Angry Birds to be honest with you
oh stand short yes the conversion
and he rested he gets out of there
that's a big one Punk yeah he's trying
to wait for the drive gauge finds the
hit cleans It Up level one to try and
get the kill it's enough
we need cash for Angry Bird in the next
round I understand yeah great jump back
on that Dragon line so he was trying to
retreat get rid of that drive gauge
early hit that Angry Bird into the
corner Punk's gonna start making some
guesses opening Gambit walk up low
forward that's confidence oh I like it
the way punk changes offensive and the
adjustment from Angry Birds
who caught the jump back there
everybody's gonna do between strings ex
reversal wow he left that Dragon Last
Breath too nice stuff again pump ready
this time
next I could do it very scary man
harassing him and now burnout fades it
walks back level three easy peasy just
like that we are going to a game five in
our winners finals
and I wouldn't want it any other way
these guys are putting on an amazing
show in front of this capacity crowd
right here Evo talk to us you loving
that
foreign
way to cross the street and there you go
he's out of there
oh I like that little walk back clean
and he got the punish counter so stand
like taking to the Gin ride man the
respect on the stand Fierce off of the
drive Rush is definitely shown here
that's why you see pumpkins like you
know what you're gonna have to throw me
bro I'm not touching
that's exactly what was on the blueprint
nice
okay let's see Punk looking for the
chimney no dice
this time stop the driver and it's like
Drive Rush the drivers doesn't work
Angry Birds like cool I'll drive us or
do dragon Lance right after catch below
punished the crouching Jazz of course
Parker's just looking for the text for
the checks on the dash
I like that idea yeah he didn't want to
get it thrown again Spencer bar has the
level three that should be the Kill
Angry Bird is moving into our grand
finals winners side over a punk that was
optimal for that much life you ended
with the ex excuse me op old part of me
the OD medium kick genre that's what
leads into that combo very nice very
efficient I like that fucker's not even
beating himself up that was a great
match this is a hard opponent to deal
with Angry Bird definitely one of the
best players in the business not even
mad at that man Grand finals what an
opportunity for Angry Birds I kind of
like it right like she's about a five
Big Bird Grand finals now we got angry
bird and Grand finals that's pretty cool
true yeah paper was in that grand finals
up against BonChon yeah yeah that was a
wild one that the Eagles fight heard
around the world
oh man some good old-fashioned street
fighter man yeah it's been good so far
and angry but I have to say the thing I
love about him is he's willing to do
drivers to have driver's job check you
and then Punk sitting there like I'm
gonna check it when he does it right
he's waiting and then he just lets the
dragon lash with or he just starts
walking up checking with buttons and
other stuff like that he does a really
good job of rotating all of his really
strong options and just being like are
you ready for all this can you handle
option A B C D Etc all of this at the
same time and punk normally is someone
who can but you know against some of the
best in the world is very difficult but
yeah one thing that was uh you know I
was thinking about a lot about this set
was the uses of Drive Rush from Angry
Bird yeah and he always clip Punk trying
to uh he's always pick up with a
standing jab right but I think it was
more so because if I'm trying to check
the dashes all the time so he like hit
the brakes from that range you know I
mean obviously the jab comes out faster
than the low forward right so
what was probably cried today but either
I feel like he used that for the sense
of just to to snipe out his uh check
attempt on the driveway yeah because
most people are doing like Drive version
to a medium or a heavy right and it's so
much slower so the timing to do the
early jab is a really smart choice as
you mentioned right there he played that
really well and again you saw how Punk
has looked against everybody else so far
so that set was a nail biter close one
three two and that sets up punk down
there and losers finals playing the
winner of Mena and tokido those are the
three right there that I think a lot of
people talk about as being you know the
best in the last games era and all three
of them have to fight each other to see
who gets the chance against Angry Bird
and Grand finals yeah it's a bit of
leader leaders of the new school
featuring tokido I'm gonna be honest
with you
know and I'm pretty sure he just has
nothing but smiles on his face but right
now this match is a bit of a lore match
here of course you mentioned a 2017
Capcom Cup Championship right Mena
versus tokido men of course took that
but I could only imagine that tokido's
just thinking about that every single
day now let me not say that but you know
it means something here they're about to
play each other again in a new game
fresh Street Fighter right so let's
let's uh etch our history in the books
and you mentioned you know the
difference in experience right like Mana
first Evo obviously way back in 2017.
six evos since then and then 19 for
tokido he's been to so many oh my
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I gotta go watch that footage again
man but that's that that's the best but
look um just to touch up a little bit on
the history with these two besides cam
Cup in terms of
coming together as one to learn how to
play fighting games this is a prime
example of that I'm talking about men as
I hate man I want to come to Japan
what's up taquitos like you're more than
welcome pull up and they just chilling
and playing video games and just enjoy
enjoying each other's presence you know
learning of each other's uh you know
cultures exactly which is pretty cool I
was gonna say that's the cool thing the
reason they can do that fun stared on is
that these two are competitors but
they're also friends Mana goes out to
Japan and it's like yo tukito whatever
I'm trying to play everybody I'm trying
to eat good food I'm trying to hang out
and he'll go out there and stay in
tokido and all these people they host
them right so he is somebody who you
know they had that match in 2017 and you
know it's easy as you say to be like
Rivals and be like yeah I gotta beat
that guy but men is like dude I'm gonna
come to Japan I'm trying to train I want
to play everybody no sandbagging no like
dodging and I'm trying to play everybody
and be as good as I can so this is what
I I think of these two they are like
model professionals right they are
people who want to be the absolute best
they're not trying to do it like in a
shortcut way they're like I'm gonna play
and train with everybody in the world to
be as good as I can be and that builds a
friendship between them yeah man
oh
[Applause]
the loop leblanca he's thinking about
which one he wants to play here
the crowd cheering for that Blanca doing
it for the people Mena Rd said I'm
rocking like are you sure he said are
you sure you saw he locked in he like
hit it
let's go Blanca
let's hit him with the oh I can't do
that voice
it's over
you know I'm glad you enjoyed it yeah
you saw how Blanca was looking at kid
did you hear the people yeah he said
what's that all about yeah
yo oh this is lore at its finest stop
Blanca and loser semis of Evo by the way
character that one CEO for men obviously
he played a lot of Luke as well because
Blanca is so good yeah
that button is very good hard to punish
running spaced out like that
we see the gaps yes that brain traps get
exposed by reversals nice electricity
activates and a throw is perfect Harry
is a very common response there because
a lot of players will hop through try to
get left right
so that's what separates a lot of
blances right when you do a heavy Blanca
ball from Beyond sweet range yeah those
are the hardest ones to react to right
oh yeah nice I like the beat there
Amanda taking the scoop and the slide
for Okie try Rush overhead and they pick
up there very nicely done on that first
round feel that overhead look like it's
a thousand Springs
oh
that's everybody bottom brick
I like it I like the spacing for men and
neutral have been really good so far
crouching medium punch a great poke
cancelable you can get driver's comments
off this level two I like he's in a
Parry here oh we install it now
you can extend we Perry
shut up
that doesn't activate it he gets double
rolling here he gets triple rolling here
excuse me that'll be 3.99. that'll be
3.99. cross up stays in the front goes
low and Mena with game one here
[Applause]
that'll be 3.99 please do you need a bag
you gonna get that to go yeah wow oh but
Amelia looks like they played a lot of
sets on the low oh yeah yeah I bet they
still played already for sure oh and you
get a combo yep I'm loving the space
that he's doing it too yeah yeah it's
hard to do it doesn't take the slide I
don't think he wanted to spend the drive
cage though I agree I agree with you on
that oh he tried sweep a little too late
um yep get the better oh boy
that's big damage anything that's a fair
starter from Kenneth especially on
punish count It's Gonna Hurt You are
going to pay them oh drop it take one
now not a lot of try again unless the
drive impact ribs
DB inside now nicely done tokido a
little scrambly there but I kind of like
that he was thriving in the scramble
that's what you got to do against Blanca
sometimes yep but again tokidos is
trying to figure out a way to smother uh
Menace Blanca that way just she just
won't have no space for nothing the only
thing I feel like he's gonna have to
look forward uh for is when uh when he
says throw loops and they just want to
jump back and do a rainbow ball yeah
yeah the air balls cheap air balls he's
so strong yeah
Plus on block it activates Blanco dolls
when you're in level two which is really
strong too hold the Jack Fireballs those
are the classics yeah he tried to slide
under right there and he was just a
little late so sokita gets to pick up to
the corner
um
or something
negative three but it's all right take
your turn back we activate we install
this does the medium kick after activate
in the middle of the screen
maybe Parry into electricity
no it doesn't go for it yet that stays
on screen for a long time so he doesn't
feel pressured yet
those is a classic we're coming fast
enough you could probably follow it a
little bit you know get some pressure
going
on a little three-piece right into the
ca level three there rather for tokido I
open up a game of peace I wonder if Mana
sticks it out here
yeah we'll think about it here yeah
that's me that's right
I'm kind of with you I do wonder if
that's the plan here I'm curious
what a handsome fellow
goddamn rhyme goddamn right
all right we gotta think about it we got
the notes
I appreciate that look that's the
professional I don't blame you tokido
respects it yeah and he's locked right
back in oh from the Raptors top of the
Mandalay Bay
wow
after the Hop anyway you could do light
kick you do throw oh a little too far
that back medium kicking whip on
crouchers from farther away nice buffer
yeah I like the shimmy itself that's
what he was looking for wasn't crouching
jab not even a throw oh wow oh my God
that's the number one for the pickup on
that good to know that the damage might
not have been enough on something else
even if it was just spend it yeah cash
out we'll try to get that perfect pair
you can't drive Rush after that and get
a good uh a solid punish yeah the most
important thing is take the corner carry
nicely done tokido finds that little
whiff category five oh good read into
the different that was awesome for yo
clip that oh clip that down he's got if
you got a plan for that you're ready for
Blanco all right yeah I like I like it
it's amazing it is stolen it is stolen
it's AJ oh my God he definitely should
have prepared nice I like that it's only
slightly negative so it's not a bad idea
I left it rip he gets the setup off this
with the doll
[Applause]
beautiful with the cuticles yeah he saw
it
oh no Auntie at that time though tokido
gets away with it and unless the
overhead rip I like to jump forward from
Minna activate good driver's combo is
the heavy punch here yeah
oh set up the doll yeah oh he let it rip
that is a lot of damage and a lot of
fried game damage on this too
that's gonna hurt ow welcome to standing
roundhouse no not even we're trying to
check it you know what smart move for
men a good reaction now he's a little
helped in the drive game gotta be
careful his level one goes full screen
here while he's an install so tokido if
he throws another Fireball he's gonna
he's trying to beat him the super oh my
God that would have been that would have
been a yes yes
okay not a factor anymore
can you get the plus frame regardless I
respect that you do it
we gotta check out we gotta check out
here spend the cash an eye for an eye
and also good good knowledge of coquito
win Blanca is in level two install his
level one super goes full screen so you
have to know that you can't just throw
Fireballs for free like that
you see how he's like sitting behind oh
yeah I like it that purple Vision I like
he wants to see
same thing again
out of the corner
so keto Drive gauge is taking a beating
by the way it is it is in trouble he's
trying to jump back trying to avoid any
kind of pressure and here he gets
stopped in front of the few jumpings
that beats out what a challenge oh we've
seen the gaps in the Gin ride you can OD
in between them nice activates I'm a
little uh went the wrong way level one
not enough for Burnout but a fireball
will do it so man it's got a jump wow
lovely air ball I thought he said that I
was gonna do like a rookie beat but gets
hit anyway good stuff tokido we're gonna
challenge all right oh yeah and that
ball if you do jump a heavy ball there's
a lot of recovery on that too I just
called it yeah the handshake off yeah
Tokyo's feeling it up there
dry brush
yes plus frames trying to clip a walking
back good defense here for men a great
defense
yeah yeah very nice so that's okay
he's ready for it oh shaking him shaking
his behind good read on the throw
attemptive jump back ball
and I'm just waiting for that drive
gauge to come back now he can drive rush
and he's not gonna be in Burnout
oh finds a punish counter not enough
though tokido you know Dragon lash or
dry brush is on the mine for sure oh I
thought he's gonna look forward scary
range standing medium punch check on him
those looking for the cover on the low
forward level two I promise you that
yeah and I only have a chip is a big
Factory here for tokido I think h-bomb
might be close to shipping but we
activate Jan's gone
oh
[Applause]
no man a little drop there from tokido
that ball was very punishable light and
medium ball are so punishable but
sometimes you forget because heavy
Ball's safe that's right man it's a
visual cue right man that's tough man
you can talk about the noise too which
is another big factor wow
you can do that I did not know that I
didn't either meta great knowledge he
can drive us to extend here no chooses
to go for the football yeah he's blowing
drive game I like that
Perry he doesn't do the second fall of
the pizza that's very smart good bait oh
I love this Ken protein give me more
please yeah you want more
here you go
look at that from stomach to Chin that's
crazy all the way up to big one needed
to get out of there out of meter oh
finds it not a combo though a lot of
Drive gauge down I think he's trying to
beat the Perry right there Middle with a
little bit of install left but not much
better respect for one to OD as well
look like he tried to react to the DP
that's pretty it's hard when it's that
close yeah oh guarding that doll it
doesn't go away until the screen it
takes a while or it's on the screen off
the screen oh my God maybe try to jump
there keeping the pressure tight I like
it from tokido another Dragon Lash
apiece
umido's face
yeah yeah he's ready
you could hit the plastic when he's
tricking the water
the crying yeah yeah yeah that was good
breathe in breathe out
back the character select that for Mena
peeping the phone thinking about it here
he obviously has another character but
do you want to go to it on game five
here elimination point in top floor of
Evo this guy is serious tokido is a god
amongst men same thing for men r d it's
a top level class Street Fighter six Evo
excuse me
yeah yeah there we go let's keep going
on the show going I had to shut the hell
up
you know what I'll wait after the match
they love their yes they love it thanks
for not skipping the intro everybody on
top six here we go last match for these
two former Capcom Cup finals
Evo champ Capcom cup champ a lot of
accolades between these two nice bait
there from zokido and this one the
momentum wheel starts right here the
snowball oh it wasn't ready let it rip
yeah I had to see it's getting laid and
he does it again I like it from Mena
rainbow all the way out of there wow
just to shave off the drive Gage I
respect that here for tokido one
Challenge and a punish good awareness
there for a minute he knew and he was
ready for the slide but a little late on
that it's hard at that range
nicely not those cancel on a ball but
men are doing a good job fighting in
this burnout he's almost out
[Applause]
one more game and he goes to the
spectator to see
we'll have to see here no stop and yeah
they come back immediately just has to
see regular throw he is not afraid of
the reversals even though tokido's done
it a lot yeah that's true exactly
your mind says Blanca wow
those poke those the pope class
there he hasn't checked the driver as
much but definitely been pretty good on
that stuff
oh he's gonna land yeah he's got the
punish nice it was like a smidget
plus yeah it's okay challenge after
far enough on the anti-ever goes for the
standings I respect that we've seen the
Swiss cheese
burnout chips a big problem here too
heavy ball is gonna hurt but you know
men is he's a little confident right he
doesn't want to over commit on the
offense and the big thing in this range
is whether tokido would jump forward or
not too
it's not gonna over extend
it's the sneaky Fireballs okay yeah he's
gonna try again Meadow is really passive
during that he didn't want to over
commit
was a punish counter
I'm back man I was playing so cautious
he really doesn't want to overextend but
that's giving tokido a little bit of
room here chances to think about it
right
at the CH from California bro
it's enough to kill just like that final
game final round between these two
oh my God look at look at the space look
at the respect
no anti-air but the jump is with so
that's okay now we Mount offense let's
install please
oh he goes down he's trying to beat the
Perry Taquito does not let it rip no
Perry no super none of that
the respect showing on the low fold is
why that drag flash is lasting so it's
Landing so much unblocked yeah you're
right interesting he was trying to catch
a button or something like that and that
doesn't let it rip mana's install almost
out this level two almost completely
gone with no offense from it
all right come on welcome him down
though yeah he's a lot of space although
the heavy ball whipping is a big deal
there tokido all his Drive gauge back
and he has full resources it's gonna be
tough all right he's getting a little
too comfortable with these Fireballs but
I know Mana doesn't want to take the
risk and go for the slide or there's a
knock down we close the perfect Barry
got solid damage I love it you get a
nice little Oaky with the standing fish
good reaction ready this time but he was
gonna press because of the dry feet he
tried to do the slide I like the idea it
doesn't work oh my God all right there's
nothing up on there he's got level one
also bulletin burnout here tried to fade
it didn't buy it he blocks oh my God
electricity win oh my God
I don't think it would have reached
though oh my God he's got another suit
for the install two in one round
the Rd
he takes out so keto and loses Sammy's
burrito through the collapse on the
level two the awareness for that combo
listen man Round of Applause I don't
even got to say the names you know who's
on the stage right now
of applause
amazing match oh my God yo everything
like all right everything worked out
overheads landed but it was out of range
there was just a lot of situations but
you just couldn't get the full
punishment and that just created so many
cinematic cinematics for me yeah I mean
that map is out of control that was one
of the best matches I've seen in any
game ever that was so close and you know
now he's got a chance against Punk can
we all everybody here at Mandalay Bay
can you all make some noise for the Evo
Champion one of the greatest competitors
to ever do it tokido
that is a fact go look at the wikipedias
my friend that is a great w but you know
what makes this win even sweeter not
even that was tokido he did it for the
people the people you see talk to the
people say hey man who y'all want Blanca
you sure you're really sure you did that
for the crowd here the Crouch here for
Blanca he picked Blanca and that's why
he got the W there very impressive man
man his situational Awareness on Luke
earlier was so impressive right but the
situational awareness there on Blanca
was Unreal having the up all there to
the double extension was ridiculous and
then little things like the jab another
slide he just has these Great Moments
where you're like how does he know
everything in every scenario and what to
do you know yeah the situation
situational awareness man these guys is
at the highest of levels and this guy is
chilling yo man how you doing baby
My Man Thumbs Up thumbs up he's feeling
good
Sky though good luck down there champ he
plays by the way with no headphones in
this Arena so the crowd he really feels
it which is one of those things that I
love but uh yeah here's some of the
highlights from the match
my heart can't take any more of these
that was a good one I gotta say just
this nail biter here yo now okay let me
let me look at this real quick so if he
blocks a fireball I just want to know
just for a reference because then I
could probably snipe out why he had so
much bar for the uh for the insole yeah
he built yeah level two and then he had
a level two again man I cannot believe
he recognized he had the level two here
I love that Taquito recognizes that I
don't know if the ca would have reached
if he hit that gin ride yeah and then
right here just
that yeah it does not usually lose the
drive impact there like that man getting
the three piece on the Blanca ball there
the awareness was so so good it's one of
those things is when you bounce like
that with the ball normally Drive Impact
with but you can also when you have the
install just do the extension go over
right so you can just beat it like that
really smart for minnow right there and
uh impressive to switch between two
characters at a high level like this in
top six of an event really hard to do
he's up against Punk next which leads to
have played each other many times
obviously two incredible players people
you know everybody knows these are two
of the best players in the last game and
I'm sure two of the best players in this
game's lifespan for sure right I mean
looking very impressive here so to my
understanding this will be our final
break before we close out Eva